data has evolved in the last decade like
never before and currently data
generation has increased by leaps and
bounds
and all this data is collectively termed
as big data
businesses require big data engineers
who can handle this data and big data
engineers do this with the help of
frameworks like hadoop and spark on that
note hi everyone welcome to this video
on big data engineer full course
in this video we will help you
understand how you can become a big data
engineer and we will also cover the
fundamentals of big data hadoop and
spark we'll begin this full course by
understanding how to become a big data
engineer
we will then understand the top skills
required for big data jobs here we will
also take a close look at other top job
roles in the big data domain we will
then understand big data analytics
and understand how big data is used
across several domains by learning a few
crucial big data applications
we will then gain a deeper understanding
of big data its evolution and its
challenges
following which we will learn about
hadoop and how it solves big data
problems
we will also take an individual look at
components of hadoop like hdfs mapreduce
and yarn
we will also be learning about scope
high pig and hedge base the next topic
we will be covering is spark here we
will understand the architecture of
spark and look at spark streaming
finally we will conclude this full
course by looking into a set of top
hadoop interview questions and answers
so let's start off with our full course
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn today i am going to
tell you how you can become a big data
engineer now it should come as no
surprise for you guys to know that
organizations generate as well as use a
whole lot of data this vast volume of
data is called big data companies use
big data to draw meaningful insights and
take business decisions and big data
engineers are the people who can make
sense out of this enormous amount of
data now let's find out who is a big
data engineer a big data engineer is a
professional who develops maintains
tests and evaluates the company's big
data infrastructure in other words
develop big data solutions based on a
company's requirements they maintain
these solutions they test out these
solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with the various tools and
systems of the organization and finally
they evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of etl or the extract transform load
process and they need to research as
well as propose new ways to acquire data
improve the overall data quality and the
efficiency of the system now to ensure
that all the business requirements are
met they need to build a suitable data
architecture they need to be able to
integrate several programming languages
and tools together so that they can
generate a structured solution they need
to build models that reduce the overall
complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system by mining data from
various sources and finally they need to
work well with other teams ones that
include data architects data analysts
and data scientists next up let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
big data solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages i can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice practice and more
practice some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for big data
engineering are python java and c-plus
plus the second skill that you require
is to have in-depth knowledge about dbms
and sql you need to know how data is
maintained as well as managed in a
database you need to know how sql can be
used to transform as well as perform
actions on a database and by extension
know how to write sql queries for any
relational database management systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for big data
engineering mysql rackle database and
the microsoft sql server the third skill
that you require is to have experience
working with etl and warehousing tools
now you need to know how to construct as
well as use a data warehouse so that you
can perform the etl operation or the
extract transform and load operations
now as a big data engineer you'll be
constantly tasked with extracting
unstructured data from a number of
different sources transforming it into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages databases or
data warehouses now what this is is
basically aggregating unstructured data
from multiple sources analyzing it so
that you can take better business
decisions some of the tools used for
this purpose are talent ibm data stage
pentaho and informatica next up we have
the fourth skill that you require which
is knowledge about operating systems now
since most big data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like linux and unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by big data
engineers are unix linux and solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with hadoop based analytics
since hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to big data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with apache
hadoop based technologies technologies
like hdfs hadoop mapreduce apache h-base
hive and pig the sixth skill that you
require is to have worked with real-time
processing frameworks like apache spark
now as a big data engineer you'll have
to deal with vast volumes of data so for
this data you need an analytics engine
like spark which can be used for
large-scale real-time data processing
now spark can process live streaming
data from a number of different sources
like facebook instagram twitter and so
on it can also perform interactive
analysis and data integration and now
we're at our final skill requirement
which is to have experience with data
mining and modeling so as a data
engineer you'll have to examine massive
pre-existing data so that you can
discover patterns as well as new
information with this you will create
predictive models for your business so
that you can make better informed
decisions some of the tools used for
this are r rapidminer weka and name now
let's talk about a big data engineer's
salary as well as other roles they can
look forward to now the average salary
of a big data engineer in the united
states is approximately ninety thousand
dollars per year now this ranges from
sixty six thousand dollars all the way
to hundred and thirty thousand dollars
per annum in india the average salary is
around seven lakh rupees and ranges from
four lakhs to 13 lakhs per annum after
you've become a big data engineer some
of the job roles that you can look
forward to are that of a senior big data
engineer a business intelligence
architect and a data architect now let's
talk about certifications that a big
data engineer can opt for first off we
have the cloudera ccp data engineer a
cloudera certified professional data
engineer possesses the skills to develop
reliable and scalable data pipelines
that result in optimized data sets for a
variety of workloads it is one of the
industry's most demanding performance
based certification ccp evaluates and
recognizes a candidate's mastery of the
technical skills most sought after by
employers the time limit for this exam
is 240 minutes and it costs 400 next we
have the ibm certified data architect
big data certification an ibm certified
big data architect understands the
complexity of data and can design
systems and models to handle different
data variety including structured
semi-structured unstructured volume
velocity veracity and so on a big data
architect is also able to effectively
address information governance and
security challenges associated with the
system this exam is 75 minutes long and
finally we have the google cloud
certified data engineer a google
certified data engineer enables data
driven decision making by collecting
transforming and publishing data they
should also be able to leverage deploy
and continuously train pre-existing
machine learning models the length of
the certification exam is two hours and
its registration fee is 200 now let's
have a look at how simply learn can help
you become a big data engineer
simply learn provides the big data
architect masters program this includes
a number of different courses like big
data hadoop and spark developer apache
spark and scala mongodb developer and
administrator big data and hadoop
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in demand
skills and tools 12 plus real life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per annum it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like kafka apache spark
flume edge base mongodb hive pig
mapreduce java scala and much more now
why don't you head over to
simplylearn.com and get started on your
journey to get certified and get ahead
we all use smartphones but have you ever
wondered how much data it generates in
the form of texts phone calls emails
photos videos searches and music
approximately 40 exabytes of data gets
generated every month by a single
smartphone user
now imagine this number multiplied by 5
billion smartphone users that's a lot
for our mind even process isn't it in
fact this amount of data is quite a lot
for traditional computing systems to
handle and this massive amount of data
is what we term as big data
let's have a look at the data generated
per minute on the internet
2.1 million snaps are shared on snapchat
3.8 million search queries are made on
google one million people log onto
facebook 4.5 million videos are watched
on youtube
188 million emails are sent that's a lot
of data so how do you classify any data
as big data this is possible with the
concept of five v's
volume
velocity
variety
veracity and value
let us understand this with an example
from the healthcare industry hospitals
and clinics across the world generate
massive volumes of data
2314 exabytes of data are collected
annually in the form of patient records
and test results
all this data is generated at a very
high speed which attributes to the
velocity of big data
variety refers to the various data types
such as structured semi-structured and
unstructured data examples include excel
records log files and x-ray images
accuracy and trustworthiness of the
generated data is termed as veracity
analyzing all this data will benefit the
medical sector by enabling faster
disease detection
better treatment and reduced cost
this is known as the value of big data
but how do we store and process this big
data
to do this job we have various
frameworks such as cassandra hadoop and
spark
let us take hadoop as an example
and see how hadoop stores and processes
big data
hadoop uses a distributed file system
known as hadoop distributed file system
to store big data if you have a huge
file your file will be broken down into
smaller chunks and stored in various
machines not only that when you break
the file you also make copies of it
which goes into different nodes this way
you store your big data in a distributed
way and make sure that even if one
machine fails your data is safe on
another
mapreduce technique is used to process
big data a lengthy task a is broken into
smaller tasks
b
c
and d
now instead of one machine three
machines take up each task and complete
it in a parallel fashion and assemble
the results at the end thanks to this
the processing becomes easy and fast
this is known as parallel processing
now that we have stored and processed
our big data we can analyze this data
for numerous applications
in games like halo 3 and call of duty
designers analyze user data to
understand at which stage most of the
users pause restart or quit playing this
insight can help them rework on the
storyline of the game and improve the
user experience
which in turn reduces the customer churn
rate
similarly big data also helped with
disaster management during hurricane
sandy in 2012. it was used to gain a
better understanding of the storm's
effect on the east coast of the u.s and
necessary measures were taken it could
predict the hurricane's landfall five
days in advance which wasn't possible
earlier
these are some of the clear indications
of how valuable big data can be once it
is accurately processed and analyzed
back in the early 2000s there was
relatively less data generated but with
the rise of various social media
platforms and multinational companies
across the globe the generation of data
has increased by leaps and bounds
according to the idc the total volume of
data is expected to reach 175 zettabytes
in 2025 that's a lot of data
so we can define big data as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using the
traditional ways let's now have a look
at the challenges with respect to big
data
the first challenge with big data is its
storage storing big data is not easy as
the data generation is endless in
addition to this storing unstructured
data in our traditional databases is a
great challenge unstructured data refers
to data such as photographs and videos
the second challenge is processing big
data data is only useful to us if it is
processed and analyzed processing big
data consumes a lot of time due to its
size and structure
to overcome these challenges of big data
we have various frameworks such as
hadoop cassandra and spark let us have a
quick look at hadoop and spark
so what is hadoop it is a framework that
stores big data in a distributed way and
processes it parallely how do you think
hadoop does this
well hadoop uses a distributed file
system known as hadoop distributed file
system to store big data if you have a
huge file your file will be broken out
into smaller chunks and stored in
various machines this is why it is
termed as distributed storage
mapreduce is the processing unit of
hadoop here we have multiple machines
working parallelly to process big data
thanks to this technique the processing
becomes easy and fast
let's now move on to spark spark is a
framework that is responsible for
processing data both in batches and in
real time spark is used to analyze data
across various clusters of computers
now that you have understood big data
hadoop and spark let's look into few of
the different job roles in this domain
career opportunities in this field are
limitless as organizations are using big
data to enhance their products business
decisions and marketing effectiveness
so here we will understand in depth as
to how to become a big data engineer in
addition to this we will also look into
the various uh skills required to become
a hadoop developer spark developer and a
big data architect
starting off with a big data engineer
role
do you know who a big data engineer is
well big data engineers are
professionals who develop maintain test
and evaluate a company's big data
infrastructure
they have several responsibilities
firstly they are responsible for
designing and implementing software
systems
they verify and maintain these systems
for the ingestion and processing of data
they build robust systems extract
transform load operations known as the
etl process is carried out by big data
engineers they also research various new
methods to obtain data and improve its
quality
big data engineers are also responsible
for building data architectures that
meet the business requirements they
provide a solution by integrating
various tools and programming languages
in addition to the above
responsibilities their primary
responsibility is to mine data from
plenty of different sources to build
efficient business models lastly they
also work closely with data architects
data scientists and data analysts
those acquire a lot of responsibilities
let us now have a look at the skills
required to achieve these
responsibilities
as you can see on your screens we have
listed the top top seven skills needed
to be possessed by a big data engineer
starting off the essential skill is
programming
a big data engineer needs to have
hands-on experience in any one of the
programming languages such as java
c-plus plus or python
as a big data engineer you should also
have in-depth knowledge of dbms and sql
this is because you have to understand
how data is managed and maintained in a
database hence you need to know how to
write sql queries for any rdbms systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for big data
engineering are mysql oracle database
and the microsoft sql server
as mentioned earlier carrying out an e
carrying out an etl operation is a big
data engineer's responsibility
now you need to know how to construct as
well as use a data warehouse so that you
can perform these etl operations as a
big data engineer you will be
continuously tasked with extracting data
from various sources transforming them
into meaningful information and loading
it into other data storages some of the
tools used for this purpose are talent
ibm data stage pentaho and informatica
next up we have the fourth skill that
you require which is knowledge about
operating systems
big data tools run on operating systems
hence a sound understanding of unix
linux windows and solaris is mandatory
the fifth skill that you require is to
have experience with hadoop based
analytics
since hadoop is one of the most commonly
used big data engineering tools it's
understood that you need to have
experience with apache hadoop based
technologies like hdfs mapreduce apache
pig hive and apache hedge base
the sixth skill that you require is to
have worked with real-time processing
frameworks like apache spark as a big
data engineer you would deal with large
volumes of data so for this you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for both batch and real-time
processing spark can process live
streaming data from several different
sources like facebook instagram twitter
and so on
and now we are at our final skill
requirement which is to have experience
with data mining and data modeling as a
big data engineer you would have to
examine massive pre-existing data so
that you can discover patterns and new
information this will help you create
predictive models that will help you
make various business business decisions
some of the tools used for this are are
rapidminer becca and nime
now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary in the u.s a big data
engineer's average annual salary is
around hundred and two thousand dollars
per annum in india a big data engineer
makes about seven lakh rupees per annum
that was all about our first role big
data engineer moving on to our second
role we have hadoop developer
as the name suggests a hadoop developer
looks into the coding and programming of
the various hadoop applications this job
role is more or less similar to that of
a software developer
moving on to the skills required to
become a hadoop developer at first it is
a knowledge of the hadoop ecosystem a
hadoop developer should have in-depth
knowledge about the hadoop ecosystem and
its components which include hbase pig
scoop flume uzi etc you should also have
data modeling experience with olap and
oltp knowledge of sql is required like a
big data engineer a hadoop developer
must also know popular tools like
pentaho informatica and talent
finally you should also be well versed
in writing pig latin scripts and
mapreduce jobs
the average annual salary of a hadoop
developer in the us is nearly 76
thousand dollars per annum in india a
hadoop developer makes approximately 4
lakh 57 000 rupees per annum
moving to our third job role we have
spark developer
we saw what spark is now let's
understand what a spark developer does
spark developers create spark jobs using
python or scala for data aggregation and
transformation they also write analytics
code and design data processing
pipelines
a spark developer needs to have the
following skills they need to know spark
and its components such as spark core
spark streaming spark machine learning
library etc they should also know the
scripting languages like python or perl
just like the previous job roles a spark
developer should also have basic
knowledge of sql queries and a database
structure
in addition to the above a spark
developer is also expected to have a
fairly good understanding of linux and
its commands
moving to the average annual salary of a
spark developer it is nearly 81 000
dollars per annum in the us in india a
spark developer earns nearly 5 lakh 87
000 rupees per annum
let's now move on to our final job role
that is big data architect
so let's understand who a big data
architect is
well a big data architect is a
professional who is responsible for
designing and planning big data systems
they also manage large-scale development
and deployment of hadoop applications
moving on to the skills required to
become a big data architect first up the
individual must have advanced data
mining and data analysis skills
big data architects should also be able
to implement and use a nosql database
and cloud computing techniques
they must also have an idea of various
big data technologies like hadoop
mapreduce hbase hive and so on
finally big data architects must hold
experience with agile and scrum
frameworks
let's now have a look at the average
annual salary of a big data architect in
the united states and india
in the u.s a big data architect earns a
whopping 118 000 per annum meanwhile in
india a big data architect makes nearly
19 lakh rupees per annum these are huge
numbers right
so now that we have understood the job
roles of a big data engineer hadoop
developer spark developer and a big data
architect let us have a look at the
companies hiring these professionals
as you all can see on your screens we
have ibm amazon american express netflix
microsoft and bosch to name a few
let us now understand why big data
analytics is required with an example so
all of you listen to music online isn't
it here we will take an example of
spotify which is a swedish audio
streaming platform and see how big data
analytics is used here spotify has
nearly 96 plus million users and all
these users generate a tremendous amount
of data data like the songs which are
played repeatedly the numerous likes
shares and the user search history all
these data can be termed as big data
here with respect to spotify have you
ever wondered what spotify does with all
this big data well spotify analyzes this
big data for suggesting songs to its
users i'm sure all of you might have
come across the recommendation list
which is made available to each one of
you by spotify each one of you will have
a totally different recommendation list
this is based on your likes your past
history like the songs you like
listening to and your playlists this
works on something known as the
recommendation system recommendation
systems are nothing but data filtering
tools they collect all the data and then
filter them using various algorithms
this system has the ability to
accurately predict what a user would
like to listen to next with the help of
big data analytics this prediction helps
the users stay on the page for a longer
time and by doing so spotify engages all
its users the users don't have the need
to go on searching for different songs
this is because spotify readily provides
them with a variety of songs according
to their taste well this is how big data
analytics is used by spotify now that we
have understood why big data analytics
is required let us move on to our next
topic that is what is big data analytics
but before that there is another term we
need to understand that is big data we
all hear the term big data many times
but do you know what exactly big data
means well we will understand the term
big data clearly right now big data is a
term for data sets that cannot be
handled by traditional computers or
tools due to their value volume velocity
and veracity it is defined as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using various
traditional methods do you know how much
data is being generated every day every
second even as i talk right now there
are millions of data sources which
generate data at a very rapid rate these
data sources are present across the
world as you know social media sites
generate a lot of data let's take an
example of facebook facebook generates
over 500 plus terabytes of data every
day this data is mainly generated in
terms of your photographs videos
messages etc big data also contains data
of different formats like structured
data semi-structured data and
unstructured data data like your excel
sheets all fall under structured data
this data has a definite format your
emails fall under semi-structured and
your pictures and videos all fall under
unstructured data all these data
together make up for big data it is very
tough to store process and analyze big
data using rtbms if you have looked into
our previous videos you would know that
hadoop is the solution to this hadoop is
a framework that stores and processes
big data it stores big data using the
distributed storage system and it
processes big data using the parallel
processing method hence storing and
processing big data is no more a problem
using hadoop big data in its raw form is
of no use to us we must try to derive
meaningful information from it in order
to benefit from this big data do you
know amazon uses big data to monitor its
items that are in its fulfillment
centers across the globe how do you
think amazon does this well it is done
by analyzing big data which is known as
big data analytics what is big data
analytics in simple terms big data
analytics is defined as the process
which is used to extract meaningful
information from big data this
information could be your hidden
patterns unknown correlations market
trends and so on by using big data
analytics there are many advantages it
can be used for better decision making
to prevent fraudulent activities and
many others we will look into four of
them step by step i will first start off
with big data analytics which is used
for risk management bdo which is a
philippine banking company uses big data
analytics for risk management risk
management is an important aspect for
any organization especially in the field
of banking risk management analysis
comprises a series of measures which are
employed to prevent any sort of
unauthorized activities identifying
fraudulent activities was a main concern
for bdo it was difficult for the bank to
identify the fraudster from a long list
of suspects bdo adopted big data
analytics which held the bank to narrow
down the entire list of suspects thus
the organization was able to identify
the fraudster in a very short time this
is how big data analytics is used in the
field of banking for risk management let
us now see how big data analytics is
used for product development and
innovations with an example all of you
are aware of rolls-royce cars right do
you also know that they manufacture jet
engines which are used across the world
what is more interesting is that they
use big data analytics for developing
and innovating this engine a new product
is always developed by trial and error
method big data analytics is used here
to analyze if an engine design is good
or bad it is also used to analyze if
there can be more scope for improvement
based on the previous models and on the
future demands this way big data
analytics is used in designing a product
which is of higher quality using big
data analytics the company can save a
lot of time if the team is struggling to
arrive at the right conclusion big data
can be used to zero in on the right data
which have to be studied and thus the
time spent on the product development is
less big data analytics helps in quicker
and better decision making in
organizations the process of selecting a
course of action from various other
alternatives is known as decision making
a lot of organizations take important
decisions based on the data that they
have data-driven business decisions can
make or break a company hence it is
important to analyze all the
possibilities thoroughly and quickly
before making important decisions let us
now try to understand this with an use
case starbucks uses big data analytics
for making important decisions they
decide the location of their new outlet
using big data analytics choosing the
right location is an important factor
for any organization the wrong location
will not be able to attract the required
amount of customers positioning of a new
outlet a few miles here or there can
always make a huge difference for an
outlet especially a one like starbucks
various factors are involved in choosing
the right location for a new outlet for
example parking adequacy has to be taken
into consideration it would be
inconvenient for people to go to a store
which has no parking facility similarly
the other factors that have to be
considered are the visibility of the
location the accessibility the economic
factors the population of that
particular location and also we would
have to look into the competition in the
vicinity all these factors have to be
thoroughly analyzed before making a
decision as to where the new outlet must
be started without analyzing these
factors it would be impossible for us to
make a wise decision using big data
analytics we can consider all these
factors and analyze them quickly and
thoroughly thus starbucks makes use of
big data analytics to understand if
their new location would be fruitful or
not finally we will look into how big
data analytics is used to improve
customer experience using an example
delta an american airline uses big data
analytics to improve its customer
experiences with the increase in global
air travel it is necessary that an
airline does everything they can in
order to provide good service and
experience to its customers delta
airlines improves its customer
experience by making use of big data
analytics this is done by monitoring
tweets which will give them an idea as
to how their customers journey was if
the airline comes across a negative
tweet and if it is found to be the
airline's fault the airline goes ahead
and upgrades that particular customer's
ticket when this happens the customer is
able to trust the airlines and without a
doubt the customer will choose delta for
their next journey by doing so the
customer is happy and the airlines will
be able to build a good brand
recognition thus we see here that by
using analysis delta airlines was able
to improve its customer experience
moving on to our next topic that is life
cycle of big data analytics here we will
look into the various stages as to how
data is analyzed from scratch the first
stage is the business case evaluation
stage here the motive behind the
analysis is identified we need to
understand why we are analyzing so that
we know how to do it and what are the
different parameters that have to be
looked into once this is done it is
clear for us and it becomes much easier
for us to proceed with the rest after
which we will look into the various data
sources from where we can gather all the
data which will be required for analysis
once we get the required data we will
have to see if the data that we received
is fit for analysis or not not all the
data that we receive will have
meaningful information some of it will
surely just be corrupt data to remove
this corrupt data we will pass this
entire data through a filtering stage in
this stage all the corrupt data will be
removed now we have the data minus the
corrupt data do you think our data is
now fit for analysis well it is not we
still have to figure out which data will
be compatible with the tool that we will
be using for analysis if we find data
which is incompatible we first extract
it and then transform it to a compatible
form depending on the tool that we use
in the next stage all the data with the
same fields will be integrated this is
known as the data aggregation stage the
next stage which is the analysis stage
is a very important stage in the life
cycle of big data analytics right here
in this step the entire process of
evaluating your data using various
analytical and statistical tools to
discover meaningful information is done
like we have discussed before the entire
process of deriving meaningful
information from data which is known as
analysis is done here in this stage the
result of the data analysis stage is
then graphically communicated using
tools like tableau power bi click view
this analysis result will then be made
available to different business
stakeholders for various decision making
this was the entire life cycle of big
data analytics we just saw how data is
analyzed from scratch now we will move
on to a very important topic that is the
different types of big data analytics
well we have four different types of big
data analytics as you see here these are
the types and below this are the
questions that each type tries to answer
we have descriptive analytics
which asks the question what has
happened then we have diagnostic
analytics which asks why did it happen
predictive analytics asking what will
happen and prescriptive analytics which
questions by asking what is the solution
we will look into all these four one by
one with an use case for each we will
first start off with descriptive
analytics as mentioned earlier
descriptive analytics asks the question
what has happened it can be defined as
the type that summarizes past data into
a form that can be understood by humans
in this type we will look into the past
data and arrive at various conclusions
for example an organization can review
its performance using descriptive
analytics that is it analyzes its past
data such as revenue over the years and
arrives at a conclusion with the profit
by looking at this graph we can
understand if the company is running at
a profit or not thus descriptive
analytics helps us understand this
easily we can simply say that
descriptive analytics is used for
creating various reports for companies
and also for tabulating various social
media metrics like facebook likes tweets
etc now that we have seen what is
descriptive analytics let us look into
and use case of descriptive analytics
the dow chemical company analyzed all
its past data using descriptive
analytics and by doing so they were able
to identify the underutilized space in
their facility descriptive analytics
helped them in this space consolidation
on the whole the company was able to
save nearly 4 million dollars annually
so we now see here that descriptive
analytics not only helps us derive
meaningful information from the past
data but it can also help companies in
cost reduction if it is used wisely let
us now move on to our next type that is
diagnostic analytics diagnostic
analytics asks the question why a
particular problem has occurred as you
can see it will always ask the question
why did it happen it will look into the
root cause of a problem and try to
understand why it has occurred
diagnostic analytics makes use of
various techniques such as data mining
data discovery and drill down companies
benefit from this type of analytics
because it helps them look into the root
cause of a problem by doing so the next
time the same problem will not arise as
the company already knows why it has
happened and they will arrive at a
particular solution for it initsoft's bi
query tool is an example of diagnostic
analytics we can use query tool for
diagnostic analytics now that you know
why diagnostic analytics is required and
what diagnostic analytics is i will run
you through an example which shows where
diagnostic analytics can be used all of
us shop on e-commerce sites right have
you ever added items to your cart but
ended up not buying it yes all of us
might have done that at some point an
organization tries to understand why its
customers don't end up buying their
products although it has been added to
their cuts and this understanding is
done with the help of diagnostic
analytics an e-commerce site wonders why
they have made few online sales although
they have had a very good marketing
strategy there could have been various
factors as to why this has happened
factors like the shipping fee which was
too high or the page that didn't load
correctly not enough payment options
available and so on all these factors
are analyzed using diagnostic analytics
and the company comes to a conclusion as
to why this has happened thus we see
here that the root cause is identified
so that in future the same problem
doesn't occur again let us now move on
to the third type that is predictive
analytics as the name suggests
predictive analytics makes predictions
of the future it analyzes the current
and historical facts to make predictions
about future it always asks the question
what will happen next predictive
analytics is used with the help of
artificial intelligence machine learning
data mining to analyze the data it can
be used for predicting customer trends
market trends customer behavior etc it
solely works on probability it always
tries to understand what can happen next
with the help of all the past and
current information a company like
paypal which has 260 plus million
accounts always has the need to ensure
that their online fraudulent and
unauthorized activities are brought down
to nil fear of constant fraudulent
activities have always been a major
concern for paypal when a fraudulent
activity occurs people lose trust in the
company and this brings in a very bad
name for the brand it is inevitable that
fraudulent activities will happen in a
company like paypal which is one of the
largest online payment processors in the
world but paypal uses analytics wisely
here to prevent such fraudulent
activities and to minimize them it uses
predictive analytics to do so the
organization is able to analyze past
data which includes a customer's
historical payment data a customer's
behavior trend and then it builds an
algorithm which works on predicting what
is likely to happen next with respect to
their transaction with the use of big
data and algorithms the system can gauge
which of the transactions are valid and
which could be potentially a fraudulent
activity by doing so paypal is always
ready with precautions that they have to
take to protect all their clients
against fraudulent transactions we will
now move on to our last type that is
prescriptive analytics prescriptive
analytics as the name suggests always
prescribes a solution to a particular
problem the problem can be something
which is happening currently hence it
can be termed as the type that always
asks the question what is the solution
prescriptive analytics is related to
both predictive and descriptive
analytics as we saw earlier descriptive
analytics always asks the question what
has happened and predictive analytics
helps you understand what can happen
next with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
prescriptive analytics helps you arrive
at the best solution for a particular
problem various business rules
algorithms and computational modeling
procedures are used in prescriptive
analytics let us now have a look at how
and bear prescriptive analytics is used
with an example here we will understand
how prescriptive analytics is used by an
airline for its profit do you know that
when you book a flight ticket the price
of it depends on various factors both
internal and external factors apart from
taxes seed selection there are other
factors like oil prices customer demand
which are all taken into consideration
before the flight sphere is displayed
prices change due to availability and
demand holiday seasons are a time when
the rates are much higher than the
normal days seasons like christmas and
school vacations also weekends the rates
will be much higher than weekdays
another factor which determines a
flight's fair is your destination
depending on the place where you are
traveling to the flight fair will be
adjusted accordingly this is because
there are quite a few places where the
air traffic is less and in such places
the flight sphere will also be less so
prescriptive analytics analyzes all
these factors that are discussed and it
builds an algorithm which will
automatically adjust a flight sphere by
doing so the airline is able to maximize
its profit these were the four types of
analytics now let us understand how we
achieve these with the use of big data
tools our next topic will be the various
tools used in big data analytics these
are a few of the tools that i will be
talking about today we have hadoop
mongodb talindi kafka cassandra spark
and storm we will look into each one of
them one by one we will first start off
with hadoop when you speak of big data
the first framework that comes into
everyone's mind is hadoop isn't it as i
mentioned earlier apache hadoop is used
to store and process big data in a
distributed and parallel fashion it
allows us to process data very fast
hadoop uses mapreduce big and high for
analyzing this big data hadoop is easily
one of the most famous big data tools
now let us move on to the next one that
is mongodb mongodb is a cross-platform
document oriented database it has the
ability to deal with large amount of
unstructured data processing of data
which is unstructured and processing of
data sets that change very frequently is
done using mongodb talandi provides
software and services for data
integration data management and cloud
storage it specializes in big data
integration talente open studio is a
free open source tool for processing
data easily on a big data environment
cassandra is used widely for an
effective management of large amounts of
data it is similar to hadoop in its
feature of fault tolerance where data is
automatically replicated to multiple
nodes cassandra is preferred for
real-time processing spark is another
tool that is used for data processing
this data processing engine is developed
to process data way faster than hadoop
mapreduce this is done in a way because
spark does all the processing in the
main memory of the data nodes and thus
it prevents unnecessary input output
overheads with the disk whereas
mapreduce is disk based and hence spark
proves to be faster than hadoop
mapreduce storm is a free big data
computational system which is done in
real time it is one of the easiest tools
for big data analysis it can be used
with any programming language this
feature makes storm very simple to use
finally we will look into another big
data tool which is known as kafka kafka
is a distributed streaming platform
which was developed by linkedin and
later given to apache software
foundation it is used to provide
real-time analytics result and it is
also used for fault tolerant storage
these were few of the big data analytics
tools now let us move on to our last
topic for today that is big data
application domains here we will look
into the various sectors where big data
analytics is actively used the first
sector is e-commerce merely 45 percent
of the world is online and they create a
lot of data every second big data can be
used smartly in the field of e-commerce
by predicting customer trend forecasting
demands adjusting the price and so on
online retailers have the opportunity to
create better shopping experience and
generate higher sales if big data
analytics is used correctly having big
data doesn't automatically lead to a
better marketing strategy meaningful
insights need to be derived from it in
order to make right decisions by
analyzing big data we can have
personalized marketing campaigns which
can result in better and higher sales in
the field of education depending on the
market requirements new courses are
developed the market requirement needs
to be analyzed correctly with respect to
the scope of a course and accordingly a
scope needs to be developed there is no
point in developing a course which has
no scope in the future hence to analyze
the market requirement and to develop
new courses we use big data analytics
here there are a number of uses of big
data analytics in the field of health
care and one of it is to predict a
patient's health issue that is with the
help of their previous medical history
big data analytics can determine how
likely they are to have a particular
health issue in the future the example
of spotify that we saw previously showed
how big data analytics is used to
provide a personalized recommendation
list to all its users similarly in the
field of media and entertainment big
data analytics is used to understand the
demands of shows songs movies and so on
to deliver personalized recommendation
list as we saw with spotify big data
analytics is used in the field of
banking as we saw previously with a few
use cases big data analytics was used
for risk management in addition to risk
management it is also used to analyze a
customer's income and spend patterns and
to help the bank predict if a particular
customer is going to choose any of the
bank offers such as loans credit card
schemes and so on this way the bank is
able to identify the right customer who
is interested in its offers it has
noticed that telecom companies have
begun to embrace big data to gain profit
big data analytics helps in analyzing
network traffic and call data records it
can also improve its service quality and
improve its customer experience let us
now look into how big data analytics is
used by governments across the world in
the field of law enforcement big data
analytics can be applied to analyze all
the available data to understand crime
patterns intelligence services can use
predictive analytics to forecast the
crime which could be committed in durham
the police department was able to reduce
the crime rate using big data analytics
with the help of data police could
identify whom to target where to go when
to petrol and how to investigate crimes
big data analytics help them to discover
patterns of crime emerging in the area
before we move on to the applications
let's have a quick look at the big data
market revenue forecast worldwide from
2011 to 2027.
so here's a graph in which the y-axis
represents the revenue in billion us
dollars and the x-axis represents the
years as it is seen clearly from the
graph big data has grown until 2019 and
statistics predict that this growth will
continue even in the future this growth
is made possible as numerous companies
use big data in various domains to boost
their revenue we will look into few of
such applications the first big data
application we will look into is weather
forecast imagine there is a sudden storm
and you're not even prepared that would
be a terrifying situation isn't it
dealing with any calamities such as
hurricane storms floods would be very
inconvenient if we are caught off guard
the solution is to have a tool that
predicts the weather of the coming days
well in advance this tool needs to be
accurate and to make such a tool big
data is used so how does big data help
here well it allows us to gather all the
information required to predict the
weather information such as the climate
change details wind direction
precipitation previous weather reports
and so on after all this data is
collected it becomes easier for us to
spot a trend and identify what's going
to happen next by analyzing all of this
big data a weather prediction engine
works on this analysis it predicts the
weather of every region across the world
for any given time by using such a tool
we can be well prepared to face any
climate change or any natural calamity
let's take an example of a landslide and
try to understand how big data is used
to tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the university of melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur two weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and applied mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecast and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce sky-high results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your previous browsing history and your
purchase data publishers then display
what you like in the form of ads which
will in turn catch your interest in
looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
revenue big data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations etc
these emotions are then analyzed to
arrive at a conclusion regarding the
customer satisfaction if the customer is
unhappy the company strives to do better
the next time and provides their
customers a better experience while
purchasing an item from an e-commerce
site or while watching videos on an
entertainment site you might have
noticed a segment which says most
recommended list for you this list is a
personalized list which is made
available to you by analyzing all the
data such as your previous watch history
your subscriptions your likes and so on
recommendation engine is a tool that
filters and analyzes all this data and
provides you with a list that you would
most likely be interested in by doing so
the site is able to retain and engage
its customer for a longer time next is
customer churn analysis in simple words
customer churn happens when a customer
stops a subscription with a service
predicting and preventing this is of
paramount importance to any organization
by analyzing the behavioral patterns of
previously churned customers an
organization can identify which of their
current customers are likely to churn by
analyzing all of this data the
organization can then implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of starbucks big data is
effectively used by the starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the store they visit and to the
time they purchase all of this data is
fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new starbucks location the
system analyzes all their data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is healthcare
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available big data
medical researchers are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence personal care is
very important personal care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history and individuals medical
history along with their body parameters
are analyzed and personal attention is
given to each of them as we all know
medical treatments are not very pocket
friendly every time a medical treatment
is taken the amount increases this can
be reduced if readmissions are brought
down analyzing all the data precisely
will deliver a long-term efficient
result which will in turn prevent a
patient's readmission frequently with
globalization came an increase in the
ease for infectious diseases to spread
widely based on geography and
demographics big data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
american health care company united
health care uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
intentional misrepresentation of data
and so on the healthcare company runs
disease management programs the success
rates of these programs are predicted
using big data depending on how patients
respond to it the next sector we will
look into is logistics logistics looks
into the process of transportation and
storage of goods the movement of a
product from its supplier to a consumer
is very important big data is used to
make this process faster and efficient
the most important factor in logistics
is the time taken for the products to
reach their destination to achieve
minimum time sensors within the vehicle
analyze the fastest route this analysis
is based on various data such as the
weather traffic the list of orders and
so on by doing so the fastest route is
obtained and the delivery time is
reduced capacity planning is another
factor which needs to be taken into
consideration details regarding the
workforce and the number of vehicles are
analyzed thoroughly and each vehicle is
allocated a different route this is done
as there is no need for many trucks to
travel in the same direction which will
be pointless depending on the analysis
of the available workforce and resources
this decision is taken big data
analytics also finds its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
a use case of ups as you know ups is one
of the biggest shipping company in the
world they have a huge customer database
and they work on data every minute ups
uses big data to gather different kinds
of data regarding the weather the
traffic jams the geography the locations
and so on after collecting all this data
they analyze it to discover the best and
the fastest route to the destination in
addition to this they also use big data
to change the routes in real time this
is how efficiently ups leverages big
data next up we have a very interesting
sector that is the travel and tourism
sector the global tourism market is
expected to grow in the near future big
data is used in various ways in this
sector let us look into a few of them
hotels can increase their revenue by
adjusting the room tariffs depending on
the peak seasons such as holiday seasons
festive seasons and so on the tourism
industry uses all of this data to
anticipate the demand and maximize their
revenue big data is also used by resorts
and hotels to analyze various details
regarding their competitors this
analysis result helps them to
incorporate all the good facilities
their competitors are providing and by
doing so the hotel is able to flourish
further a customer always comes back if
they are offered good packages which are
more than just the basic ones looking
into a customer's past travel history
likes and preferences hotels can provide
its customers with personalized
experiences which will interest them
highly investing in an area which could
be the hub of tourism is very wise few
countries use big data to examine the
tourism activities in their country and
this in turn helps them discover new and
fruitful investment opportunities let us
look into one of the best online
homestay networks airbnb and see how big
data is used by them airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world big data
is used by it to analyze the different
kinds of available properties depending
on the customer's preferences the
pricing the keywords previous customers
ratings and experiences airbnb filters
out the best result big data works its
magic yet again now we will move on to
our final sector which is the government
and law enforcement sector maintaining
law and order is of utmost importance to
any government it is a huge task by
itself big data plays an active role
here and in addition to this it also
helps governments bring in new policies
and schemes for the welfare of its
citizens the police department is able
to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region the
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which breaks the
law and order of the region governments
are able to tackle unemployment to a
great extent by using big data by
analyzing the number of students
graduating every year to the number of
relevant job openings the government can
have an idea of the unemployment rate in
the country and then take necessary
measures to tackle it our next factor is
poverty in large countries it is
difficult to analyze which area requires
attention and development big data
analytics makes it easier for
governments to discover such areas
poverty gradually decreases once these
areas begin to develop
governments have to always be on the
lookout for better development a public
survey voices the opinion of a country's
citizens analyzing all the data
collected from such surveys can help
governments build better policies and
services which will benefit its citizens
let us now move on to our use case did
you know that the new york police
department uses big data analytics to
protect its citizens the department
prevents and identifies crimes by
analyzing a huge amount of data which
includes fingerprints certain emails and
records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes now when we talk
about evolution of big data we have
known that data has evolved in last five
years like never before now in fact
before going to big data or before
understanding these solutions and the
need and why there is a rush towards big
data technology in solution i would like
to ask a question take a couple of
minutes and think why are organizations
interested in big data why is there a
certain rush in industry where everyone
would want to ramp up their current
infrastructure or would want to be
working on technologies which allow them
to use this big data think about it what
is happening and why are organizations
interested in this and if you think on
this
you will start thinking about what
organizations have been doing in past
what organizations have not done and why
are organizations interested in big data
now before we learn on big data we can
always look into internet and check for
use cases where organizations have
failed to use legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past five years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided not to ignore
any data as being uneconomical now we
can talk about different platforms
through which data is generated take an
example of social media like twitter
facebook instagram whatsapp youtube you
have e-commerce and various portals say
ebay amazon flipkart alibaba.com
and then you have various tech giants
such as google oracle sap amazon
microsoft and so on so
lots of data is getting generated every
day in every business sector the point
here is that organizations have slowly
started realizing that they would be
interested in working on all the data
now the question which i asked was why
are organizations interested in big data
and some of you might have already
answered or thought about that
organizations are interested in doing
precise analysis or they want to work on
different formats of data such as
structured unstructured semi-structured
data organizations are interested in
gaining insights or finding the hidden
treasure in the so-called big data and
this is the main reason where
organizations are interested in big data
now there are various use cases there
are various use cases we can compare
that organizations from past 50 or more
than 50 years have been handling huge
amount of data they have been working on
huge volume of data but the question
here is have they worked on all the data
or have they worked on some portion of
it what have they used to store this
data and if they have used something to
store this data what is happening what
is what is changing now when we talk
about the businesses we cannot avoid
talking about the dynamism involved now
any organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on whatsapp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on youtube did
you guys know that youtube is the second
largest search engine after google every
minute users send 31.25 million messages
and watch 2.77 million videos on
facebook walmart handles more than 1
million customer transactions every hour
google 40 000 search queries are
performed on google per second that is
3.46 million searches a day in fact you
could also say that a lot of times
people when they are loading up the
google page is basically just to check
their internet connection however that
is also generating data idc reports that
by 2025 real-time data will be more than
a quarter of all the data and by 2025
the volume of digital data will increase
to 163 zeta bytes that is we are not
even talking about gigabytes or
terabytes anymore we are talking about
petabytes exabytes and zeta bytes and
zeta bytes means 10 to the power 21
bytes so this is how data has evolved
now you can talk about different
companies which would want to use their
data to take business decisions they
would want to collect the data store it
and analyze it and that's how they would
be interested in drawing insights for
the business now this is just a simple
example about facebook and what it does
to work on the data now before we go to
facebook you could always check in
google by just typing in companies using
big data and if we say companies using
big data we should be able to find a
list of different companies which are
using big data for different use cases
there are various sources from where you
can find we could also search for
solution that is hadoop which we'll
discuss later but you could always say
companies using hadoop and that should
take you to the wiki page which will
basically help you know what are the
different companies which are using this
so called solution called hadoop okay
now coming back to what we were
discussing about so organizations are
interested in big data as we discussed
in gaining insights they would want to
use the data to find hidden information
which probably they ignored earlier now
take an example of rdbms what is biggest
drawback in using an rdbms now you might
think that rdbms is known for stability
and consistency and organizations would
be interested in storing their data in
oracle or db2 or mysql or microsoft sql
server and they have been doing that for
many years now so what has changed now
now when we talk about rdbms the first
question which i would ask is do we have
access to 100 of data being online in
rdbms the answer is no we would only
have 10 or 20 or 30 percent of data
online and rest of the data would be
archived which means that if an
organization is interested in working on
all the data they would have to move the
data from the archived storage to the
processing layer and that would involve
bandwidth consumption now this is one of
the biggest drawbacks of rdbms you do
not have access to 100 of data online in
many of the cases organizations started
realizing that the data which they were
ignoring as being uneconomical had
hidden value which they had never
exploited i had read a presentation
somewhere which said torture the data
and it will confess to anything now
that's the value of data which
organizations have realized in recent
past take an example of facebook now
this shows what facebook does with its
big data and we'll come to what is big
data but let's understand the use case
now facebook collects huge volumes of
user data whether that is sms whether
that is likes whether that is
advertisements whether that is features
which people are liking or photographs
or even user profiles now by collecting
this data and providing a portal which
people can use to connect facebook is
also accumulating huge volume of data
and that's way beyond petabytes they
would also be interested in analyzing
this data and one of the reasons would
be they would want to personalize the
experience take an example of
personalized news feed depending on a
user behavior depending on what a user
likes what a user would want to know
about they can recommend a personalized
news feed to every particular user
that's just one example of what facebook
does with its data take an example of
photo tag suggestions now when you log
into facebook account you could also get
suggestions on different friends whom
you would like to connect to or you
would want to tag so that they could be
known by others some more examples which
show how facebook uses its data are as
follows so the flashback collection of
photos and posts that receive the most
comments and likes okay there was
something called as i voted that was
used for 2016 elections with reminders
and directions to tell users their time
and place of polling also something
called as safety checks in incidents
such as earthquake hurricane or mass
shooting facebook gives you safety
checks now these are some examples where
facebook is using big data and that
brings us to the question what is big
data this was just an example where we
discussed about one company which is
making use of that data which has been
accumulated and it's not only for
companies which are social media
oriented like facebook where data is
important take an example of ibm take an
example of jpmorgan chase
take an example of ge or any other
organization which is collecting huge
amount of data they would all want to
gather insights they would want to
analyze the data they would want to be
more precise in building their services
or solutions which can take care of
their customers so what is big data big
data is basically a term it is used to
describe the data that is too large and
complex to store in traditional
databases and as i gave an example it's
not just about storing the data it is
also about what you can do with the data
it also means that if there is a lot of
dynamism involved can you change the
underlying storage and handle any kind
of data that comes in now before we get
into that let's just understand what is
big data so big data is basically a term
which has been given to categorize the
data if it has different characteristics
organizations would want to have the big
data stored processed and then analyzed
to get whatever useful information they
can get from this data now there are
five v's of big data volume velocity
variety value veracity although these
are five v's but then there are other
v's which also categorize the data as
big data such as volatility validity
viscosity virality of data okay so these
are five v's of big data and if the data
has one or all of these characteristics
then it can be considered as big data
including the other ways which i just
mentioned so volume basically means
incredible amount of data huge volumes
of data data generated every second now
that could be used for batch processing
that could be used for real-time stream
processing okay you might have data
being generated from different kind of
devices like your cell phones your
social media websites online
transactions variable devices servers
and these days with iot we are also
talking about data of getting generated
via internet of things that is you could
have different devices which could be
communicating to each other you could be
getting data from radars or leaders or
even camera sensors so there is a huge
volume of data which is getting
generated and if we are talking about
data which has huge volume which is
getting generated constantly or has been
accumulated over a period of time we
would say that is big data velocity now
this is one more important aspect of big
data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
a lot of speed where it becomes
difficult to capture collect process
cure mine or analyze the data then we
are certainly talking about big data the
next aspect of big data is variety now
this is where we talk about structured
data semi-structured data or
unstructured data and here i would like
to ask a question what is the difference
when do you call the data is structured
semi-structured or unstructured now
let's look at an example before we
theoretically discuss about this i
always would like to use some examples
let's look at a log file and let's see
what is it so if i look at this log file
and if i would say what kind of data is
this which is the highlighted one the
answer would be
it is structured data it has specific
delimiters such as space it has data
which is separated by space and if i had
a hundred or thousand or million rows
which had similar kind of data i could
certainly store that in a table i could
have a predefined schema to store this
data so i would call the one which is
highlighted and structured but if i look
at this portion where i would look at a
combination of this kind of data where
some data has a pattern and some data
doesn't now this is an example of
semi-structured data so if i would have
a predefined structure to store this
data probably the pattern of data would
break the structure and if i look at all
the data then i would certainly call it
unstructured data because there is no
clear schema which can define this data
now this is what i mean by variety of
data that is structured data which
basically has a schema or has a format
which could be easily understood you
have semi-structured which could be like
an xml or json or even your excel sheets
where you could have some data which is
structured and the other is unstructured
and when we talk about unstructured we
are talking about absence of schema it
does not have a format it does not have
a schema and it is hard to analyze which
brings its own challenges the next
aspect is value now value refers to the
ability to turn your data useful for
business you would have a lot of data
which is being collected as we mentioned
in previous slides right there would be
a lot of data wrangling or data
pre-processing or cleaning up of data
happening and then finally you would
want to draw value from that data but
from all the data collected what
percentage of data gives us value and if
all my data can give me value then why
wouldn't i use it this is an aspect of
big data right veracity now this means
the quality of data billions of dollars
are lost every year by organizations
because the data which was collected was
not of good quality or probably they
collected a lot of data and then it was
erroneous take an example of autonomous
driving projects which are
happening in europe or u.s where there
are car fleets which are on the road
collecting data via radar sensors and
camera sensors and when this data has to
be processed to train algorithms it is
realized that sometimes the data which
was collected was missing in some values
might be was not appropriate or had a
lot of errors and all this process of
collecting the data becomes a repetitive
task because the quality of data was not
good this is just one example we can
take example from healthcare industry or
stock markets or financial institutions
and so on so extracting loads of data is
not useful if the data is messy or poor
in quality and that basically means that
velocity is a very important v of big
data now apart from veracity volume
variety velocity and value we have the
other v such as viscosity how dense the
data is
validity is the data still valid
volatility is my data volatile or
virality is the data viral now all of
these different v's categorize the data
as big data now here we would like to
talk on a big data case study and we
have taken an example of google which
obviously is one of the companies which
is churning and working on huge amount
of data now it's actually said that if
you compare one grain of sand with one
byte of data then google is processing
or google is handling whole worlds sand
every week that is the kind of data
which google is processing now in early
2000 and since then when the number of
internet users started growing google
also faced lot of problems in storing
increasing user data and
using the traditional servers to manage
that now that was a challenge which
google started facing could they use
traditional data server to store the
data well yes they could right storage
devices have been getting cheaper day by
day but then how much time does it take
to retrieve that data what is the seek
time what is the time taken to read and
process that data thousands of search
queries were raised per second no doubt
now we could say millions and billions
of queries are raised per second every
query read 100 mbs of data and consumed
tens of billions of cpu cycles based on
these queries so the requirement was
that they wanted to have a large
distributed highly fault tolerant file
system large to store to capture process
huge amount of data distributed because
they could not rely just on one server
even if that had multiple disks stacked
up that was not an efficient choice what
would happen if this particular machine
failed what would happen if the whole
server was down so they needed a
distributed storage
and a distributed computing environment
they needed something which can be
highly fault tolerant right so this was
the requirement which google had and the
solution which came out as a result was
gfs google file system now let's look at
how gfs works so normally in any
particular linux system or linux server
you would have a file system you would
have set of processes you would have set
up files and directories which could
store the data gfs was different so to
facilitate gfs which could store huge
amount of data there was an architecture
an architecture which had one master and
multiple chunk servers or you could say
slave servers or slave machines master
machine was to contain metadata was to
contain data about data when we say
metadata we are talking about
information about data and then you have
the chunk servers or the slave machines
which could be storing data in a
distributed fashion now any client or an
api or an application which would want
to read the data would first contact the
master server it would contact the
machine where the master process was
running and client would place a request
of
reading the data or showing an interest
of reading the data internally what it
is doing is it is requesting for
metadata your api or an application
would want to know from where it can
read the data master server which has
metadata whether that is in ram or disk
we can discuss that later but then
master server would have the metadata
and it would know which are the chunk
servers or the slave machines where the
data was stored in a distributed fashion
master would respond back with the
metadata information to the client and
then client could use that information
to read or write to these slave machines
where actually the data was stored now
this is what the process or set of
processes work together to make gfs so
when you say a chunk server we would
basically have the files getting divided
into fixed size chunks now how would
they get divided so there would be some
kind of chunk size or a block size which
would determine that if the file is
bigger than the pre-decided chunk size
then it would be split into smaller
chunks and be distributed across the
chunk servers or the slave machines if
the file was smaller then it would still
use one chunk or a block to get stored
on the underlying slave machines so
these chunk servers or slave machines
are the ones which actually store the
data on local disks as your linux files
client which is interacting with master
for metadata and then interacting with
chunk servers for read write operations
would be the one which would be
externally connecting to the cluster so
this is how it would look so you have a
master which would obviously be
receiving some kind of heartbeats from
the chunk servers to know their status
and receive information in the form of
packets which would let the master know
which machines were available for
storage which machines already had data
and master would build up the metadata
within itself the files would be broken
down into chunks for example we can look
at file one it is broken down into chunk
one and chunk two and file two has one
chunk which is one portion of it and
then you have file two residing on some
other chunk server which also lets us
know that there is some kind of auto
replication for this file system right
and the data which is getting stored in
the chunk could have a data of 64 mb now
that chunk size could be changed based
on the data size but google file system
had the basic size of the chunk as 64 mb
each chunk would be replicated on
multiple servers the default replication
was three and that could again be
increased or decreased as per
requirement this would also mean that if
a particular slave machine or a chung
server would die or would get killed or
would crash there would never be any
data loss because a replica of data
residing on the failed machine would
still be available on some other slave
server chunk server or slave machine now
this helped google to store and process
huge volumes of data in a distributed
manner and does have a fault tolerant
distributed scalable storage which could
allow them to store a huge amount of
data now that was just one example which
actually led to the solution which today
we call as hadoop now when we talk about
big data here i would like to ask you
some questions that if we were talking
about the rdbms case take an example of
something like nasa which was working on
a project called set eye search of
extraterrestrial intelligence now this
was a project where they were looking
for a solution to take care of their
problem the problem was that they would
roughly send some waves in space capture
those waves back and then analyze this
data to find if there was any
extraterrestrial object in space now
they had two options for it they could
either have a huge server built which
could take care of storing the data and
processing it or they could go for
volunteer computing now volunteer
computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and
being part of this project and what they
would in turn do is they would be
donating their ram and storage
from their machines when they are not
using it how would that happen basically
download some kind of patch on their
machine which would run as a screen
saver and if the user is not using his
machine some portion of data could be
transferred to these machines for
intermittent storage and processing
using ram now this sounds very
interesting and this sounds very easy
however it would have its own challenges
right think about security think about
integrity but those those problems are
not bigger as much as is the requirement
of bandwidth and this is the same thing
which happens in rdbms if you would have
to move data from archived solution to
the processing layer that would consume
huge amount of bandwidth big data brings
its own challenges huge amount of data
is getting generated every day now the
biggest challenge is storing this huge
volume of data and especially when this
data is getting generated with lot of
variety when it can have different kind
of formats where it could be viral it
could be having a lot of value and
nobody has looked into the veracity of
data but the primary problem would be
handling this huge volume of data
variety of the data would bring in
challenges of storing it in legacy
systems if processing of the data was
required now here again i would suggest
you need to think what is the difference
between reading a data and processing a
data so reading might just mean bringing
in the data from desk and doing some io
operations and processing would mean
reading the data probably doing some
transformations on it extracting some
useful information from it and then
storing it in the same format or
probably in a different format so
processing this massive volume of data
is the second challenge organizations
don't just store their big data they
would eventually want to use it to
process it to gather some insights now
processing and extracting insights from
big data would take huge amount of time
unless and until there was an efficient
solution to handle and process this big
data securing the data that's again a
concern for organizations right
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the cpu cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that led to hadoop
as a solution so big data brings its own
challenges big data brings its own
benefits and here we have a solution
which is hadoop now what is hadoop it's
a open source framework for storing data
and running applications on clusters of
commodity hardware hadoop is an open
source framework and before we discuss
on two main components of hadoop it
would be good to look into the link
which i was suggesting earlier that is
companies using hadoop and any person
who would be interested in learning big
data should start somewhere here where
you could list down different companies
what kind of setup they have why are
they having hadoop what kind of
processing they are doing and how are
they using these so-called hadoop
clusters to process and in fact store
capture and process huge amount of data
another link which i would suggest is
looking at different distributions
of hadoop any person who is interested
in learning in big data should know
about different distributions of hadoop
now in linux we have different different
distributions like ubuntu centos red hat
susie debian in the same way you have
different distributions of hadoop which
we can look on the wiki page and this is
the link which talks about products that
include apache hadoop or derivative
works and commercial support which
basically means that apache hadoop the
sole products that can be called a
release of apache hadoop come from
apache.org that's an open source
community and then you have various
vendor-specific distributions like
amazon web services you have cloudera
you have hortonworks you have ibm's big
insight you have mapper all these are
different distributions of hadoop so
basically all of these vendor-specific
distributions are depending on using on
core apache hadoop in brief we can say
that these are the vendors which take up
the apache hadoop package it within a
cluster management solution so that
users who intend to use apache hadoop
would not have difficulties of setting
up a cluster setting up a framework they
could just use a vendor-specific
distribution with its cluster
installation solutions clustered
management solution and easily plan
deploy install and manage a cluster
let's rewind to the days before the
world turned digital
back then miniscule amounts of data were
generated at a relatively sluggish pace
all the data was mostly documents and in
the form of rows and columns
storing or processing this data wasn't
much trouble as a single storage unit
and processor combination would do the
job but as years passed by the internet
took the world by storm giving rise to
tons of data generated in a multitude of
forms and formats every microsecond
semi-structured and unstructured data
was available now in the form of emails
images audio and video to name a few
all this data became collectively known
as big data
although fascinating it became nearly
impossible to handle this big data
and a storage unit processor combination
was obviously not enough so what was the
solution
multiple storage units and processors
were undoubtedly the need of the hour
this concept was incorporated in the
framework of hadoop that could store and
process vast amounts of any data
efficiently using a cluster of commodity
hardware hadoop consisted of three
components that were specifically
designed to work on big data in order to
capitalize on data the first step is
storing it the first component of hadoop
is its storage unit the hadoop
distributed file system or hdfs
storing massive data on one computer is
unfeasible
hence data is distributed amongst many
computers and stored in blocks
so if you have 600 megabytes of data to
be stored hdfs splits the data into
multiple blocks of data that are then
stored on several data nodes in the
cluster
128 megabytes is the default size of
each block
hence 600 megabytes will be split into
four blocks a b c and d of 128 megabytes
each
and the remaining 88 megabytes in the
last block e
so now you might be wondering what if
one data node crashes
do we lose that specific piece of data
well no that's the beauty of hdfs
hdfs makes copies of the data and stores
it across multiple systems
for example when block a is created it
is replicated with a replication factor
of 3 and stored on different data nodes
this is termed the replication method
by doing so data is not lost at any cost
even if one data node crashes making
hdfs fault tolerant after storing the
data successfully it needs to be
processed
this is where the second component of
hadoop mapreduce comes into play
in the traditional data processing
method entire data would be processed on
a single machine having a single
processor
this consumed time and was inefficient
especially when processing large volumes
of a variety of data to overcome this
mapreduce splits data into parts and
processes each of them separately on
different data nodes
the individual results are then
aggregated to give the final output
let's try to count the number of
occurrences of words taking this example
first the input is split into five
separate parts based on full stops the
next step is the mapper phase where the
occurrence of each word is counted and
allocated a number
after that depending on the words
similar words are shuffled sorted and
grouped following which in the reducer
phase all the grouped words are given a
count
finally the output is displayed by
aggregating the results all this is done
by writing a simple program
similarly mapreduce processes each part
of big data individually and then sums
the result at the end
this improves load balancing and saves a
considerable amount of time
now that we have our mapreduce job ready
it is time for us to run it on the
hadoop cluster this is done with the
help of a set of resources such as ram
network bandwidth and cpu
multiple jobs are run on hadoop
simultaneously and each of them needs
some resources to complete the task
successfully
to efficiently manage these resources we
have the third component of hadoop which
is yarn
yet another resource negotiator or yarn
consists of a resource manager node
manager application master and
containers the resource manager assigns
resources node managers handle the nodes
and monitor the resource usage in the
node the containers hold a collection of
physical resources
suppose we want to process the mapreduce
job we had created
first the application master requests
the container from the node manager
once the node manager gets the resources
it sends them to the resource manager
this way yarn processes job requests and
manages cluster resources in hadoop in
addition to these components hadoop also
has various big data tools and
frameworks dedicated to managing
processing and analyzing data
the hadoop ecosystem comprises several
other components like hive pig apache
spark flume and scoop to name a few the
hadoop ecosystem works together on big
data management before we dive into the
technical side of hadoop we're going to
take a little detour to try to give you
a visual understanding and relate it to
maybe a more life setup and we're going
to go to the farm in this case so we
have in a farm far away i almost wish
they'd put far far away it does remind
me a little bit of a star wars theme so
we're going to look at fruit at a farm
we have jack who harvests his grapes and
then sells it in the nearby town after
harvesting he stores his produce in a
storage shed or a storage room in this
case we found out though is there was a
high demand for other fruits so he
started harvesting apples and oranges as
well hopefully it has a couple fills
with these different fruit trees growing
and he set up there and you can see that
he's working hard to harvest all these
different fruits but he has a problem
here because there's only one of him so
he can't really do more work so what he
needs to do then is hire two more people
to work with him with this harvesting is
done simultaneously so instead of him
trying to harvest all this different
fruit he now has two more people in
there who are putting their food away
and harvesting it for him now the
storage room becomes a bottleneck to
store and access all the fruits in a
single storage area so they can't fit
all the fruit in one place so jack
decides to distribute the storage area
and give each one of them a separate
storage and you can look at this
computer terms we have our people that
are the processors we have our fruit
that's a data and you can see it's
storing it in the different storage
rooms so you can see me popping up there
getting my
hello i want fruit basket of three
grapes two apples and three oranges i'm
getting ready for a breakfast with
family a very large family my family's
not that large to complete the order on
time all of them work parallelly with
their own storage space so here we have
a process of retrieving or querying the
data and you can see from the one
storage space he pulls out three grapes
she pulls out two apples and then
another storage room he pulls out three
oranges and we complete a nice fruit
basket and this solution helps them to
complete the order on time without any
hassle all of them are happy and they're
prepared for an increase in demand in
the future so they now have this growth
system where you can just keep hiring on
new people they can continue to grow and
develop a very large farm so how does
this story relate to big data and i
hinted at that a little bit earlier the
limited data only one processor one
storage unit was needed i remember back
in the 90s they would just upgrade the
computer instead of having a small
computer you would then spend money for
a huge mainframe with all the flashing
lights on it then the craig computers
were really massive nowadays a lot of
the computers that sits on our desktop
are powerful as the mainframes they had
back then so it's pretty amazing how
time has changed but used to be able to
do everything on one computer and you
had structured data and a database you
stored your structured data in so most
of the time you're requiring databases
sql queries just think of it as a giant
spreadsheet with rows and columns where
everything has a very specific size and
fits neatly in that rows and columns and
back in the 90s this was a nice setup
you just upgraded your computer you
would get yourself a nice big sun
computer or mainframe if you had a lot
of data and a lot of stuff going on and
it was very easy to do soon though the
data generation increased leading to
high volume of data along with different
data formats and so you can imagine in
today's world this year we will generate
more data than all the previous years
summed together we will generate more
data just this year than all the
previous years sum together and that's
the way it's been going for some time
and you can see we have a variety of
data we have our structured data which
is what we're you think about a database
with rows and columns and easy to look
at nice spreadsheet we have our
semi-structured data they have emails as
an example here that would be one
example your xml your html web pages and
we have unstructured data if you ever
look through your folder on photos i
have photos that were taken on my phone
with high quality i've got photos from a
long time ago i got web photos low
quality so just in my pictures alone
none of them are the same you know there
certainly are groups of them that are
but overall there are a lot of variety
in size and setup so a single processor
was not enough to process such high
volume of different kinds of data as it
was very time consuming you can imagine
that if you are twitter with millions of
twitter feeds you're not going to be
able to do a query across one server
there's just no way that's going to
happen unless people don't mind waiting
a year to get the history of their
tweets or look something up hence we
start doing multiple processors so
they're used to process high volume of
data and this saved time so we're moving
forward we got multiple processors the
single storage unit became the
bottleneck due to which network overhead
was generated so now you have your
network coming in and each one of these
servers has to wait before it can grab
the data from the single stored unit
maybe you have a sql server there with a
nice setup or a file system going the
solution was to use distributed storage
for each processor this enabled easy
access to storage and access to data so
this makes a lot of sense you have
multiple workers multiple storage units
just like we had our storage room and
the different fruit coming in your
variety you can see that nice parallel
to working on a farm now we're dealing
with a lot of data it's all about the
data now this method worked and there
were no network overhead generated
you're not getting a bottleneck
somewhere where people are just waiting
for data being pulled or being processed
this is known as parallel processing
with distributed storage so parallel
processing distributed storage and you
can see here the parallel processing is
your different computers running the
processes and distributed storage here
is a quick demo on setting up cloudera
quick start vm in case you are
interested in working on a standalone
cluster you can download the cloudera
quick start vm so you can just type in
download cloud error quick start vm and
you can search for package now this can
be used to set up a quick start vm which
would be a single node cloudera based
cluster so you can click on this link
and then basically based on the platform
which you would be choosing to install
such as using a vm box or which version
of cloudera you would install so here i
can select a platform so i can choose
virtualbox and then you can click on get
it now so give your details and
basically then it should allow you to
download the quick start vm which would
look something like this and once you
have the zip file which is downloaded
you can unzip it which can then be used
to set up a single node cloud error
cluster so once you have downloaded the
zip file that would look something like
this so you would have a quick start
virtual box and then a virtual boss disk
now this can be used to set up a cluster
ignore these files which are related to
amazon machines and we you don't need to
have that so you would just have this
and this can be used to set up a cloud
data cluster so for this to be set up
you can click on file import appliance
and here you can choose your quick start
vm by looking into downloads quick start
vm select this and click on open now you
can click on next and that shows you the
specifications of cpu ram which we can
then change later and click on import
this will start importing virtual disk
image dot vmdk file into your vm box
once this is done we will have to change
the specifications or machines to use
two cpu cores minimum and give a little
more ram because cloudera quick start vm
is very cpu intensive and it needs good
amount of ram so to survive i will give
two cpu cores and 5 gb ram and that
should be enough for us to bring up a
quick start vm which gives us a cloudera
distribution of hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in cloudera clusters
working with sdfs and other hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
vm for our practice here the importing
of appliance is done and we see cloudera
quickstart machine is added to my list
of machines i can click on this and
click on settings as mentioned i would
like to give it more ram and more cpu
cores so click on system and here let's
increase the ram to at least five and
click on processor and let's give it two
cpu cores which would at least be better
than using one cpu core network it goes
for nat and that's fine click on ok and
we would want to start this machine so
that it uses two cpu cores 5gb ram and
it should bring up my cloudera quick
start vm now let's go ahead and start
this machine which has our quick start
vm it might take initially some time to
start up because internally there will
be various cloudera services which will
be starting up and those services need
to be up for our cloud era quick start
vm to be accessible so unlike your
apache hadoop cluster where we start our
cluster and we will be starting all our
processes in case of cloudera it is your
cloudera scm server and agents which
take care of starting up of your
services and starting up of your
different roles for those services i
explained in my previous session that
for a cloud era cluster it would be
these services let me just show you that
so in case of apache cluster we start
our services that is we start our
cluster by running script and then
basically those scripts will
individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloud error we would always have a
cloudera scm server which would be
running on one machine and then
including that machine we would have
clouded icm agents which would be
running on multiple machines similarly
if we had a hortonworks cluster we would
have ambari server starting up on the
first machine and then ambari agents
running on other machines so your server
component knows what are the services
which are set up what are their
configurations and agents running on
every node are responsible to send
heartbeats to the server receive
instructions and then take care of
starting and stopping off of individual
roles on different machines in case of
our single node cluster setup in quick
start vm we would just have one scm
server and one scm agent which will
start on the machine which will then
take care of all the roles which need to
be started for your different services
so we will just wait for our machine to
come up and basically have clouded sem
server and agent running and once we
have that we need to follow few steps so
that we can have the cloudera admin
console accessible which allows you to
browse the cluster look at different
services look at the roles for different
services and also work with your cluster
either using command line or using the
web interface that is
now that my machine has come up and it
already is connected to the internet
which we can see here we need to do
certain things so that we can have our
admin console accessible at this point
of time you can click on terminal and
check if you have access to the cluster
so here type in hostname and that shows
you your host name which is
quickstart.cloudera we can also type in
hdfs command to see if we have access
and if my cluster is working these
commands are same as you would give them
in a apache hadoop cluster or in any
other distribution of a loop sometimes
when your cluster is up and you have
access to the terminal it might take few
seconds or few minutes before there is a
connection established between cloudera
cm server and cloudera cm agent running
in the background which takes care of
your cluster i have given a sdfs dfs
list command which basically should show
me what by default exists on my sdfs
let's just give it a couple of seconds
before it shows us the output we can
also check by giving a service cloudera
scm server status and here it tells me
that if you would want to use cloudera
express free run this command it needs 8
gb of ram and it leads to virtual cpu
cores and it also mentions it may take
several minutes before cloudera manager
has started i can login as root here and
then give the command service cloud
error scm server status remember the
password for root is clouded so it
basically says that if you would want to
check the settings it is good to have
express edition running so we can close
this my sdfs access is working fine
let's close the terminal and here we
have launch cloud error express click on
this and that will give you that you
need to give a command which is
force let's copy this command let's open
a different terminal and let's give this
command like this which will then go
ahead and shut down your cloudera based
services and then it will restart it
only after which you will be able to
access your admin console so let's just
give it a couple of minutes before it
does this and then we will have access
to our admin console here if you see it
is starting the cloudera manager server
again it is waiting for cloudera manager
api then starting the cloudera manager
agents and then configuring the
deployment as per the new settings which
we have given as to use the express
edition of cloudera once all this is
done it will say the cluster has been
restarted and the admin console can be
accessed by id and password as cloudera
we'll give it a couple of more minutes
and once this is done we are ready to
use our admin console now that
deployment has been configured client
configurations have also been deployed
and it has restarted the cloudera
management service it gives you an
access to quick start admin console
using username and password as cloudera
let's try accessing it so we can open up
the browser here and let's change this
to
7180 that's the default port and that
shows the admin console which is coming
up now here we can log in as cloud error
cloud error and then let's click on
login now as i said cloudera is very cpu
intensive and memory intensive so it
would slow down since we have not given
enough gb ram to our cloud error cluster
and thus it will be advisable to stop or
even remove the services which we don't
need now as of now if we look at the
services all of them look in a stop
status and that's good in one way
because we can then go ahead and remove
the services which we will not use in
the beginning and later we can anytime
add services to the cluster so for
example i can click on key value store
here and then i can scroll down where it
says delete to remove this service from
the admin console now anytime you are
removing a particular service it will
only remove the service from the
management by cloudera manager all the
role groups under this service will be
removed from host templates so we can
click on delete now if this service was
depending on some other service it would
have prompted me with a message that
remove the relevant services on which
this particular service depends if the
service was already running then it
would have given me a message that the
service has to be stopped before it can
be deleted from the cloudera admin
console now this is my admin console
which allows you to click on services
look at the different roles and
processes which are running for this
service we anyways have access to our
cloudera cluster from the terminal using
our regular sdfs or yarn or map red
commands now i removed a service i will
also remove solar which we will not be
using for the beginning but then it
depends on your choice so we can here
scroll down to delete it and that says
that before deleting the solar service
you must remove the dependencies on the
service from the configuration of
following services that is hue now hue
is a web interface which allows you to
work with your sdfs and that is
depending on this so click on configure
service dependency and here we can make
sure that our hue service does not
depend on a particular service we are
removing so that then we can have a
clean removal of the service so i'll
click on none and i will say save
changes once this is done then we can go
ahead and try removing the solar service
from our admin console which will reduce
some load on my management console which
will also allow me to work faster on my
cluster now here we have removed the
dependency of hue on solar so we can
click on this and then we can delete it
remember i'm only doing this so that my
cluster becomes little lighter and i can
work on my focus services at any point
of time if you want to add more services
to your cluster you can anytime do that
you can fix different configuration
issues like what we see here with
different warning messages
and here we have these services which
are already existing now if we don't
need any of the service i can click on
the drop down and click on delete again
this says that scoop 2 also has
relevance to hue so hue as a web
interface also depends on scope 2. as of
now we'll make it none at any point of
time later you can add the services by
clicking the add service option now this
is a cluster to which you have admin
access and this is a quick start vm
which gives you a single node cloud
error cluster which you can use for
learning and practicing so here we will
click on scope 2 and then we will say
delete as we have configured the
dependency now and we will remove scope
2 also from the list of services which
your admin console is managing right so
once this is done we have removed three
services which we did not need we can
even remove scope as a client and if we
need we can add that later now there are
various other alerts which your cloudera
admin console shows and we can always
fix them by clicking on the health
issues or configuration issues we can
click here and see what is the health
issue it is pointing to if that is a
critical one or if that can be ignored
so it says there is an issue with a
clock offset which basically relates to
an ntp service network time protocol
which makes sure that one or multiple
machines are in the same time zone and
are in sync so for now we can click on
suppress and we can just say suppress
for all hosts and we can say look into
it later and confirm so now we will not
have that health issue reported that
probably the ntp service and the
machines
might not be in sync now that does not
have an impact for our use case as of
now but if we have a kerberos kind of
setup which is for security then
basically this offset and time zone
becomes important so we can ignore this
message and we are still good to use the
cluster we also have other configuration
issues and you can click on this which
might talk about the heap size or the
ram which is available for machines it
talks about zookeeper should be in odd
numbers queue does not have a load
balancer sdfs only has one data node but
all of these issues are not to be
worried upon because this is a single
node cluster setup so if you want to
avoid all of these warnings you can
always click on suppress and you can
avoid and let your cluster be in all
green status but that's nothing to worry
so we can click on cluster and basically
we can look at the services so we have
removed some services which we don't
intend to use now i have also suppressed
a offset warning which is not very
critical for my use case and basically i
am good to start the cluster at any
point of time as i said if you would
want to add services this is the actions
button which you can use to add service
so we will just say restart my cluster
which will restart all the services one
by one starting from zookeeper as the
first service to come up we can always
click on this arrow mark and see what is
happening in the services what services
are coming up and in which order if you
have any issues you can always click on
the link next to it which will take you
to the logs and we can click on close to
let it happen in the background so this
will basically let my services restart
one by one and my cluster will then
become completely accessible either
using hue as a web interface or quick
start terminal which allows you to give
your commands now while my machines are
coming up you can click on hosts and you
can have a look at all the hosts we have
as of now only one which will also tell
you how many roles or processes are
running on this machine so that is 25
rolls it tells you what is the disk
usage it tells you what is the physical
memory being used and using this host
tab we can add new host to the cluster
we can check the configuration we can
check all the hosts in diagnostics you
can look at the logs which will give you
access to all the logs you can even
select the sources from which you would
want to have the logs or you can give
the host name you can click on search
you can build your own charts you can
also do the admin stuff by adding
different users or enabling security
using the administration tab so since we
have clicked on restart of a cluster we
will slowly start seeing all the
services one by one coming up starting
with zookeeper to begin with and once we
have our cluster up and running whether
that is showing all services in green or
in a different status we still should be
able to access the service now as we saw
in apache hadoop cluster even here we
can click on sdfs and we can access the
web ui once our sdfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web ui link which will
allow you to check things from sdfs web
interface similarly yarn as a service
also has a web interface so as soon as
the service comes up under your quick
links we will have access to the yarn ui
and similarly once the service comes up
we will have access to hue which will
give you the web interface which allows
you to work with your sdfs which allows
you to work with your different other
components within the cluster without
even using the command line tools or
command line options so we will have to
give it some time while the cloud error
scm agent on every machine will be able
to restart the roles which are
responsible for your cluster to come up
we can always click here with tells that
there are some running commands in the
background which are trying to start my
cluster we can go to the terminal and we
can switch as hdfs user remember sdfs
user is the admin user and it does not
have a password unless you have set one
so you can just log in as sdfs which
might ask you for a password initially
which we do not have so the best way to
do this is by logging in as root where
the password is cloud error and then you
can log in as hdfs so that then onwards
you can give your sdfs commands to work
with your file system now since my
services are coming up right now when i
try to give a sdfs dfs command it might
not work or it might also say that it is
trying to connect to the name node which
is not up yet so we will have to give it
some time and only once the name node is
up we will be able to access our sdfs
using commands so this is how you can
quickly set up your quick start and then
you can be working using the command
line options from the terminal like what
you would do in apache hadoop cluster
you could use the web interfaces which
allow you to work with your cluster now
this usually takes more time so you will
have to give it some time before your
services are up and running and for any
reason if you have issues it might
require you to restart your cluster
several times in the beginning before it
gets accustomed to the settings what you
have given and it starts up the services
at any point of time if you have any
error message then you can always go
back and look in logs and see what is
happening and try starting your cluster
so this is how we set up a quick start
vm and you can be using this to work
with your cloudera clusters we'll start
with the big data challenges and the
first thing with the big data is you can
see here we have a nice chaotic image
with all these different inputs server
racks all over the place graphs being
generated just about everything you can
imagine and so the problems that come up
with big data is one storing it how do
you store this massive amount of data
and we're not talking about a terabyte
or 10 terabytes we're talking a minimal
of 10 terabytes up to petabytes of data
and then the next question is processing
and so the two go hand in hand because
when you're storing the data that might
take up a huge amount of space or you
might have a small amount of data that
takes a lot of processing and so either
one will drive series of data or
processing into the big data arena so
with storing data storing big data was a
problem due to its massive volume just
straight up people would have huge
backup tapes and then you'd have to go
through the backup tapes for hours to go
find your data and a simple query could
take days and then processing processing
big data consumed more time and so the
hadoop came up with a cheap way to
process the data it used to be like i've
had some processes that if i ran on my
computer without trying to use multiple
cores and multiple threads would take
years to process just a simple data
analysis can get that heavy in the data
processing and so processing can be as
big of a problem as the size of the data
itself so hadoop as a solution this is
the solution to big data and big data
storage storing big data was a problem
due to its massive volume so we take the
hadoop file system or the hdfs and now
we're able to store huge data across a
large number of machines and access it
like it's one file system and processing
big data consumed more time we talked
about some processes you can't even do
on your computer because it would take
years now the hadoop with the map reduce
processing big data was faster and i'm
going to add a little notation right
here that's really important to note
that hadoop is the beginning when we
talk about data processing they've added
new processes on top of the map reduce
that even accelerate it your spark setup
and some other different functionalities
but really the basis of all of it where
it all starts with the most basic
concept is your hadoop mapreduce let us
now look into the hdfs in detail in the
traditional approach all the data was
stored in a single central database with
the rise of big data a single database
was not enough for storage and i
remember the old sun computers or the
huge ibm machines with all the flashing
lights now all the data on one of those
can be stored on your phone it's almost
a bit of humor how much this has
accelerated over the years the same
thing with our rise of big data no
longer can you just store it on one
machine no longer can you go out and buy
a sun computer and put it on that one
sun computer no more can you buy a craig
machine or an enterprise ibm server it's
not going to work you're not going to
fit it all into one server the solution
was to use distributed approach to store
the massive amount of data data was
divided and distributed amongst many
individual databases and you can see
here where we have three different
databases going on so you might actually
saw this in one where they divided up
the user accounts a through g so on by
the letter and so the first query would
say what's the first letter of this uh
whatever id it was and then it would go
into that database to find it so i had a
database telling it which database to
look for stuff that was a long time ago
and to be honest it didn't work really
well nowadays so that was a distributed
database you'd have to track which
database you put it in so what is hdfs
hadoop distributed file system hdfs is a
specially designed file system for
storing huge data sets in commodity
hardware and commodity is an interesting
term because i mentioned enterprise
versus commodity and i'll touch back
upon that it has two core components
name node and data node name node is the
master
daemon there's only one active name node
it manages the data nodes and stores all
the metadata so it stores all the
mapping of where the data is on your
hadoop file system now the name node is
usually an enterprise machine you spend
a lot of extra money on it so you have a
very solid name known machine and so
then we have our data nodes our data
node data node data node we have three
here the data node is the slave there
can be multiple data nodes and it stores
the actual data and this is where your
commodity hardware comes in the best
definition i've heard of commodity
hardware is the cheap knockoffs this is
where you buy you can buy 10 of these
and you expect one of them not to work
because you know when they come in
they're going to break right away so
you're looking at hardware it's not as
high-end so where you might have your
main master node as your enterprise
server then your data nodes are just as
cheap as you can get them with all the
different features you need on them as
said earlier name node stores the
metadata metadata gives information
regarding the file location block size
and so on so our metadata in the hdfs is
maintained by using two files it has the
edit log and the fs image the edit log
keeps track of the recent changes made
on the hadoop file system only recent
changes are tracked here the fs image
keeps track of every change made on the
hdfs since the beginning now what
happens when the edit log file size
increases the name node fails these are
big ones so what happens we get our edit
log it just keeps so big until it's too
big or our main enterprise
computer that we spend all that money on
so when break actually fails because
they still fail the solution we make
copies of the edit log and the fs image
files so that's pretty straightforward
you just copy them over so you have both
the most recent edits going on and the
long term image of your file system and
then we also create a secondary name
node is a node that maintains the copies
of the edit log and the fs image it
combines them both to get an updated
version of the fs image now the
secondary name node only came in the
last oh i guess two three years where it
became as part of the main system and
usually your secondary name node is also
an enterprise computer and you'll put
them on separate racks so if you have
three racks of computers you would have
maybe the first two racks would have the
name node and the second rack would have
the secondary name note and the reason
you put them on different racks is you
can have a whole rack go down you can
have somebody literally trip over the
power cable or the switch that goes
between the racks is most common goes
down well if the switch goes down you
can usually switch to the secondary name
node and while you're getting your
switch replaced and replacing that
hardware because of the way the hdfs
works it still is completely functional
so let's take a look at the name node we
have our edit log our fs image and we
have our secondary name node and you
take that and copies the edit log over
and it copies the fs image and you can
see right here you have all the
different contents on your main name
node now also on your secondary name
node and then your secondary name node
will actually take these two your edit
log and your fs image and it will make a
copy so you have a full fs image that
contains its current it's up to date the
secondary name node creates a periodic
checkpoint of the files and then it
updates the new fs image into the name
node now it used to be this all occurred
on the name node before you had a
secondary name note so now you can use
your secondary node to both up
everything going on the name node and it
does that lifting in the back where
you're combining your edit log and
bringing your fs image so it's current
and then you end up with a new edit log
and a new you have your fs image updated
and you start a fresh edit log this
process of updating happens every hour
and that's how it's scheduled you can
actually change those schedules but that
is the standard is to update every hour
so let's we took a look at the the
master node and the you know the name
node and the secondary name node let's
take a look at the cluster architecture
of our hadoop file system the hdfs
cluster architecture so we have our name
node and it stores the metadata and we
have our block location so we have our
fs image plus our edit log and then we
have the backup fs image and edit log
and then we have so you have your rack
we have our switch on top remember i was
talking about the switch that's the most
common thing to go in the rack is the
switches and underneath the rack you
have your different data nodes you have
your data node one two three four five
maybe have 10 15 on this rack you can
stack them pretty high nowadays uh used
to be you only get about 10 servers on
there but now you see racks that contain
a lot more and then you have multiple
racks so we're not talking about just
one rack we also have you know rack two
rack three 4 5 6 and so on until you
have rack in so if you had a 100 data
nodes we would be looking at 10 racks of
10 data nodes each and that is literally
10 commodity server computers hardware
and we have a core switch which
maintains the network bandwidth and
connects the name node to the data nodes
so just like each rack has a switch that
connects all your nodes on the rack you
now have core switches that connect all
the racks together and these also
connect into our name node setup so now
we can look up your fs image and your
edit log and pull that information your
metadata out so we've looked at the
architecture from the name node coming
down and you have your metadata your
block locations this then sorts it out
you have your core switches which
connect everything all your different
racks and then each individual rack has
their own switches which connect all the
different nodes and to the core switches
so now let's talk about the actual data
blocks what's actually sitting on those
commodity machines and so the hadoop
file system splits massive files into
small chunks these chunks are known as
data blocks each file in the hadoop file
system is stored as a data block and we
have a nice picture here where it looks
like a lego if you ever played with the
legos as a kid it's a good example we
just stacked that data right on top of
each other but each block has to be the
same symmetry has to be the same size so
that it can track it easily and the
default size of one data block is
usually 128 megabytes now you can go in
and change that this standard is pretty
solid as far as most data is concerned
when we're loading up huge amounts of
data and there's certainly reasons to
change it 128 megabytes is pretty
standard block so why 128 megabytes if
the block size is smaller then there
will be too many data blocks along with
lots of metadata which will create
overhead so that's why you don't really
want to go smaller on these data blocks
unless you have a very certain kind of
data similarly if the block size is very
large then the processing time for each
block increases then as i pointed out
earlier each block is the same size just
like your lego blocks are all the same
but the last block can be the same size
or less so you might only be storing 100
megabytes in the last block and you can
think of this as if you had a terabyte
of data that you're storing on here it's
not going to be exactly divided into 128
megabytes we just store all of it 128
megabytes except for the last one which
could have anywhere between 1 and 128
megabytes depending on how evenly your
data is divided now let's look into how
files are stored in the hadoop file
system so we have a file a text let's
say it's 520 megabytes we have block a
so we take 128 megabytes out of the 520
and we store it in block a and then we
have block b again we're taking 128
megabytes out of our 520 storing it
there and so on block c block d and then
block e we only have eight megabytes
left so when you add up 128 plus 128
plus 128 plus 128 you only get 512 and
so the last 8 megabytes goes into its
own block the final block uses only the
remaining space for storage data node
failure and replication and this is
really where hadoop shines this is what
makes it this is why you can use it with
commodity computers this is why you can
have multiple racks and have something
go down all the data blocks are stored
in various data notes you take each
block you store it at 128 megabytes and
then we're going to put it on different
nodes so here's our block a block b
block c from our last example and we
have node 1 node 2 node 3 node 4 node 5
node 6. and so each one of these
represents a different computer it
literally splits the data up into
different machines so what happens if
node 5 crashes well that's a big deal i
mean we might not even have just node 5
you might have a whole rack go down and
if you're a company that's building your
whole business off of that you're going
to lose a lot of money so what does
happen when node 5 crashes or the first
rack goes down the data stored in node 5
will be unavailable as there is no copy
stored elsewhere in this particular
image so the hadoop file system
overcomes the issue of data node failure
by creating copies of the data this is
known as the replication method you can
see here we have our six nodes here's
our block a but instead of storing it
just on the first machine we're actually
going to store it on the second and
fourth node so now it's spread across
three different computers and in this if
these are on a rack one of these is
always on a different rack so you might
have two copies on the same rack but you
never have all three on the same rack
and you always have you never have more
than two copies on one node there's no
reason to have more than one copy per
node and you can see we do the same
thing with block b block c is then also
spread out across the different machines
and same with block d and block e node
five crashes will the data blocks b d
and e be lost well in this example no
because we have backups of all three of
those on different machines the blocks
have their copies in the other nodes due
to which the data is not lost even if
the node 5 crashes and again because
they're also stored on different racks
even if the whole rack goes down you are
still up and live with your hadoop file
system the default replication factor is
three in total we'll have three copies
of each data block now that can be
changed for different reasons or
purposes but you got to remember when
you're looking at a data center this is
all in one huge room these switches are
connecting all these servers so they can
shuffle the data back and forth really
quick and that is very important when
you're dealing with big data and you can
see here each block is by default
replicated three times that's the
standard there is very rare occasions to
do four and there's even fewer reasons
to do two blocks i've only seen four
used once and it was because they had
two data centers and so each data center
kept two different copies rack awareness
in the hadoop file system rack is a
collection of 30 to 40 data nodes rack
awareness is a concept that helps to
decide where the replica of the data
block should be stored so here we have
rack 1 we have our data node one to four
remember i was saying that it used to be
only put ten machines and then it went
to twenty now it's thirty to forty so
you can have a rack with forty servers
on it then we have rack two and rack
three and we put block one on there
replicas of block a cannot be in the
same rack and so i'll put the replicas
onto a different rack and notice that
these are actually these two are on the
same rack but you'll never have all
three stored on the same rack in case
the whole rack goes down and replicas of
block a are created in rack two and they
actually do they do by default create
the replicas onto the same rack and that
has to do with the data exchange and
maximizing your processing time and then
we have of course our block b and it's
replicated onto rack 3 and block c which
will then replicate onto rack 1 and so
on for all of your data all the way up
to block d or whatever how much ever
data you have on there hdfs architecture
so let's look at where the architecture
is a bigger picture we looked at the
name node and we store some metadata
names replicas home foo data three so it
has all your different infra your
metadata stored on there and then we
have our data nodes and you can see our
data nodes are each on different racks
with our different machines and we have
our name node and you're going to see we
have a heartbeat or pulse here and a lot
of times one of the things that confuses
people sometimes in classes they talk
about nodes versus machines so you could
have a data node that's a hadoop data
node and you could also have a spark
node on there sparks a different
architecture and these are each daemons
that are running on these computers
that's why you refer to them as nodes
and not just always as servers and
machines so even though i use them
interchangeable be aware that these
nodes you can even have virtual machines
if you're testing something out it
doesn't make sense to have 10 virtual
nodes on one machine and deploy it
because you might as well just run your
code on the machine and so we have our
heartbeat going on here and the
heartbeat is a signal that data nodes
continuously send to the name nodes this
signal shows the status of the data node
so there's a continual pulse going up
and saying hey i'm here i'm ready for
whatever instructions or data you want
to send me and you can see here we've
divided up into rack 1 and rack 2 and
our different data nodes and it also
have the replications we talked about
how to replicate data and replicates it
in three different locations and then we
have a client machine and the client
first requests the name node to read the
data now if you're not familiar with the
client machine the client is you the
programmer the client is you've logged
in external to this hadoop file system
and you're sending it instructions and
so the client whatever instructions or
script you're sending is first request a
name node to read the data the name node
allows a client to read the requested
data from the data nodes the data is
read from the data nodes and sent to the
client and so you can see here that
basically the the name node connects the
client up and says here here's a data
stream and now you have the query that
you sent out returning the data you
asked for and then of course it goes and
finishes it and says oh metadata
operations and it goes in there and
finalizes your request the other thing
the name node does is you're sending
your information because the client
sends the information in there is your
block operations so your block
operations are performs creation of data
so you're going to create new files and
folders you're going to delete the
folders and also it covers the
replication of the folders which goes on
in the background and so we can see here
that we have a nice full picture you can
see where the client machine comes in it
queues the metadata the metadata goes
into it stores a metadata and then it
goes into block operations and maybe
you're sending the data to the hadoop
file system maybe you're querying maybe
you're asking it to delete if you're
sending data in there it then does a
replication on there it goes back so you
have your data client which is writing
the data into the data node and of
course replicating it and that's all
part of the block operations and so
let's talk a little bit about read
mechanisms in the hadoop file system the
hadoop file system read mechanism we
have our hadoop file system client
that's you on your computer and the
client jvm on the client node so we have
our client jvm or the java virtual
machine that is going through and then
your client node and we're zooming in on
the read mechanism so we're looking at
this picture here as you can guess your
client is reading the data and i also
have another client down here writing
data we're going to look a little closer
at that and so we have our name node up
here we have our racks of your data
nodes and your racks of computers down
here and so our client the first thing
it does is it opens a connection up with
the distributed file system to the hdfs
and it goes hey can i get the block
locations and so it goes by using the
rpc remote procedure call it gets those
locations and the name node first checks
if the client is authorized to access
the requested file and if yes it then
provides a block location and a token to
the client which is showing to the slave
for authentication so here's the name
node it tells a client hey here's the
token the client's going to come in and
get this information from you and it
tells the client oh hey here's where the
information is so this is what is
telling your script you sent to query
your data whether you're writing your
script in one of the many setups that
you have available through the hadoop
file system or a connection through your
code and so you have your client machine
at this point then reads so your fs data
input stream comes through and you have
and you can see right here we did one
and two which is verify who you are and
give you all the information you need
then three you're going to read it from
the input stream and then the input
stream is going to grab it from the
different nodes where it's at and it'll
supply the tokens to those machines
saying hey this client needs this data
here's a token for that we're good to go
let me have the data the client will
show the authentication token to the
data nodes for the read process to begin
so after reaching the end of the data
block the connection is closed and we
can see here where we've gone through
the different steps get block locations
we have step one you open up your
connection you get the block locations
by using the rpc then you actively go
through the fs data input stream to grab
all those different data brings it back
into the client and then once it's done
it closes down that connection and then
once the client or in this case the
programmer you know manager has gone in
and pig script you can do that there's
an actual coding in each in hadoop we're
pulling data called pig or hive once you
get that data back we close the
connection delete all those randomly
huge series of tokens so they can't be
used anymore and then it's done with
that query and we'll go ahead and zoom
in just a little bit more here and let's
look at this even a little closer here's
our hadoop file system client and our
client jvm our java virtual machine on
the client node and we have the data to
be read block a block b and so we
request to read block a and b and it
goes into the name node two then it
sends the location in this case ip
addresses of the blocks for the dn1 and
dn2 where those blocks are stored then
the client interacts with the data nodes
through the switches and so you have
here the core switch so your client node
comes in three and it goes to the core
switch and that then goes to rack switch
one rack switch two and rack switch
three now if you're looking at this
you'll automatically see a point of
failure in the core switch and certainly
you want a high end switch mechanism for
your core switch you want to use
enterprise hardware for that and then
when you get to the racks that's all
commodity all your rack switches if one
of those goes down you don't care as
much you just have to get in there and
swap it in and out really quick you can
see here we have block a which is
replicated three times and so is block b
and it'll pull from there so we come in
here and here the data is read from the
dn1 and dn2 as they are the closest to
each other and so you can see here that
it's not going to read from two
different racks it's going to read from
one rack whatever the closest setup is
for that query the reason for this is if
you have 10 other queries going on you
want this one to pull all the data
through one setup and it minimizes that
traffic so the response from the data
nodes to the client that read the
operation was successful it says ah
we've read the data we're successful
which is always good we like to be
successful i don't know about you i like
to be successful so if we look at the
read mechanism let's go ahead and zoom
in and look at the right mechanism for
the hadoop file system so our hdfs write
mechanism and so when we have the hdfs
write mechanism here's our client
machine this is again the programmer on
their in computer and it's going through
the client java machine or java virtual
machine the jvm this is all occurring on
the client node somebody's office or
maybe it's on the local server for the
office so we have our name node we have
data nodes and we have the distributed
file system so the client first executes
create file on the distributed file
system says hey i'm going to create this
file over here then it goes through the
rpc call just like our read did the
client first executes create file on the
distributed file system then the dfs
interacts with the name node to create a
file name node then provides a location
to write the data and so here we have
our hdfs client and the fs data output
stream so this time instead of the data
going to the client it's coming from the
client and so here the client writes the
data through the fs data output stream
keep in mind that this output stream the
client could be a streaming code it
could be i mean you know i always refer
to the client as just being this
computer that your programmer is writing
on it could be you have your sql server
there where your data is that's current
with all your current cells and it's
archiving all that information through
scoop one of the tools in the hadoop
file system it could be streaming data
it could be a connection to the stock
servers and you're pulling stock data
down from those servers at a regular
time and that's all controlled you can
actually set that code up to be
controlled in many of the different
features in the hadoop file system and
some of the different resources you have
that sit on top of it so here the client
writes the data through the fs data
output stream and the fs data output
stream as you can see goes into right
packet so it divides it up into packets
128 megabytes and the data is written
and the slave further replicates it so
here's our data coming in and then if
you remember correctly that's part of
the fs data setup is it tells it where
to replicate it out but the data node
itself is like oh hey okay i've got the
data coming in and it's also given the
tokens of where to send the replications
to and then acknowledgement is sent
after the required replicas are made uh
so then that goes back up saying hey
successful i've written data made three
replications on this as far as our you
know going through the pipeline of the
data nodes and then that goes back and
says after the date is written the
client performs the close method so the
client's done and says okay i'm done
here's the end of the data we're
finished and after the date is written
the clan performs a closed method and we
can see here just a quick reshape we go
in there just like we did with the read
we create the connection this creates a
name node which lets it know what's
going on step two step three that also
includes uh the tokens and everything
and then we go into step three where
we're now writing through the fs data
output stream and that sorts it out into
whatever data node it's going to go to
and which also tells it how to replicate
it so that data node then sends it to
other data nodes so we have a
replication and of course you finalize
it and close everything up marks it
complete to the name node and it deletes
all those magical tokens in the
background so that they can't be reused
and we go ahead and just do this with an
example the same setups and whether
you're doing a read or write they're
very similar as we come in here from our
client and our name node and you can see
right here we actually depicting these
as the actual rack and the switch is
going on and so as the data comes in you
have your request like we saw earlier it
sends the location of the data nodes and
this actually turns your your ip
addresses your dynamic node connections
they come back to your client your hdfs
client and at that point with the tokens
it then goes into the core switch and
the core switch says hey here it goes
the client interacts with the data nodes
through the switches and you can see
here where you're writing in block a
replication of block a and a second
replication of block a on the second
server so blocking is replicated on the
second server and the third server at
this point you now have three
replications of block a and it comes
back and says it acknowledges and says
hey we're done and that goes back into
your hadoop file system to the client
who says okay we're done and finally the
success written to the name node and it
just closes everything down a quick
recap of the hadoop file system and the
advantages and so the first one is
probably one of the all of these are
huge one you have multiple data copies
are available so it's very fault
tolerant whole racks can go down
switches can go down even your main name
node could go down if you have a
secondary name node something we didn't
talk too much about is how scalable it
is because it uses distributed storage
you run into then you're oh my gosh i'm
out of space or i need to do some
heavier processing let me just add
another rack of computers so you can
scale it up very quickly it's a linear
scalability where it used to be if you
bought a server you would have to pay a
lot of money to get that the craig
computer remember the big craig
computers coming out the craig computer
runs 2 million a year just the
maintenance to liquid coolant that's
very expensive compared to just adding
more racks of computer and extending
your data center so it's very cost
effective since commodity hardware is
used we're talking cheap knockoff
computers you still need your high-end
enterprise for the name node but the
rest of them literally it is a tenth of
the cost of storing data on more
traditional high-end computers and then
the data is secure so it has a very
high-end data security provides data
security for your data so all theory and
no play doesn't make for much fun so
let's go ahead and show you what it
looks like as far as some of the
dimensions when you're getting into
polling data or putting data into the
hadoop file system and you can see here
i have oracle virtual machine virtual
box manager i have a couple of different
things loaded on there cloudera is one
of them so we should probably explain
some of these things if you're new to
virtual machines the oracle virtualbox
allows you to spin up a machine as if it
is a separate computer so in this case
this is running i believe centos linux
and it creates like a box on my computer
so the centos is running on my machine
while i'm running my windows 10 this
happens to be a windows 10 computer and
then underneath here i can actually go
under let me just open up the general
might be hard to see there and you can
see i can actually go down to system
processor i happen to be on an eight
core it has 16 dedicated threads
registers are 16 cpus but eight cores
and i've only designated this for one
cpu so it's only going to use one of my
dedicated threads on my computer and
this the oracle virtual machine is open
source you can see right here we're on
the oracle
www.oracle.com i usually just do a
search for downloading virtualbox if you
search for virtualbox all one word it
will come up with this page and then you
can download it for whatever operating
system you're working with there
certainly are a number of different
options and let me go and point those
out if you're setting this up as a for
demoing for yourself the first thing to
note for doing a virtual box and doing a
cloudera or horton setup on that virtual
box for doing the hadoop system to try
it out you need a minimum of 12
gigabytes it cannot be a windows 10 home
edition because you'll have problems
with your virtual setup and sometimes
you have to go turn on the virtual
settings so it knows it's in there so if
you're on a home setup there are other
sources there's cloudera and we'll talk
a little bit about clardera here in just
a second but they have the cloudera
online live we can go try the cloudera
setup i've never used it but cloudera is
a pretty good company cloudera and
hortonworks are two of the common ones
out there and we'll actually be running
a cloudera hadoop cluster on on our demo
here so you have oracle virtual machine
you also have the option of doing it on
different vmware that's another one like
virtual machine this is more of a paid
service there is a free setup for just
doing it for yourself which will work
fine for this and then in the cloudera
like again they have the new online
setup where you can go in there to the
online and for cloudera you want to go
underneath the cloudera quick start if
you type in a search for cloudera quick
start it'll bring you to this website
and then you can select your platform in
this case i did virtualbox there's
vmware we just talked about docker
docker is a very high-end virtual setup
unless you already know it you really
don't want to mess with it then your kvm
is if you're on a linux computer that
sets up multiple systems on that
computer so the two you really want to
use are usually the virtual box or do an
online setup and you can see here with
the download if you're going into the
horton version it's called hortonworks
and they call it sandbox so you'll see
the term hortonworks sandbox and these
are all test demos you're not going to
deploy a single node hadoop systems that
would just be kind of ridiculous and
defeat the whole purpose of having a
horton or having a hadoop system if it's
only installed on one computer in a
virtual node so a lot of different
options if you're not on a professional
windows version or you don't have at
least 12 gigabytes ram to run this uh
you'll want to try and see if you can
find an online version and of course
simply learn has our own labs if you
sign up for our classes we set you up i
don't know what it is now but last time
i was in there was a five node uh setup
so you can get around and see what's
going on whether you're studying for the
admin side or for the programming side
in script writing and if i go into my
oracle virtual box and i go under my
cloudera and i start this up and each
one has their own flavors um horton uses
just a login so you log everything in
through a local host through your
internet explorer or i might use chrome
cloudera actually opens up a full
interface so you actually are in that
setup and you can see when i started it
let me go back here once i downloaded
this this is a big download by the way i
had to import the appliance in
virtualbox the first time i ran it it
takes a long time to configure the setup
and the second time it comes up pretty
quick and with the cloudera quick start
again this is a pretend single node it
opens up and you'll see that it actually
has firefox here so here's my web
browser i don't have to go to local host
i'm actually already in the quick start
for cloudera and if we come down here
you can see getting started i have some
information analyze your data manage
your cluster your general information on
there and what i always want to start to
do is to go ahead and open up a terminal
window so we'll open up a terminal widen
this a little bit let me just maximize
this out here so you can see so we are
now in a virtual machine this virtual
machine is centos linux so i'm on a
linux computer on my windows computer
and so when i'm on this terminal window
this is your basic terminal if i do list
you'll see documents eclipse these are
the different things that are installed
with the quick start guide on the linux
system so this is a linux computer and
then hadoop is running on here so now i
have hadoop single node so it has both
the name node and the data node and
everything squished together in one
virtual machine we can then do let's do
hdfs telling it that it's a hadoop file
system dfs minus ls now notice the ls is
the same i have ls for list and ls for
list and i click on here it'll take you
just a second reading the hadoop file
system and it comes up with nothing so a
quick recap let's go back over this
three different environments i have this
one out here let's just put this in a
bright red so you can actually see it i
have this environment out here which is
my slides i have this environment here
or i did a list that's looking at the
files on the linuxcentos computer and
then we have this system here which is
looking at the files on the hadoop file
system so three completely separate
environments and then we connect them
and so right now we have i have whatever
files i have my personal files and the
um of course we're also looking at the
screen for my windows 10 and then we're
looking at the screen here
here's our list there let's look at the
files and this is the screen for centos
linux and then this is looking at the
files right here for the hadoop file
system so three completely separate
files this one here which is the linux
is running in a virtual box so this is a
virtual box i'm using one core to run it
or one cpu and everything in there is it
has its own file system you can see we
have our desktop and documents and
whatever in there and then you can see
here we right now have no files in our
hadoop file system and this hadoop file
system currently is stored on the linux
machine but it could be stored across 10
linux machines 20 100 this could be
stored across in petabytes i mean it
could be really huge or it could just be
in this case just a demo or putting it
on just one computer and then once we're
in here let me just see real quick if i
can go under view zoom in view zoom in
and this is just a standard browser so i
can use any like the control plus and
stuff like that to zoom in and this is
very common to be in a browser window
with the hadoop file system so right now
i'm in a linux and i'm going to do oh
let's just create a file we'll go file
my new file and i'm going to use vi and
this is a vi editor just a basic editor
and we go ahead and type something in
here
one two
three four maybe it's columns 44 66 77.
of course i do file system just like
your regular computer can also so in our
vi editor you hit your colon i actually
work with a lot of different other
editors and we'll write quit vi so let's
take a look and see what happened here
i'm in my linux system i type in ls for
list and we should see my new file and
sure enough we do over here there it is
let me just highlight that my new file
and if i then go into the hadoop system
hdfs dfs minus ls for list we still show
nothing it's still empty so what i can
simply do is i can go hdfs dfs
minus put and i'm going to put my new
file and this is just going to move it
from the linux system because i'm in
this file folder into the hadoop file
system and now if we go in and we type
in our list for a new file system you
will see in here that i now have just
the one file on there which is my new
file and very similar to linux we can do
cat and the cat command simply evokes
reading the file so hd fs dfs minus cat
and i had to look it up remember
cloudera the the format is going to be a
user uh then of course the
path location and the file name and in
here when we did the list here's our
list so you can see it lists our file
here and we realize that this is under
uh user cloudera and so i can now go
user cloudera my new file and the minus
cat and we'll be able to read the file
in here and you can see right here this
is the file that was in the linux system
is now copied into the cloudera system
and it's one three four five that what i
entered in there and if we go back to
the linux and do list you'll still see
it in here my new file and we can also
do something like this in our hdfs minus
mv i will do my new file and we're going
to change it to my new new file and if
we do that
underneath our hadoop file system the
minus mv will rename it so if i go back
here to our hadoop file system ls you'll
now see instead of my new file it has my
new new file coming up and there it is
my new new files we've renamed it we can
also go in here and
delete this so i can now come in here so
in our hdfs dfs we can also do a remove
and this will remove the file and so if
we come in here we run this we'll see
that when i come back and do the list
the file is gone and now we just have
another empty
folder with our hadoop file system and
just like any file system we can take
this and we can go ahead and make
directory create a new directory so mk
for make directory we'll call this my
dir so we're going to make a directory
in my dir it'll take it just a second
and of course if we do
the list command you'll see that we now
have the directory in there give it just
a second there it comes my dir and just
like we did before i can go in here and
we're gonna put the file and if you
remember correctly from our files in the
setup i called it my new file so this is
coming from the linux system and we're
going to put that into my dir that's the
target in my hadoop setup and so if i
hit enter on there i can now do
the hadoop list and that's not going to
show the file because remember i put it
in a sub folder so if i should do the
kadroop just this will show my directory
and i can do list and then i can do my
dur for my directory and you'll see
underneath the my directory in the
hadoop file system it now has my new
file put in there and with any good
operating system we need a minus help so
just like you can type in help in your
linux you can now come in here and type
in hdfs help and it shows you a lot of
the commands in there underneath the
hadoop file system most of them should
be very similar to the linux on here and
we can also do something like this uh
hadoop version and the hadoop version
shows up that we're in hadoop 2.60
cdh is it we're cloudera 5 and compiled
by jenkins and it has a date and all the
different information on our hadoop file
system so this is some basics in the
terminal window let me go ahead and
close this out because if you're going
to play with this you should really come
in here let me just maximize the cloud
data it opens up in a browser window and
so once we're in here again this is a
browser window which you could access
might look like any access for a hadoop
file system one of the fun things to do
when you're first starting is to go
under hue you'll see it up here at the
top has cloudera hue hadoop your hbase
your impala your spark these are
standard installs now and hue is
basically an overview of the file system
and so come up here and you can see
where you can do queries as far as if
you have a hbase or a hive the hive
database we go over here to the top
where it says file browser and if we go
under file browser now this is a hadoop
file system we're looking at and once we
open up the file browser you can now see
there's my directory which we created
and if i click on my directory there's
my new file which is in here and if i
click on my new file it actually opens
it up and you can see from our hadoop
file system this is in the hadoop file
system the file that we created so we
covered the terminal window you can see
here's a terminal window up here it
might be if you were in a web browser
it'll look a little different because it
actually opens up as a web browser
terminal window and we've looked a
little bit at hue which is one of the
most basic components of hadoop one of
the original components for going
through and looking at your data and
your databases of course now they're up
to uh the hue four it's gone through a
number of changes and you can see
there's a lot of different choices in
here for other different tools in the
hadoop file system and i'll go ahead and
just close out of this and one of the
cool things with the virtual
box i can either save the machine state
send the shutdown signal or power off
the machine i'll go and just power off
the machine completely now suppose you
have a library that has a collection of
huge number of books on each floor and
you want to count the total number of
books present on each floor what would
be your approach you could say i will do
it myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you could then say if each friend could
count the books on every floor then
obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing so when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you're talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its ram and cpu cores for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person 1 who would be taking
care of books on floor 1 and counting
them person 2 on floor 2 then you have
someone on floor 3 and someone on floor
4. so every individual would be counting
the books on every floor in parallel so
that reduces the time consumed for this
activity and then there should be some
mechanism where all these counts from
every floor can be aggregated so what is
each person doing here each person is
mapping the data of a particular floor
or you can say each person is doing a
kind of activity or basically a task on
every floor and the task is counting the
books on every floor now then you could
have some aggregation mechanism that
could basically reduce or summarize this
total count and in terms of map reduce
we would say that's the work of reducer
so when you talk about hadoop map reduce
it processes data on different node
machines now this is the whole concept
of hadoop framework right that you not
only have your data stored across
machines but you would also want to
process the data locally so instead of
transferring the data from one machine
to other machine or bringing all the
data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data processed
on the machines wherever that is stored
so we know in case of hadoop cluster we
would have our data stored on multiple
data nodes on their multiple disks and
that is the data which needs to be
processed but the requirement is that we
want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
mapreduce
we basically have the first phase which
is your mapping phase so in case of
mapreduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes in parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your
mapreduce works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about mapreduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of
hadoop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes exabytes and that amount of
data which needs to be processed on a
huge cluster we could also use mapreduce
programming model and run a mapreduce
algorithm in a local mode but what does
that mean if you would go for a local
mode it basically means it would do all
the mapping and reducing on the same
node using the processing capacity that
is ram and cpu cores on the same machine
which is not really efficient in fact we
would want to have our map reduce work
on multiple nodes which would obviously
have mapping phase followed by a
reducing phase and intermittently there
would be data generated there would be
different other phases which help this
whole processing so when you talk about
hadoop map reduce you are mainly talking
about two main components or two main
phases that is mapping and reducing
mapping taking care of map tasks
reducing taking care of reduced tasks so
you would have your data which would be
stored on multiple machines now when we
talk about data data could be in
different formats we could or the
developer could specify what is the
format which needs to be used to
understand the data which is coming in
that data then goes through the mapping
internally there would be some shuffling
sorting and then reducing which gives
you your final output so the way we
access data from sdfs or the way our
data is getting stored on sdfs we have
our input data which would have one or
multiple files in one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 mb which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if i have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster i would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of blocks
creating a load on name notes ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map task doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function which basically says
what each of these map tasks has to do
on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to sdfs where it is sorted and
shuffled and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which decides
how many reduce tasks would be used or
what data goes to which reducer you
could also have a combiner phase which
is like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
reduce then you have your reducing phase
which is taken care by a reducer class
and internally the reducer function
provided by developer which would have
reduced task running on the data which
comes as an output from map tasks
finally your output is then generated
which is stored on sdfs now in case of
hadoop it accepts data in different
formats your data could be in compressed
format your data could be in part k your
data could be in afro text csv psv
binary format and all of these formats
are supported however remember if you
are talking about data being compressed
then you have to also look into what
kind of split ability the compression
mechanism supports otherwise when
mapreduce processing happens it would
take the complete file as one chunk to
be processed so sdfs accepts input data
in different formats this data is stored
in sdfs and that is basically our input
which is then passing through the
mapping phase now what is mapping phase
doing as i said it reads record by
record depending on the input format it
reads the data so we have multiple map
tasks running on multiple chunks once
this data is being read this is broken
down into individual elements and when i
say individual element i could say this
is my list of key value pairs so your
records based on some kind of delimiter
or without delimiter are broken down
into individual elements and thus your
mac creates key value pairs now these
key value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller tuples or tuples as you would
say finally your output is getting
stored in the
designated directory as a list of
aggregated key value pairs which gives
you your output so when we talk about
mapreduce one of the key factors here is
the parallel processing which it can
offer so we know that we have a data is
getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs to be processed
and the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on multiple data nodes or
multiple slave nodes in each slave node
would have again one or multiple disks
to process this data basically we have
to go for parallel processing approach
we have to use the map reduce now let's
look at the mapreduce workflow to
understand how it works so basically you
have your input data stored on sdfs now
this is the data which needs to be
processed it is stored in input files
and the processing which you want can be
done on one single file or it can be
done on a directory which has multiple
files you could also later have multiple
outputs merged which we achieve by using
something called as chaining of mappers
so here you have your data getting
stored on sdfs now input format is
basically something to define the input
specification and how the input files
will be split so there are various input
formats now we can search for that so we
can go to google and we can basically
search for
hadoop map reduce
yahoo tutorial this is one of the good
links and if i look into this link i can
search for different input formats and
output formats so let's search for input
format so when we talk about input
format you basically have something to
define how input files are split so
input files are split up and read based
on what input format is specified so
this is a class that provides following
functionality it selects the files or
other objects that should be used for
input it defines the input split that
break a file into tasks provides a
factory for record reader objects that
read the file so there are different
formats if you look in the table here
and you can see that the text input
format is the default format which reads
lines of a text file and each line is
considered as a record here the key is
the byte offset of the line and the
value is the line content it says you
can have key value input format which
passes lines into key value pairs
everything up to the first tab character
is the key and the remainder is the line
you could also have sequence file input
format which basically works on binary
format so you have input format and in
the same way you can also search for
output format which takes care of how
the data is handled after the processing
is done so the key value pairs provided
to this output collector are then
written to output files the way they are
written is governed by output format so
it functions pretty much like input
format as described in earlier right so
we could set what is the output format
to be followed and again you have text
output sequence file output format null
output format and so on so these are
different classes which take care of how
your data is handled when it is being
read for processing or how is the data
being written when the processing is
done so based on the input format the
file is broken down into splits and this
logically represents the data to be
processed by individual map tasks or you
could say individual mapper functions so
you could have one or multiple splits
which need to be processed depending on
the file size depending on what
properties have been set now once this
is done you have your input splits which
are subjected to mapping phase
internally you have a record reader
which communicates with the input split
and converts the data into key value
pairs suitable to be read by mapper and
what is mapper doing it is basically
working on these key value pairs the map
task giving you an intermittent output
which would then be forwarded for
further processing now once that is done
and we have these key value pairs which
is being worked upon my map your map
tasks as a part of your mapper function
are generating your key value pairs
which are your intermediate outputs to
be processed further now you could have
as i said a combiner face or internally
a mini radio surface now combiner does
not have its own class so combiner
basically uses the same class as the
reducer class provided by the developer
and its main work is to do the reducing
or its main work is to do some kind of
mini aggregation on the key value pairs
which were generated by map so once the
data is coming in from the combiner then
we have internally a partitioner phase
which decides how outputs from combiners
are sent to the reducers or you could
also say that even if i did not have a
combiner partitioner would decide based
on the keys and values based on the type
of keys how many reducers would be
required or how many reduced tasks would
be required to work on your output which
was generated by map task now once
partitioner has decided that then your
data would be then sorted and shuffled
which is then fed into the reducer so
when you talk about your reducer it
would basically have one or multiple
reduced tasks now that depends on what
or what partition decided or determined
for your data to be processed it can
also depend on the configuration
properties which have been set to decide
how many radio stars should be used now
internally all this data is obviously
going through sorting and shuffling so
that your reducing or aggregation
becomes an easier task once we have this
done we basically have the reducer which
is the code for the reducer is provided
by the developer and all the
intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the
output files now this is how your
mapreduce works wherein the final output
data can be not only stored but then
read or access from sdfs or even used as
an input for further mapreduce kind of
processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically means one or multiple
map tasks working on your chunks of data
you could have a combiner face which is
optional which is not mandatory then you
have a partitioner phase which decides
on how many reduced tasks or how many
reducers would be used to work on your
data internally there is sorting and
shuffling of data happening and then
basically based on your output format
your record reader will write the output
to sdfs directory now internally you
could also remember that data is being
processed locally so you would have the
output of each task which is being
worked upon stored locally however we do
not access the data directly from data
nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
mapreduce workflow when you talk about
mapreduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically a edge node or a client
program or an api which intends to
process some data so it submits the job
to the job tracker or you can say
resource manager in case of hadoop yarn
framework right now before this step we
can also say that an interaction with
name node would have already happened
which would have given information of
data nodes which have the relevant data
stored then your master processor so in
hadoop version 1 we had job tracker and
then the slaves were called task
trackers in hadoop version 2 instead of
job tracker you have resource manager
instead of task trackers you have node
managers so basically your resource
manager has to assign the job to the
task trackers or node managers so your
node managers as we discussed in yarn
are basically taking care of processing
which happens on every note so
internally there is all of this work
happening by resource manager node
managers and application master then you
can refer to the yarn based tutorial to
understand more about that so here your
processing master is basically breaking
down the application into tasks what it
does internally is once your application
is submitted your application to be run
on yarn processing framework is handled
by resource manager now forget about the
yarn part as of now i mean who does the
negotiating of resources who allocates
them how does the processing happen on
the nodes right so that's all to do with
how yarn handles the processing request
so you have your data which is stored in
sdfs broken down into one or multiple
splits depending on the input format
which has been specified by the
developer your input splits are to be
worked upon by your one or multiple map
tasks which will be running within the
container on the nodes basically you
have the resources which are being
utilized so for each map task you would
have some amount of ram which will be
utilized and then further the same data
which has to go through reducing phase
that is your reduced task will also be
utilizing some ram and cpu cores now
internally you have these functions
which take care of deciding on number of
reducers doing a mini reduce and
basically reading and processing the
data from multiple data nodes now this
is how your mapreduce programming model
makes parallel processing work or
processes your data which is stored
across multiple machines finally you
have your output which is getting stored
on his dfs
so let's have a quick demo on mapreduce
and see how it works on a hadoop cluster
now we have discussed briefly about
mapreduce which contains mainly two
phases that is your mapping phase and
your reducing phase and mapping phase is
taken care by your mapper function and
your reducing phase is taken care by
your reducer function now in between we
also have sorting and shuffling and then
you have other phases which is
partitioner and combiner and we will
discuss about all those in detail in
later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a mapreduce which
is already existing as a package jar
file within your apache hadoop cluster
or even in your cloudera cluster now we
can build our own mapreduce programs we
can package them as jar transfer them to
the cluster and then run it on a hadoop
cluster on yarn or we could be using
already provided default program so
let's see where they are now these are
my two machines which i have brought up
and basically this would have my apache
hadoop cluster running now we can just
do a simple start hyphen all dot sh now
i know that this script is deprecated
and it says instead use start dfs and
start yarn but then it will still take
care of starting off my cluster on these
two nodes where i would have one single
name node two data nodes one secondary
name node one resource manager and two
node managers now if you have any doubt
in how this cluster came up you can
always look at the previous sessions
where we had a walkthrough in setting up
a cluster on apache and then you could
also have your cluster running using
less than 3gb of your total machine ram
and you could have apache cluster
running on your machine now once this
cluster comes up we will also have a
look at the web ui which is available
for name node and resource manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the ui is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up i
can just do a jps to look at java
related processes and that will show me
what are the processes which are running
on c1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my m1 machine which is my second
machine which i've configured here i can
always do a jps and that shows me the
process is running which also means that
my cluster is up with two data nodes
with two node managers and here i can
have a look at my web ui so i can just
do a refresh and the same thing with
this one just to refresh so i had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web ui using your name
notes hostname and 570 port it tells me
what is my cluster id what is my blog
pool id it gives you information of what
is the space usage how many live notes
you have and you can even browse your
file system so i have put in a lot of
data here i can click on browse the file
system and this basically shows me
multiple directories and these
directories have one or multiple files
which we will use for our mapreduce
example now if you see here these are my
directories which have some sample files
although these files are very small like
8.7 kilobytes if you look into this
directory if you look into this i have
just pulled in some of my hadoop logs
and i have put it on my sdfs these are a
little bigger files and then we also
have some other data which we can see
here and this is data which i have
downloaded from web now we can either
run a mapreduce on a single file or in a
directory which contains multiple files
let's look at that before looking at
demo and map reduce also remember
mapreduce will create a output directory
and we need to have that directory
created plus we need to have the
permissions to run the mapreduce job so
by default since i'm running it using
admin id i should not have any problem
but then if you intend to run mapreduce
with a different user then obviously you
will have to ask the admin or you will
have to give the user permission to read
and write from sdfs so this is the
directory which i've created which will
contain my output once the mapreduce job
finishes and this is my cluster file
system if you look on this ui this shows
me about my yarn which is available for
taking care of any processing it as of
now shows that i have total of 8 gb
memory and i have 8 v cores now that can
be depending on what configuration we
have set or how many nodes are available
we can look at nodes which are available
and that shows me i have two node
managers running each has 8 gb memory
and 8 vcores now that's not true
actually but then we have not set the
configurations for node managers and
that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8gb laminate we
course now this is my yarn ui we can
also look at scheduler which basically
shows me the different queues if they
have been configured where you will have
to run the jobs we'll discuss about all
these in later in detail now let's go
back to our terminal and let's see where
we can find some sample applications
which we can run on the cluster so once
i go to the terminal i can well submit
the mapreduce job from any terminal now
here i know that my hadoop related
directory is here and within hadoop you
have various directories we have
discussed that in binaries you have the
commands which you can run in s bin you
basically have the startup scripts and
here you also notice there is a share
directory in the end if you look in the
shared directory you would find hadoop
and within hadoop you have various sub
directories in which we will look for
mapreduce now this mapreduce directory
has some sample jar files which we can
use to run a mapreduce on the cluster
similarly if you are working on a
cloudera cluster you would have to go
into opt cloudera parcel cdh slash lib
and in that you would have directories
for sdfs mapreduce or sdfs yarn where
you can still find the same jars it is
basically a package which contains your
multiple applications now how do we run
a mapreduce we can just type in hadoop
and hit enter and that shows me that i
have an option called jar which can be
used to run a jar file now at any point
of time if you would want to see what
are the different classes which are
available in a particular
jar you could always do a jar minus xvf
for example i could say jar xv xvf and i
could say user local hadoop share hadoop
mapreduce and then list down your jar
file so i'll say hadoop mapreduce
examples and if i do this this should
basically unpack it to show me what
classes are available within this
particular jar and it has done this it
has created a meta file and it has
created a org directory we can see that
by doing a ls and here if you look in ls
org since i ran the command from your
phone directory i can look into org
patchy hadoop examples which shows me
the classes which i have and those
classes contain which mapper or reducer
classes so it might not be just mapper
and reducer but you can always have a
look so for example i am targeting to
use word count program which does a word
count on files and gives me a list of
words and how many times they occur in a
particular file or in set of files and
this shows me that what are the classes
which belong to word count so we have a
int sum reducer so this is my reducer
class i have tokenizer mapper that is my
mapper class right and basically this is
what is used these classes are used if
you run a word code now there are many
other programs which are part of this
jar file and we can expand and see that
so i can say hadoop jar and give your
path so i'll say hadoop jar user local
hadoop share hadoop map reduce hadoop
mapreduce examples and if i hit on enter
that will show me what are the inbuilt
classes which are already available now
these are certain things which we can
use now there are other jar files also
for example i can look at hadoop and
here we can look at the jar files which
we have in this particular path so this
is one hadoop mapreduce examples which
you can use you can always look in other
jar files like you can look for
hadoop mapreduce client job client and
then you can look at the test one so
that is also an interesting one so you
can always look into hadoop mapreduce
client job client and then you have
something ending with this so if i would
have tried this one using my hadoop jar
command so in my previous example when
we did this it was showing me all the
classes which are available and that
already has a word count now there are
other good programs which you can try
like teragen to generate dummy data
terasort to check your sorting
performance and so on and terra validate
to validate the results similarly we can
also do a hadoop jar as i said on hadoop
mapreduce i think that was client and
then we have job client and then test
star now this has a lot of other classes
which can be used or programs which can
be used for doing a stress testing or
checking your cluster status and so on
one of them interesting one is test dfs
io but let's not get into all the
details in first instance let's see how
we can run a mapreduce now if i would
want to run a mapreduce i need to give
hadoop jar and then my jar file and if i
hit on enter it would say it needs the
input and output it needs which class
you want to run so for example i would
say word count and again if i hit on
enter it tells me that you need to give
me some input and output to process and
obviously this processing will be
happening on cluster that is our yarn
processing framework unless and until
you would want to run this job in a
local mode so there is a possibility
that you can run the job in local mode
but let's first try how it runs on the
cluster so how do we do that now here i
can do a hdfs
ls slash command to see what i have on
my sdfs now through my ui i was already
showing you that we have set of files
and directories which we can use to
process now we can take up one single
file so for example if i pick up new
data and i can look into the files here
what we have and we can basically run a
mapreduce on a single file or multiple
files so let's take this file whatever
that contains and i would like to do a
word count so that i get a list of words
and their occurrence in this file so let
me just copy this now i also need my
output to be written and that will be
written here so here if i want to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop which we can
pull out from history so hadoop jar word
count now i need to give my input so
that will be new data and then i will
give this file which we just copied now
i am going to run the word count only on
a single file and i will basically have
my output which will be stored in this
directory the directory which you have
created already mr output so let's do
this
output and this is fair enough now you
can give many other properties you can
specify how many map jobs you want to
run how many reduced jobs you want to
run do you want your output to be
compressed do you want your output to be
merged or many other properties can be
defined when you are specifying word
count and then you can pass in an
argument to pass properties from the
command line which will affect your
output now once i go ahead and submit
this this is basically running a simple
inbuilt mapreduce job on our hadoop
cluster now obviously internally it will
be looking for name node now we have
some issue here and it says the output
already exists what does that mean so it
basically means that hadoop will create
an output for you you just need to give
a name but then you don't need to create
it so let's give let's append the output
with number one and then let's go ahead
and run this so i've submitted this
command now this can also be done in
background if you would want to run
multiple jobs on your cluster at the
same time so it takes total input paths
to processes one so that is there is
only one split on which your job has to
work now it will internally try to
contact your resource manager and
basically this is done so here we can
have a look and we can see some counters
here now what i also see is
for some property which it is missing it
has run the job but it has run in a
local mode it has run in a local mode so
although we have submitted so this might
be related to my yarn settings and we
can check that so if i do a refresh when
i have run my application it has
completed it would have created an
output but the only thing is it did not
interact with your yarn it did not
interact with your resource manager we
can check those properties and here if
we look into the job it basically tells
me that it went for mapping and reducing
it would have created an output it
worked on my file but then it ran in a
local mode it ran in a local mode so
mapreduce remember is a programming
model right now if you run it on yarn
you get the facilities of running it on
a cluster where yarn takes care of
resource management if you don't run it
on yarn and run it on a local mode it
will use your machines ram and cpu cores
for processing but then we can quickly
look at the output and then we can also
try running this on yarn so if i look
into my hdfs and if i look into my
output mr output that's the directory
which was not used actually let's look
into the other directory which is ending
with one and that should show me the
output created by this mapreduce
although it ran in the local mode it
fetched an input file from usdfs and it
would have created output in hdfs now
that's my part file which is created and
if you look at part minus r minus these
zeros if you would have more than one
reducer running then you would have
multiple such files created we can look
into this what does this file contain
which should have my word count and here
i can say cat which basically shows me
what is the output created by my
mapreduce let's have a look into this so
the file which we gave for processing
has been broken down and now we have the
list of words which occur in the file
plus a count of those words so if there
is some word which is in is more then it
shows me the count so this is a list of
my words and the count for that so this
is how we run a sample mapreduce job i
will also show you how we can run it on
yeah now let's run mapreduce on yarn and
initially when we tried running a
mapreduce it did not hit yarn but it ran
in a local mode and that was because
there was a property which had to be
changed in mapreduce hyphen site file so
basically if you look into this file the
error was that i had given a property
which says
mapred.framework.org
and that was not the right property name
and it was ignored and that's why it ran
in a local mode so i changed the
property to mapreduce.framework.name
restarted my cluster and everything
should be fine now and that map red
hyphen site file has also been copied
across the nodes now to run a mapreduce
on a hadoop cluster so that it uses yarn
and yarn takes care of resource
allocation on one or multiple machines
so i'm just changing the output here and
now i will submit this job which should
first connect to the resource manager
and if it connects to the resource
manager that means our job will be run
using yarn on the cluster rather than in
a local mode so now we have to wait for
this application to internally connect
to resource manager and once it starts
there we can always go back to the web
ui and check if our application has
reached yarn so it shows me that there
is one input part to be processed that's
my job id that's my application id which
you can even monitor status from the
command line now here the job has been
submitted so let's go back here and just
do a refresh on my yarn ui which should
show me the new application which is
submitted it tells me that it is an
accepted state application master has
already started and if you click on this
link it will also give you more details
of how many map and reduce tasks would
run so as of now it says the application
master is running it would be using this
node which is m1 we can always look into
the logs we can see that there is a one
task attempt which is being made and now
if i go back to my terminal i will see
that it is waiting to get some resources
from the cluster and once it gets the
resources it will first start with the
mapping phase where the mapper function
runs it does the map tasks one or
multiple depending on the splits so
right now we have one file and one split
so we will have just one map task
running and once the mapping phase
completes then it will get into reducing
which will finally give me my output so
we can be toggling through these
sessions so here i can just do a refresh
to see what is happening with my
application is it proceeding is it still
waiting for resource manager to allocate
some resources now just couple of
minutes back i tested this application
on yarn and we can see that my first
application completed successfully and
here we will have to give some time so
that yarn can allocate the resources now
if the resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally yarn takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
yarn or you might have already followed
the yarn based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what yarn can
allocate to it sometimes you can also
see a slowness in what web ui shows up
and that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your notes
now for apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as i said the memory which
shows up here 16 gb and 16 cores is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my yarn should
be able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it a couple
of seconds and then let's look into the
output here again i had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically i restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager
and then basically the map and reduce
process should start so here i have
submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
an app master that is application master
it is looking for the number of splits
which is one it's getting the
application id and it basically then
starts running the job it also gives you
a tracking url to look at the output and
now we should go back and look at our
yarn ui if our application shows up here
and we will have to give it a couple of
seconds when it can get the final status
change to running and that's where my
application will be getting resources
now if you closely notice here i have
allocated specific amount of memory that
is 1.5 gb for node manager on every node
and i have basically given two cores
each which my machines also have and my
yarn should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving
and we can see the progress bar here
which basically will show what is
happening and if we go back to the
terminal it will show that first it went
in deciding map and reduce it goes for
map once the mapping phase completes
then the reducing phase will come into
existence and here my job has completed
so now it has basically used we can
always look at how many map and reduce
sas were run it shows me that there was
one map and one reduced task now with
the number of map tasks depends on the
number of splits and we had just one
file which is less than 128 mb so that
was one split to be processed and
reduced task is internally decided by
the reducer or depending on what kind of
property has been set in hadoop config
files now it also tells me how many
input records were read which basically
means these were the number of lines in
the file it tells me output records
which gives me the number of total words
in the file now there might be
duplicates and that which is processed
by internal combiner further processing
or forwarding that information to
reducer and basically reducer works on 3
35 records gives us a list of words and
their account now if i do a refresh here
this would obviously show my application
is completed it says succeeded you can
always click on the application to look
for more information it tells me where
it ran now we do not have a history
server running as of now otherwise we
can always access more information so
this leads to history server where all
your applications are stored but i can
click on this attempt tasks and this
will basically show me the history url
or you can always look into the logs so
this is how you can submit a sample
application which is inbuilt which is
available in the jar on your hadoop
cluster and that will utilize your
cluster to run now you could always as i
said when you are running a particular
job remember to change the output
directory and if you would not want it
to be processing is a single individual
file you could also point it to a
directory that basically means it will
have multiple files and depending on the
file sizes there would be multiple
splits and according to that multiple
map tasks will be selected so if i click
on this this would submit my second
application to the cluster which should
first connect to resource manager then
resource manager has to start an
application master now here we are
targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my yarn provides it the resources we
will have the application running on our
yarn cluster so it has already started
if you see it is going further then it
would launch 10 map tasks and it would
the number of reduced stars would be
decided on either the way your data is
or based on the properties which have
been set at your cluster level let's
just do a quick refresh here on my yarn
ui to show me the progress also take
care that when you are submitting your
application you need to have the output
directory mentioned however do not
create it hadoop will create that for
you now this is how you run a map reduce
without specifying properties but then
you can specify more properties you can
look into what are the things which can
be changed for your mapper and reducer
or basically having a combiner class
which can do a mini reducing and all
those things can be done so we will
learn about that in the later sessions
now we will compare hadoop version one
that is with mapreduce version one we
will understand and learn about the
limitations of hadoop version one what
is the need of yarn what is yarn what
kind of workloads can be running on yarn
what are yarn components what is yarn
architecture and finally we will see a
demo on yarn so hadoop version one or
mapreduce version one well that's
outdated now and nobody is using hadoop
version 1 but it would be good to
understand what was in hadoop version 1
and what were the limitations of hadoop
version 1 which brought in the thought
for the future processing layer that is
yarn now when we talk about hadoop we
already know that hadoop is a framework
and hadoop has two layers one is your
storage layer that is your sdfs hadoop
distributed file system which allows for
distributed storage and processing which
allows fault tolerance by inbuilt
replication and which basically allows
you to store huge amount of data across
multiple commodity machines when we talk
about processing we know that mapreduce
is the oldest and the most mature
processing programming model which
basically takes care of your data
processing on your distributed file
system so in hadoop person one mapreduce
performed both data processing and
resource management and that's how it
was problematic in mapreduce we had
basically when we talked about the
processing layer we had the master which
was called job tracker and then you had
the slaves which were the task records
so your job tracker was taking care of
allocating resources it was performing
scheduling and even monitoring the jobs
it basically was taking care of
assigning map and reduced tasks to the
jobs running on task trackers and task
trackers which were co-located with data
nodes were responsible for processing
the jobs so task trackers were the
slaves for the processing layer which
reported their progress to the job
tracker so this is what was happening in
hadoop version 1. now when we talk about
hadoop version 1 we would have say
client machines or an api or an
application which basically submits the
job to the master that is job tracker
now obviously we cannot forget that
there would already be an involvement
from name node which basically tells
which are the machines or which are the
data nodes where the data is already
stored now once the job submission
happens to the job tracker job tracker
being the master demon for taking care
of your processing request and also
resource management job scheduling would
then be interacting with your multiple
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines so each machine would
have a task tracker running and that
task tracker which is a processing slave
would be co-located with the data nodes
now we know that in case of hadoop you
have the concept of moving the
processing to wherever the data is
stored rather than moving the data to
the processing layer so we would have
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines and these stars
trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how many resources and when we
talk about resources we are talking
about the cpu cores we are talking about
the ram which would be available on
every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave demons
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was
eventually overburdened right because it
was managing jobs it was tracking the
resources from multiple task trackers
and basically it was taking care of job
scheduling so job tracker would be
overburdened and in a case if job
tracker would fail then it would affect
the overall processing so if the master
is killed if the master demand dies then
the processing cannot proceed now this
was one of the limitations of hadoop
version one so when you talk about
scalability that is the capability to
scale due to a single job tracker
scalability would be hitting a
bottleneck you cannot have a cluster
size of more than 4000 nodes and cannot
run more than 40 000 concurrent tasks
now that's just a number we could always
look into the individual resources which
each machine was having and then we can
come up with an appropriate number
however with a single job tracker there
was no horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as i mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a processing
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be more available and could
handle different kind of workloads when
it comes to resource utilization now if
you would have a predefined number of
map and reduce slots for each task
tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non-map reduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of hadoop version 1 and
mapreduce that the only kind of
processing you could do is mapreduce and
mapreduce programming model although it
is good it is oldest it has matured over
a period of time but then it is very
rigid you will have to go for mapping
and reducing approach and that was the
only kind of processing which could be
done in hadoop person one so when it
comes to doing a real time analysis or
doing ad hoc query or doing a graph
based processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in hadoop
version 1 which was having mapreduce
version 1 as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for yarn
so yarn it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as i mentioned
before yarn in hadoop version one well
you could have applications which could
be written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was
mapreduce we had the storage layer we
had the processing but then kind of
limited processing which could be done
now this was one thing which brought in
a thought that why shouldn't we have a
processing layer which can handle
different kind of workloads as i
mentioned might be graph processing
might be real time processing might be
massive parallel processing or any other
kind of processing which would be a
requirement of an organization now
designed to run map-reduce jobs only and
having issues in scalability resource
utilization job tracking etc that led to
the need of something what we call as
yarn now from hadoop version 2 onwards
we have the two main layers have changed
a little bit you have the storage layer
which is intact that is your hdfs and
then you have the processing layer which
is called yarn yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
yarn works but then yarn is taking care
of your processing layer it does support
mapreduce so mapreduce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing frameworks
yarn can be used to solve the issues
which hadoop version one was posing
something like resource management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by yarn now when
we talk about yarn we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for hadoop version one which
were primarily map reduce kind of
processing can run on yarn without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about
multi-tenancy so basically now the
cluster can handle different kind of
workloads so you can use open source and
proprietary data access engines you can
perform real-time analysis you can be
doing graph processing you can be doing
ad hoc querying and this can be
supported for multiple workloads which
can run in parallel so this is what yarn
offers so what is yarn as i mentioned
yarn stands for yet another resource
negotiator so it is the cluster resource
management layer for your apache hadoop
ecosystem which takes care of scheduling
jobs and assigning resources now just
imagine when you would want to run a
particular application you would
basically be telling the cust cluster
that i would want resources to run my
applications that application might be a
mapreduce application that might be a
hive query which is triggering a
mapreduce that might be a big script
which is triggering a mapreduce that
could be hive with days as an execution
engine that could be a spark application
that could be a graph processing
application in any of these cases you
would still you as in in sense client or
basically an api or the application
would be requesting for resources yan
would take care of that so yarn would
provide the desired resources now when
we talk about resources we are mainly
talking about the network related
resources we are talking about the cpu
cores or as in terms of yarn we say
virtual cpu course we would talk about
ram that is in gb or mb or in terabytes
which would be offered from multiple
machines and yarn would take care of
this so with yarn you could basically
handle different workloads now these are
some of the workloads which are showing
up here you have the traditional
mapreduce which is
mainly batch oriented you could have an
interactive execution engine something
as space you could have hbase which is a
column oriented or a four dimensional
database and that would be not only
storing data on sdfs but would also need
some kind of processing you could have
streaming functionalities which would be
from storm or kafka or spark you could
have graph processing you could have
in-memory processing such as spark and
its components and you could have many
others so these are different frameworks
which could now run and which can run on
top of yarn so how does the iron do that
now when we talk about
yarn this is how a overall yarn
architecture looks so at one end you
have the client now client could be
basically your edge node where you have
some applications which are running it
could be an api which would want to
interact with your cluster it could be a
user triggered application which wants
to run some jobs which are doing some
processing so this client would submit a
job request now what is resource manager
doing resource manager is the master of
your processing layer in hadoop version
1 we basically had job tracker and then
we had task trackers which were running
on individual nodes so your task
trackers were sending your heart beats
to the job tracker your task trackers
were sending it their resource
information and job tracker was the one
which was tracking the resources and it
was doing the job scheduling and that's
how as i mentioned earlier job tracker
was overburdened so job tracker is now
replaced by your resource manager which
is the master for your processing layer
your task trackers are replaced by node
managers which would be then running on
every node and we have a temporary demon
which you see here in blue and that's
your app master so this is what we
mentioned when we say yet another
resource negotiator so app master would
be existing in a hadoop version too now
when we talk about your resource manager
resource manager is the master for
processing layer so it would already be
receiving heartbeats and you can say
resource information from multiple node
managers which would be running on one
or multiple machines and these node
managers are not only updating their
status but they are also giving an
information of the amount of resources
they have now when we talk about
resources we should understand that if i
am talking about this node manager then
this has been allocated some amount of
ram for processing and some amount of
cpu cores and that is just a portion of
what the complete node has so if my node
has say imagine my node has around 100
gb ram and i have saved 60 cores all of
that cannot be allocated to node manager
so node manager is just one of the
components of hadoop ecosystem it is the
slave of the processing layer so we
could say keeping in all the aspects
such as different services which are
running might be cloudera or hortonworks
related services running system
processes running on a particular node
some portion of this would be assigned
to node manager for processing so we
could say for example say 60 gb ram per
node and say 40 cpu cores so this is
what is allocated for the node manager
on every machine similarly we would have
here similarly we would have here so
node manager is constantly giving an
update to resource manager about the
resources what it has probably there
might be some other applications running
and node manager is already occupied so
it gives an update now we also have a
concept of containers which is basically
we will we will talk about which is
about these resources being broken down
into smaller parts so resource manager
is keeping a track of the resources
which every node manager has and it is
also responsible for taking care of the
job request how do these things happen
now as we see here resource manager at a
higher level you can always say this is
the processing master which does
everything but in reality it is not the
resource manager which is doing it but
it has internally different services or
components which are helping it to do
what it is supposed to do now let's look
further now as i mentioned your resource
manager has these
services or components which basically
helps it to do the things it is
basically a an architecture where
multiple components are working together
to achieve what yarn allows so resource
manager has mainly two components that
is your scheduler and applications
manager and these are at high level four
main components here so we talk about
resource manager which is the processing
master you have node managers which are
the processing slaves which are running
on every nodes you have the concept of
container and you have the concept of
application master how do all these
things work now let's look at yarn
components so resource manager basically
has two main components you can say
which assist resource manager in doing
what it is capable of so you have
scheduler and applications manager now
there is when you talk about
resources there is always a requirement
for the applications which need to run
on cluster of resources so your
application which has to run which was
submitted by client needs resources and
these resources are coming in from
multiple machines wherever the relevant
data is stored and a node manager is
running so we always know that node
manager is co-located with data nodes
now what does the scheduler do so we
have different kind of schedulers here
we have basically a capacity scheduler
we have a fair scheduler or we could
have a fifo scheduler so there are
different schedulers which take care of
resource allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-tenant cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queuing so that different departments
or different users can get dedicated
resources or can share resources on the
cluster so scheduler is responsible for
allocating resources to various running
applications now it does not perform
monitoring or tracking of the status of
applications that's not the part of
scheduler it does not offer any
guarantee about restarting the failed
tasks due to hardware or network or any
other failures scheduler is mainly
responsible for allocating resources now
as i mentioned you could have different
kind of schedulers you could have a fifo
scheduler which was mainly in older
version of hadoop which stands for first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler which basically means
multiple applications could be running
in the cluster and they would have a
fair share of the resources you could
have a capacity scheduler which would
basically have dedicated or fixed amount
of resources across the cluster now
whichever scheduler is being used
scheduler is mainly responsible for
allocating resources then it's your
applications manager now this is
responsible for accepting job
submissions now as i said at higher
level we could always say resource
manager state doing everything it is
allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who is doing it in real it is these
components so you have applications
manager which is responsible for
accepting job submissions it negotiates
the first container for executing the
application specific application master
it provides the service for restarting
the application master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as i said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
tracking the resources what it has it is
tracking the processes it is taking care
of running the jobs and basically it is
tracking each container resource
utilization so let's understand what is
this container so normally when you talk
about a application request which comes
from a client so let's say this is my
client which is requesting or which is
coming up with an application which
needs to run on the cluster now this
application could be anything it first
contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as i mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks when stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exists now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources resource
manager has mainly these two components
which are helping it to do its work now
for a particular application which might
be needing data from multiple machines
now we know that we would have multiple
machines where we would have node
manager running we would have a data
node running and data nodes are
responsible for storing the data on disk
so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when i say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resources
for example it would be saying can i
have one gb of ram and one cpu core from
you because there is some data residing
on your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my application can
i again have one gb and one cpu core
from you and this is again because some
relevant data is stored and this request
which resource manager makes of holding
the resources of total resources which
the node manager has your resource
manager is negotiating or is asking for
resources from the processing slave so
this request of holding resources can be
considered as a container so resource
manager now we know it is not actually
the resource manager but it is the
application manager which is negotiating
the resources so it negotiates the
resources which
are called container so this request of
holding resource can be considered as a
container so basically a container can
be of different sizes we will talk about
that so resource manager negotiates the
resources with node manager now node
manager which is already giving an
update of the resources it has what
amount of resources it holds how much
busy it is can basically approve or deny
this request so node manager would
basically approve in saying yes i could
hold these resources i could give you
this container of this particular size
now once the container has been approved
or allocated or you can say granted by
your node manager resource manager now
knows that resources to process the
application are available and guaranteed
by the node manager so resource manager
starts a temporary demon called
appmaster so this is a piece of code
which would also be running in one of
the containers it would be running in
one of the containers which would then
take care of execution of tasks in other
containers so your application master is
per application so if i would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
masters one app master being responsible
for per application now what does this
app master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your app master
would run in one of the containers and
then it would use the other containers
which node manager is guaranteed that it
will give when the request application
request comes to it and using these
containers the app master will run the
processing tasks within these designated
resources so it is mainly the
responsibility of application master to
get the execution done and then
communicate it to the master so resource
manager is tracking the resources it is
negotiating the resources and once the
resources have been negotiated it
basically gives the control to
application master application master is
then running within one of the
containers on one of the nodes and using
the other containers to take care of
execution this is how it looks so
basically container as i said is a
collection of resources like cpu memory
your disk which would be used or which
already has the data and network so your
node manager is basically looking into
the request from application master and
it basically is granting this request or
basically is allocating these containers
now again we could have different sizing
of the containers let's take an example
here so as i mentioned from the total
resources which are available for a
particular node some portion of
resources are allocated to the node
manager so let's imagine this is my node
where node manager as a processing slave
is running so from the total resources
which the node has some portion of ram
and cpu cores is basically allocated to
the node manager so i could say
out of total 100 gb ram we can say
around
60 cores which the particular node has
so this is my ram which the node has and
these are the cpu cores which the node
has some portion of it right so we can
say might be
70 or 60 percent of the total resources
so we could say around 60 gb ram and
then we could say around 40 v cores have
been allocated to node manager so there
are these
settings which are given in the yarn
hyphen site file now apart from this
allocation that is 60 gb ram and 40v
cores we also have some properties which
say what will be the container sizes so
for example we could have a small
container setting which could say my
every container could have 2gb ram and
say one virtual cpu core so this is my
smallest container so based on the total
resources you could calculate how many
such small containers could be running
so if i say 2gb ram then i could have
around 30 containers but then i am
talking about one virtual cpu core so
totally i could have around 30
small containers which could be running
in parallel on a particular node and as
of that calculation you would say 10 cpu
cores are not being utilized you could
have a bigger container size which could
say i would go for 2 cpu cores and 3gb
ram
so 3gb ram and 2 cpu cores so that would
give me around 20 containers of bigger
size so this is the container sizing
which is again defined in the yarn
hyphen site file so what we know is on a
particular node which has this kind of
allocation either we could have 30 small
containers running or we could have 20
big containers running and same would
apply to multiple nodes so node manager
based on the request from application
master can allocate these containers now
remember it is within this one of these
containers you would have an application
master running and other containers
could be used for your processing
requirement application master which is
per application it is the one which uses
these resources it basically manages or
uses these resources for individual
application so remember if we have 10
applications running on yarn then it
would be 10 application masters one
responsible for each application your
application master is the one which also
interacts with the scheduler to
basically know how much amount of
resources could be allocated for one
application and your application master
is the one which uses these resources
but it can never negotiate for more
resources to node manager application
master cannot do that application master
has to always go back to resource
manager if it needs more resources so it
is always the resource manager and
internally resource manager component
that is application manager which
negotiates the resources at any point of
time due to some node failures or due to
any other requirements if application
master
needs
more resources on one or multiple nodes
it will always be contacting the
resource manager internally the
applications manager for more containers
now this is how it looks so your client
submits the job request to resource
manager now we know that resource
manager internally has scheduler an
applications manager node managers which
are running on multiple machines are the
ones which are tracking their resources
giving this information to the source
manager so that resource manager or i
would say its component applications
manager could request resources from
multiple node managers when i say
request resources it is these containers
so your resource manager basically will
request for the resources on one or
multiple nodes node manager is the one
which approves these containers and once
the container has been approved your
resource manager triggers a piece of
code that is application master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
will use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or i would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
locates a container application master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run an application
master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execution happens now that could
be a map task that could be a reduced
task that could be a spark executor
taking care of spark tasks and many
other processing
so before we look into the demo on how
yarn works i would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from cloudera so you
can just look for yarn untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which i explained just now
so as we mentioned here so you basically
have the master process you have the
worker process which basically takes
care of your processing your resource
manager being the master and node
manager being the slave this also talks
about the resources which each node
manager has
it talks about the yarn configuration
file where you give all these properties
it basically shows you node manager
which reports the amount of resources it
has to resource manager now remember if
worker node shows 18 to 8 cpu cores and
128 gb ram and if your node manager says
64 v cores and ram 128 gb then that's
not the total capacity of your node it
is some portion of your node which is
allocated to node manager now once your
node manager reports that your resource
manager is requesting for containers
based on the application what is a
container it is basically a logical name
given to a combination of vcore and
ram
it is within this container where you
would have basically the process running
so once your application starts and once
node manager is guaranteed these
containers your application or your
resource manager has basically already
started an application master within the
container and what does that application
master do it uses the other containers
where the tasks would run so this is a
very good blog which you can refer to
and this also talks about mapreduce if
you have already followed the mapreduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduce tasks could be running within the
container in one or multiple as i said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to yarn so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
cloudera hortonworks related services
running and other processes which might
be running and based on that some
portion of ram and cpu cores would be
allocated to node manager so that's how
it would be done in the yarn hyphen site
file and this basically shows you what
is the total amount of memory and cpu
cores which is allocated to node manager
then within every machine where you have
a node manager running on every machine
in the yarn hyphen site file you would
have such properties which would say
what is the minimum container size what
is the maximum container size in terms
of ram what is the minimum for cpu cores
what is the maximum for cpu cores and
what is the incremental size in where
ram and cpu cores can increment so these
are some of the properties which define
how containers are allocated for your
application request so have a look at
this and this could be a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in yarn which talks about
fair scheduler or you basically having
different cues in which allocations can
be done you also have different ways in
which queues can be managed and
different schedulers can be used so you
can always look at this series of blog
you can also be checking for yarn
schedulers and then search for a
hadoop
definitive
guide and that could give you some
information on how it looks when you
look for hadoop definitive guide so if
you look into this book which talks
about the different resources as i
mentioned so you could have a fee for
scheduler that is first in first out
which basically means if a long running
application is submitted to the cluster
all other small running applications
will have to wait there is no other way
but that would not be a preferred option
if you look in fifo scheduler if you
look for capacity scheduler it basically
means that you could have different
queues created and those queues would
have resources allocated so then you
could have a production queue where
production jobs are running in a
particular queue which has fixed amount
of resources allocated you could have a
development queue where development jobs
are running and both of them are running
in parallel you could then also look
into fair scheduler which basically
means again multiple applications could
be running on the cluster however they
would have a fair share so when i say
fair share in brief what it means is
if i had given 50 percent of resources
to a queue for production and 50 of
resources for a queue of development and
if both of them are running in parallel
then they would have access to 50
percent of cluster resources however if
one of the queue is unutilized then
second queue can utilize all cluster
resources so look into the fair
scheduling part it also shows you about
how allocations can be given and you can
learn more about schedulers and how
queues can be used for managing multiple
applications now we will spend some time
in looking into few ways or few quick
ways in interacting with yarn in the
form of a demo to understand and learn
on how yarn works we can look into a
particular cluster now here we have a
designated cluster which can be used you
could be using the similar kind of
commands on your apache based cluster or
a cloudera quick start vm if you already
have or if you have a cloud error or a
hortonworks cluster running there are
different ways in which we can interact
with yarn and we can look at the
information one is basically looking
into the admin console so if i would
look into cloudera manager which is
basically an admin console for a cloud
errors distribution of hadoop similarly
you could have a hortonworks cluster
than access to the admin console so if
you have even read access for your
cluster and if you have the admin
console then you can search for yarn as
a service which is running you can click
on yarn as a service and that gives you
different tabs so you have the instances
which tells basically what are the
different roles for your yarn service
running so we have here multiple node
managers now some of them showing stop
status but that's nothing to worry so we
have three and six node managers we have
resource manager which is one but then
that can also be in a high availability
where you can have active and standby
you also have a job history server which
would show you the applications once
they have completed now you can look at
the yarn configurations and as i was
explaining you can always look for the
properties which are related to the
allocation so you can here search for
course and that should show you the
properties which talk about the
allocations so here if we see we can be
looking for
yarn app mapreduce application master
resource cpu course what is the cpu
course allocated for mapreduce map task
reduce task you can be looking at yarn
node manager resource cpu course which
basically says every node manager on
every node would be allocated with six
cpu cores and the container sizing is
with minimum allocation of 1 cpu core
and the maximum could be 2 cpu cores
similarly you could also be searching
for memory allocation and here you could
then scroll down to see what kind of
memory allocation has been done for the
node manager so if we look further it
should give me information of node
manager which basically says here that
the container minimum allocation is 2 gb
the maximum is 3 gb and we can look at
node manager which has been given 25 gb
per node so it's a combination of this
memory and cpu cores which is the total
amount of resources which have been
allocated to every node manager now we
can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on yarn
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on yarn you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web ui and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web ui and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 gb memory allocated so
that could be say 25 gb per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
i could get more information so this
tells me that i have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 gb memory allocated per node and six
scores out of which some portion is
being utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root cue and within root
you have default queue and you have
basically user skew based on different
users we can always scroll here and that
can give us information if it is a fair
share so here we see that my root dot
default has 50 percent of resources and
the other queue also has 50 percent of
resources which also gives me an idea
that a fair scheduler is being used we
can always confirm that if we are using
a fair scheduler or a capacity scheduler
which takes care of a location so search
for scheduler
and that should give you some
understanding of what kind of scheduler
is being used and what are the
allocations given for that particular
scheduler so here we have fair scheduler
it shows me you have under root you have
the root q which has been given hundred
percent capacity and then you have
within that default which also takes 100
percent so this is how you can
understand about yarn by looking into
the yarn web ui you can be looking into
the configurations you can look at
applications you can always look at
different actions now since we do not
have admin access the only information
we have is to download the client
configuration we can always look at the
history server which can give us
information of all the applications
which have successfully completed now
this is from your yarn ui what i can
also do is i can be going into hue which
is the web interface and your web
interface also basically allows you to
look into the jobs so you can click on
hue web ui and if you have access to
that it should show up or you should
have a way to get to your hue which is a
graphical user interface mainly comes
with your cloud error you can also
configure that with apache hortonworks
has a different way of giving you the
web ui access you can click and get into
hue and that is also one way where you
can look at yarn you can look at the
jobs which are running if there are some
issues with it and these these are your
web interfaces so either you look from
yarn web ui or here in hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run
so here i can just remove this one which
would basically give me a list of all
the different kind of jobs or workflows
which were run so either it was a spark
based application or it was a mapreduce
or it was coming from hive so here i
have list of all the applications and it
says this was a mapreduce this was a
spark something was killed something was
successful and this was basically
probably a hive query which triggered a
mapreduce job you can click on the
application and that tells you how many
tasks were run for it so there was a map
task which ran for it you can get into
the metadata information which you can
obviously you can also look from the
yarn ui to look into your applications
which can give you a detailed
information of if it was a map reduce
how many map and reduce tasks were run
what were the different counters if it
was a spark application it can let you
follow through spark history server or
job history server so you can always use
the web ui to look into the jobs you can
be finding in lot of useful information
here you can also be looking at how many
resources were used and what happened to
the job was it successful did it fail
and what was the job status now apart
from
web ui which always you might not have
access to so in a particular cluster in
a production cluster there might be
restrictions and the organization might
not have
access given to all the users to
graphical user interface like you or
might be you would not have access to
the cloud era manager or admin console
because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access is your web console or
basically your edge node or client
machine from where you can connect to
the cluster and then you can be working
so let's log in here and now here we can
give different commands so this is the
command line from where you can have
access to different details you can
always check by just typing in map red
which gives you different options where
you can look at the map reduce related
jobs you can look at different queues if
there are queues configured you can look
at the history server or you can also be
doing some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if i just say map
red and q here this basically gives me
an option says what would you want to do
would you want to list all the queues do
you want information on a particular
queue so let's try a list
and that should give you different
queues which were being used now here we
know that per user a queue dynamically
gets created which is under root dot
users and that gives me what is the
status of the queue what is the capacity
has there been any kind of maximum
capacity or capping done so we get to
see a huge list of queues which
dynamically get configured in this
environment and then you also look at
your root dot default i could have also
picked up one particular queue and i
could have said show me the jobs so i
could do that now here we can
also give a yarn command so let me just
clear the screen and i will say yarn and
that shows me different options so apart
from your web interface
something like web ui apart from your
yarn's web ui you could also be looking
for information using yarn commands here
so these are some list of commands which
we can check now you can just type in
yarn and version if you would want to
see the version which basically gives
you information of what is the hadoop
version being used and what is the
vendor-specific distribution version so
here we see we are working on cloudera's
distribution 5.14 which is internally
using hadoop 2.6 now similarly you can
be doing a yarn application list so if
you give this that could be an
exhaustive list of all the applications
which are running or applications which
have completed so here we don't see any
applications because right now probably
there are no applications which are
running it also shows you you could be
pulling out different status such as
submitted accepted or running now you
could also say i would want to see the
services that have finished running so i
could say yarn application list and app
state says finished so here we could be
using our command so i could say yarn
application
list and then i would want to see the
app states which gives me the
applications which have finished and we
would want to list all the applications
which finished now there that might be
applications which succeeded right and
there is a huge list of application
which is coming in from the history
server which is basically showing you
the huge list of applications which have
completed so this is one way and then
you could also be searching for one
particular application if you would want
to search a particular application if
you have the application id you could
always be doing a grip that's a simple
way i could say basically let's pick up
this one and if i would want to search
for this if i would want more details on
this i could obviously do that
by calling in my previous command and
you could do a grip if that's what you
want to do and if you would want to
search is there any application which is
in the list of my applications that
shows my application i could pull out
more information about my application so
i could look at the log files for a
particular application by giving the
application id so i could say yarn logs
now that's an option and every time
anytime you have a doubt just hit enter
it will always give you options what you
need to give with a particular command
so i can say yarn logs application
id now we copied an application id and
we could just give it here we could give
other options like app owner or if you
would want to get into the container
details or if you would want to check on
a particular node now here i'm giving
yarn logs and then i'm pointing it to
an application id and it says the log
aggregation has not completed might be
this was might be this was an
application which was triggered based on
a particular interactive shell or based
on a particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill an application
so here you can be saying yarn yarn
application and then what would you want
to do with an application hit and enter
it shows you the different options so we
just tried app states you could always
look at the last one which says status
and then for my status i could be giving
my application id so that tells me what
is the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application id what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much gb memory and how
many c core seconds it used so this is
basically looking out at the application
details now i could kill an application
if the application was already running i
could always do a yarn application
minus skill and then i could be giving
my application now i could try killing
this however it would say the
application is already finished if i had
an application running and if my
application was already given an
application id by resource manager i
could just kill it i can also say yarn
node list which should give me a list of
the node managers now this is what we
were looking from the yarn web ui and we
were pulling out the information so we
can get this and kind of information
from your command line always remember
and always try to be well accustomed
with the command line so you can do
various things from the command line and
then obviously you have the web uis
which can help you with a graphical
interface easily able to access things
now you could be also starting the
resource manager which we would not be
doing here because we are already
running in a cluster so you could give a
yarn resource manager you could get the
logs of resource manager if you would
want by giving yarn demon so we can try
that so you can say yarn and then demon
so it says it does not find the demon so
you can give something like this get
level and here i will have to give the
node and the ip address where you want
to check the logs of resource manager so
you could be giving this for which we
will have to then get into cloud error
manager to look into the nodes and the
ip address you could be giving a command
something like this which basically
gives you the level of the log which you
have and i got this resource manager
address from the web ui now i can be
giving in this command to look into the
demand log and it basically says you
would want to look at the resource
manager related log and you have the log
4j which is being used for logging the
kind of level which has been set as info
which can again be changed in the way
you're logging the information now you
can try any other commands also from
yarn for example looking at the yarn rm
admin so you can always do a yarn rm
admin and this basically gives you a lot
of other informations like refreshing
the queues or refreshing the nodes or
basically looking at the admin acls or
getting groups so you could always get
group names for a particular user now we
could search for a particular user such
as yarn or hdfs itself so i could just
say here i would want get
groups and then i could be searching for
say username hdfs so that tells me sdfs
belongs to a hadoop group similarly you
could search for say map red or you
could search for yarn so these are
service related users which
automatically get created and you can
pull out information related to these
you can always do a refresh nodes kind
of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when you
are doing commissioning decommissioning
but then in case of cloudera or
hortonworks kind of cluster you would
not be manually giving this command
because if you are doing a commissioning
decommissioning from an admin console
and if you are an administrator then you
could just restart the services which
are affected and that will take care of
this but if you were working in an
apache cluster and if you were doing
commissioning decommissioning then you
would be using in two commands refresh
nodes and basically that's for
refreshing the nodes which
should not be used for processing and
similarly you could have a command
refresh nodes which comes with sdfs so
these are different options which you
can use with your yarn on the command
line you could also be using curl
commands to get more information about
your cluster by giving curl minus x and
then basically pointing out to your
resource manager web ui address now here
i would like to print out the cluster
related metrics and i could just simply
do this which basically gives me a high
level information of how many
applications were submitted how many are
pending what is the reserved resources
what is the available amount of memory
or cpu cores and all the information
similarly you can be using the same curl
commands to get more information like
scheduler information so you would just
replace the metrics with scheduler and
you could get the information of the
different queues now that's a huge list
we can cancel this and that would give
me the list of all the queues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each queue you could also
get cluster information on application
ids and status running of applications
running in yarn so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say i would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do a
grip and you can be filtering out
specific application related information
similarly you can be looking at the
notes so you can always be looking at
node specific information which gives
you how many nodes you have but this
could be mainly used when you have an
application which wants to or a web
application which wants to use a curl
command then would want to get
information about your cluster from an
http interface now when it comes to
application we can basically try running
a simple or a sample mapreduce job which
could then be triggered on yarn and it
would use the resources now i can look
at my application here and i can be
looking into my specific directory which
is this one which should have lot of
files and directories which we have here
now i could pick up one of these and i
could be using a simple example to do
some processing let's take up this file
so there is a file and i could run a
simple word count or i could be running
a hive query which triggers a mapreduce
job i could even run a spark application
which would then show that the
application is running on the cluster so
for example if i would say spark to
shell now i know that this is an
interactive way of working with spark
but this internally triggers a spark
submit and this runs an application so
here when you do a spark to shell by
default it will contact yarn so it gets
an application id it is running on yarn
with the master being yarn and now i
have access to the interactive way of
working with spark now if i go and look
into applications i should be able to
see my application which has been
started here and it shows up here so
this is my application 3827
which has been started on yarn and as of
now we can also look into the yarn ui
and that shows me the application which
has been started which basically has one
running container which has one cpu core
allocated 2gb ram and it's in progress
although we are not doing anything there
so we can always look at our application
from the yarn ui or as i mentioned from
your applications tab within yarn
services which gives us the information
and you can even click on this
application to follow and see more
information but you should be given
access to that now this is just a simple
application which i triggered using
spark shell similarly i can basically be
running a mapreduce now to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop jar and that
basically needs a class so we can look
for the default path which is opt cloud
error parcels cdh
lib hadoop map reduce hadoop mapreduce
examples and then we can look at this
particular jar file and if i hit on
enter it shows me the different classes
which are part of this jar and here i
would like to use word count so i could
just give this i could say word count
now remember i could run the job in a
particular queue by giving in an
argument here so i could say minus d map
red dot job dot q dot name and then i
can point my job to a particular queue i
can even give different arguments in
saying i would want my mapreduce output
to be compressed or i want it to be
stored in a particular directory and so
on so here i have the word count and
then basically what i can be doing is i
can be pointing it to a particular input
path
and then i can have my output which can
be getting stored here again a directory
which we need to choose and i will say
output
new and i can submit my job now once i
have submitted my job it connects to
resource manager it basically gets a job
id it gets an application id it shows
you from where you can track your
application you can always go to the
yarn ui and you can be looking at your
application and the resources it is
using so my application was not a big
one and it has already completed it
triggered one map task it launched one
reduced task it was working on around 12
466 records where you have then the
output of map which is these many number
of output records which was then taken
by a combiner and finally by a reducer
which basically gives you the output so
this is my on application which has
completed now i could be looking into
the yarn ui and if my job has completed
you might not see your application here
so as of now it shows up here the word
count which i ran it also shows me my
previous spark shell job it shows me my
application is completed and if you
would want further information on this
you can click and go to the history
server if you have been given access to
it or directly go to the history server
web ui where your application shows up
it shows how many map and reduce tasks
it was running you can click on this
particular application which basically
gives you information of your map and
reduce tasks you can look at different
counters for your application right you
can always look at map specific tasks
you can always look into one particular
task what it did on which node it was
running or you can be looking at the
complete application log so you can
always click on the logs and here you
have click here for full log which gives
you the information and you can always
look for your application which can give
you information of app appmaster being
launched or you could have
search for the word container so you
could see a job which needs one or
multiple containers and then you could
say container is being requested then
you could see container is being
allocated then you can see what is the
container size and then basically your
task moves from initializing to running
in the container and finally you can
even search for release which will tell
you that the container was released so
you can always look into the log for
more information so this is how you can
interact with yarn this is how you can
interact with your command line to look
for more information or using your yarn
web ui or you can also be looking into
your hue for more information welcome to
scoop tutorial one of the many features
of the hadoop ecosystem for the hadoop
file system what's in it for you today
we're going to cover the need for scoop
what is scoop scoop features scoop
architecture scoop import scoop export
scoop processing and then finally we'll
have a little hands-on demo on scoop so
you can see what it looks like so where
does the need for scoop come in in our
big data hadoop file system processing
huge volumes of data requires loading
data from diverse sources into hadoop
cluster you can see here we have our
data processing and this process of
loading data from the heterogeneous
sources comes with a set of challenges
so what are the challenges maintaining
data consistency ensuring efficient
utilization of resources especially when
you're talking about big data we can
certainly use up the resources when
importing terabytes and petabytes of
data over the course of time loading
bulk data to hadoop was not possible
it's one of the big challenges that came
up when they first had the hadoop file
system going and loading data using
script was very slow in other words
you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to hadoop very easily so
thank your enterprise server you want to
take the from mysql or your sql and you
want to bring that data into your hadoop
warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoop comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between hadoop and
external data stores such as relational
databases and my sql server or the
microsoft sql server or my sql server so
scoop equals sql plus hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is the middle ground and brings
the import into the hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features scoop
features has parallel import and export
it has import results of sql query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so we look at
parallel import and export scoop uses
yarn yet another resource negotiator
framework to import and export data this
provides fault tolerance on a top of
parallelism scoop allows us to import
the result returned from an sql carry
into the hadoop file system or the hdfs
and you can see here where the import
results of sql query come in scoop
provides connectors for multiple
relational database management system
rdbms's databases such as mysql and
microsoft sql server and it has
connectors for all major rdbms databases
scoop supports kerberos computer network
authentication protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
take a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing the hadoop cluster and the
client comes in and sends their command
which goes into scoop the client submits
the import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have
enterprise data warehouse document based
systems you have connect connector for
your data warehouse a connector for
document based systems which reaches out
to those two entities and we have our
connector for the rdbms so connectors
help in working with a range of popular
databases multiple mappers perform map
tasks to load the data onto hdfs a
hadoop file system and you can see here
we have the map task if you remember
from hadoop hadoop is based on map
reduce because we're not reducing the
data we're just mapping it over it only
accesses the mappers and it opens up
multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbase hive is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can now
export it using the multiple map
routines scoop import so here we have
our dbms data store and we have the
folders on there so maybe it's your
company's database maybe it's an archive
at google with all the searches going on
whatever it is usually you think um with
scoop you think sql you think mysql
server or microsoft sql server that kind
of setup
so it gathers the metadata and you see
the scoop import so introspect database
together metadata primary key
information and then it submits uh so
you can see submits map only job
remember we talked about mapreduce it
only needs the map side of it because
we're not reducing the data we're just
mapping it over scoop divides the input
data set into splits and uses individual
map tests to push the splits into hdfs
so right into the hadoop file system and
you can see down on the right is kind of
a small depiction of a hadoop cluster
and then you have scoop export so we're
going to go the other direction and with
the other direction you have your hadoop
file system storage which is your hadoop
cluster you have your scoop job and each
one of those clusters then gets a map
mapper comes out to each one of the
computers that has data on it
so the first step is you've got to
gather the metadata so step one you
gather the metadata step two submits map
only job introspect database together
metadata primary key information scoop
divides the input data set into splits
and uses individual map tests to push
the splits to rdbms scoop will export
hadoop files back to rdms tables you can
think of this in a number of different
manners one of them would be if you're
restoring a backup from the hadoop file
system into your enterprise machines
there's certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our url so
specify the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify the
connection manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use hadoop map reduce home directory
override hadoop mapped home username set
authentication username and of course
help print usage instructions and with
the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
the connection manager class to use
manually specified jdbc driver class to
use you do have to let it know to
override the hadoop map reduce home and
that's true on both of these and set
authentication username and finally you
can print out all your help setup so you
can see the format for scoop is pretty
straightforward both import and export
so let's uh continue on our path and
look at scoop processing and what the
computer goes through for that and we
talk about scoop processing first scoop
runs in the hadoop cluster it imports
data from the rdbms the nosql database
to the hadoop file system so remember it
might not be importing the data from a
rdbms it might actually be coming from
an osql and there's many out there it
uses mappers to slice the incoming data
into multiple formats and load the data
into hdfs it exports data back into an
rdbms while making sure that the schema
of the data in the database is
maintained so now that we've looked at
the basic commands in our scoop in the
scoop processing or at least the basics
as far as theory is concerned let's just
jump in and take a look at a demo on
scoop
for this demo i'm going to use our
cloudera quick start if you've been
watching our other demos we've done
you'll see that we've been using that
pretty consistently certainly this will
work in any of your
your horton sandbox which is also a
single node testing machine cloudera is
one of um there's a docker version
instead of virtualbox and you can also
set up your own hadoop cluster plan a
little extra time if you're not an admin
it's actually a pretty
significant endeavor for an admin if
you've been admitting linux machines for
a very long time and you know a lot of
the commands i find for most admins it
takes them about two to four hours the
first time they go in and create a
virtual machine and set up their own
hadoop in this case though when you're
just learning and getting set up best to
start with cloudera cloudera also
includes an installed version of mysql
that way you don't have to install the
the sql version for importing data from
and two once you're in the cloudera
quickstart you'll see it opens a nice
centos linux
interface and it has the desktop setup
on there this is really nice for
learning so you're not just looking at
command lines and from in here it should
open up by default to hue if not you can
click on hue here's a kind of a fun
little web-based interface under hue i
can go under query i can pick an editor
and we'll go right down to scoop so now
i'm just going to load the scoop editor
inner hue now i'm going to switch over
and do this all in command line i just
want to show that you can actually do
this in a hue through the web-based
interface the reason i like to do the
command line is specifically on my
computer it runs much quicker or if i do
the command line here and i run it it
tends to have an extra lag or an added
layer in it so for this we're going to
go ahead and open our command line the
second reason i do this is we're going
to need to go ahead and edit our
mysql so we have something to scoop in
otherwise i don't have anything going in
there and of course we zoom in zoom in
this and increase the size of our screen
so for this demo our hands-on i'm going
to use oracle virtualbox manager and the
cloudera quick start if you're not
familiar with this we do have another
tutorial we put out and you can send a
note in the youtube video below and let
our team know they'll send you a link or
come visit
www.simplylearn.com now this creates a
linux box on my windows computer so
we're going to be in linux and it'll be
the cloudera version
with scoop and we'll also be using mysql
mysql server once inside the cloudera
virtualbox we'll go under the hue editor
now we're going to do everything in
terminal window but i just want you to
be aware that under the hue editor you
can go under query editor and you'll see
as we come down here here's our scoop on
this so you can run your scoop from in
here now before we do this we have to do
a little exploration in my sql and my
sql server that way we know what data is
coming in so let me go ahead and open up
a terminal window in cloudera you have a
terminal window at the top here that you
can just click on it open it up and let
me just go ahead and zoom in on here go
view and zoom in now to get into my sql
server you simply type in mysql and this
part will depend on your setup now the
cloudera quickstart comes up that the
username is root and the password is
cloudera kind of a strange quirk is that
you can put a space between the minus u
and the root but not between the minus p
and the cloudera usually you put in a
minus capital p and then it prompts you
for your password on here for this demo
i don't worry too much about you knowing
the password on that so we'll just go
right into my sql server since this is
the standard password for this quick
start and you can see we're now into
mysql and we're going to do just a
couple of quick
commands in here there's show databases
and you follow by the semicolon that's
standard in most of these shell commands
so it knows it's the end of your shell
command and you'll see in here in the
quick start cloudera quickstart the
mysql comes with a standard set of
databases these are just
some of these have to do like with the
uzi which is the uzi part of hadoop
where others of these like customers and
employees and stuff like that those are
just for demo purposes they come as a
standard setup in there so that people
going in for the first time have a
database to play with which is really
good for us so we don't have to recreate
those databases and you will see in the
list here we have a retail underscore db
and then we can simply do uh use
retail underscore db this will set that
as a default in mysql and then we want
to go ahead and show the tables and if
we show the tables you can see under the
database the retail db database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard
sql command and if you did our hive
language you'll note remember it's the
same for hql also on this we're just
going to select star everything from
departments
so there's our departments table and
we're going to list everything on the
departments table and you'll see we have
about six lines in here and it has a
department id and a department name
two for fitness three for footwear so on
and so forth now at this point i can
just go ahead and exit but it's kind of
nice to have this data up here so we can
look at it and flip back and forth
between the screens so i'm going to open
up another terminal window and we'll go
ahead and zoom in on this also and it
isn't too important for this particular
setup but it's always kind of fine fun
to know what your setup you're working
with what is your host name and so we'll
go ahead and just type that in this is a
linux command and it's a
host name minus f and you see we're on
quick start cloudera no surprise there
now this next command is going to be a
little bit longer because we're going to
be doing our first scoop command and i'm
going to do two of them we're going to
list databases and list tables it's
going to take just a moment to get
through this
because there's a bunch of stuff going
on here so we have scoop we have list
databases we have connect and under the
connect command we need to let it know
how we're connecting we're going to use
the jdbc this is a very standard one
jdbc mysql so you'll see that if you're
doing an sql database that's how you
started off with and then the next part
this is where you have to go look it up
it's however it was created so if your
admin created a mysql server with a
certain setup that's what you have to go
by and you'll see that usually they list
this as localhost so you'll see
something like localhost sometimes
there's a lot of different formats but
the most common is either localhost or
the actual connection so in this case we
want to go ahead and do quickstart 3306.
and so quick start here's the name of
the local host database and how it's
hosted on here and when you set up the
quick start for um for hadoop under
cloudera it's port 3306 is where that's
coming in so that's where all that's
coming from uh and so there's our path
for that
and then we have to put in our password
we typically type password if you look
it up password on the cloudera
quickstart is cloudera and we have to
also let it know the username and again
if you're doing this you'd probably put
in a minus capital you can actually just
do it for a prompt
for the password so if you leave that
out it'll prompt you but for this
doesn't really matter i don't care if
you see my password it's the default one
for cloudera quick start and then the
username on here is simply root and then
we're going to put our semicolon at the
end and so we have here our full setup
and we go ahead and list the databases
uh and you'll see you might get some
warnings on here i haven't run the
updates on the quick start i suggest
you're not running the updates either if
you're doing this for the first time
because it'll do some reformatting on
there and it quickly pass up and you can
see here's all of our
the tables we went in there and if we go
back to
on the previous window we should see
that these tables match so here we come
in and here we have our databases and
you can see back up here where we had
the cm customers employees and so on so
the databases match and then we want to
go ahead and list the
tables for a specific database so let's
go ahead and do that i'm a very lazy
typist so i'll put the up arrow in and
you can see here scoop list databases
we're just going to go back and change
this from databases to list tables so we
want to list the tables in here same
connection so most the connection is the
same except we need to know which tables
we're listing an interesting fact is you
can create a table without being under a
database so if you left this blank it
will show the open tables that aren't
connected directly to a database or
under a database but what we want to do
is right past this last slash on the
3306 we want to put that retail
underscore
db because that's the database we're
going to be working with and this will
go in there and show the tables listed
under that database and here we go we
got categories customers departments
order items and products if we flip back
here real quick there it is the same
thing we had we had categories customers
departments order items and so on and so
let's go ahead and run our first import
command and again i'm that lazy typer so
we're going to do scoop and instead of
list tables we want to go ahead and
import so there's our import command and
so once we have our import command in
there then we need to tell it exactly
what we're going to import
so everything else is the same we're
importing from the retail db so we keep
that and then at the very end we're
going to tag on dash dash table that
tells us we can tell what table we're
importing from and we're going to import
departments
there we go so this is pretty
straightforward because what's nice
about this is you can see the commands
are the same i got the same connection
um i change it for the whatever database
i'm in um then i come in here our
password the username are going to be
the same that's all under the mysql
server setup and then we let it know
what table we're entering in we run this
and this is going to actually go through
the mapper process in hadoop so this is
a mapping process it takes the data and
it maps it up to different parts in the
setup in hadoop on there and then saves
that data into the hadoop file system
and it does take it a moment to zip
through which i kind of skipped over for
you since it is running a you know it's
designed to run across a cluster not on
a single node so when you're running on
a single node it's going to run slow
even if you dedicate a couple cores to
it i think i put dedicated four cores to
this one and so you can see right down
here we get to the end is now mapped in
that information and then we can go in
here we can go under can flip back to
our
hue and under hue on the top i have
there's databases and the second icon
over is your hadoop file system and we
can go in here and look at the hadoop
file system and you'll see it show up
underneath our documents there it is
departments cloudera departments and you
can see there's always a delay when i'm
working in hue which i don't like
and that's the quick start issue that's
not necessarily running out on a server
when i'm running it on a server you
pretty much have to run through some
kind of server interface i still prefer
the terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker but we'll flip back on over here
to the command line and we can do the
hadoop type in the hadoop fs and then
list minus ls and if we run this you'll
see underneath our hadoop file system
there is our departments which has been
added in and we can also do uh hadoop
fs and this is kind of interesting for
those who've gone through the hadoop
file system everything you'll you'll
recognize this on here i'm going to list
it the contents of departments and
you'll see underneath departments we
have part part
m0001002003 and so this is interesting
because this is how hadoop saves these
files this is in the file system this is
not in hive so we didn't directly import
this into hive we put this in the hadoop
file system depending on what you're
doing you would then write the schema
for hive to look at the hadoop file
system certainly visit our hive tutorial
for more information on hive specific uh
so you can see in here are different
files that it forms that are part of
departments and we can do something like
this we can look at the contents of one
of these files fs minus ls or a number
of the files and we'll simply do
the full path which is user cloudera and
then we already know the next one is
departments
and then after departments we're going
to put slash part star so this is going
to say anything that has part in it
so we have part dash m 0 0 0 and so on
we can go ahead and cat use that cut
command or that list command to bring
those up and then we can use the cat
command to actually display the contents
and that's a linux command hadoop linux
command the cat catenate not to be
confused with catatonic catastrophic
there's a lot of cat got your tongue and
we see here fitness footwear apparel
that should look really familiar because
that's what we had in our my sequel
server we went in here we did a select
all on here there it is fitness footwear
apparel golf outdoors and fan shop and
then of course it's really important
let's look back on over here to be able
to tell it where to put the data uh so
we go back to our import command so
here's our scoop import we have our
connect we have the db underneath our
connection our mysql server we have our
password our username the table going
where it's going to i mean the table
where it's coming from and then we can
add a target on here we can put in a
target
dash
directory and you do have to put the
full path that's a hadoop thing it's a
good practice to be in and we're going
to add it to department we'll just do
department one and so here we now add a
target directory in here and user
cloudera department one and this will
take just a moment before so i'll go
ahead and skip over the process since
it's going to run very slowly it's only
running on like i said a couple cores
and it's also on a single node and now
we can do the uh hadoop let's just do
the up arrow file system list we want
just straight list and when we do the
hadoop file system
minus ls or list you'll see that we now
have department one and we can of course
do list department one and you can see
we have the files inside department one
and they mirrored what we saw before
with the same files in there in the part
m o 0 0 and so on if we want to look at
them it'd be the same thing we did
before with the cat so except instead of
departments
we'd be department one there we go
something that's going to come up with
the same data we had before now one of
the important things when you're
importing data and it's always a
question to ask is do you filter the
data before it comes in do we want to
filter this data as it comes in so we're
not storing everything in our file
system you would think hadoop big data
put it all in there i know from
experience that putting it all in there
can turn a couple hundred terabytes into
a petabyte very rapidly and suddenly
you're having to really add on to that
data store and you're storing duplicate
data sometimes so you really need to be
able to filter your data out and so
let's go ahead and use our up arrow to
go to our last import since it's still a
lot the same stuff
so we have all of our commands under
import we have the target we're going to
change this to department 2 so we're
going to create a new directory for this
one and then after departments uh
there's another command that we didn't
really slide in here and that's our
mapping and i'll show you what this
looks like in a minute but we're going
to put m3 in there that doesn't have
nothing to do with the filtering i'll
show you that in a second though what
that's for and we just want to put in
where uh so where and what is the where
in this case we want to know where
department
id and if you want to know where that
came from we can flip back on over here
we have department underscore ids this
is where that's coming from that's just
the name of the column on here so we
come in here to department id is greater
than
four simple um logic there you can see
where you'd use that for maybe creating
buckets for ages uh you know age from 10
to 15 20 to 30. you might be looking for
i mean there's all kinds of reasons why
you could use the where command on here
and filter information out maybe you're
doing word counting and you want to know
words that are used less than 100 times
you want to get rid of the and is and
and all the stuff that's used over and
over again so we'll go ahead and put the
where and then department id is greater
than four we'll go ahead and hit enter
on here and this will create our
department two setup on this and i'll go
ahead and skip over some of the runtime
again it runs really slow on a single
node real quick page through our
commands
let's see here we go
our list and we should see underneath
the list the department two on here now
and there it is department two and then
i can go ahead and do list department
two you'll see the contents in here and
you'll see that there is only three maps
and it could be that the data created
three maps but remember i set it up to
only use three mappers uh so there's
zero one and two and we can go ahead and
do a cat on there remember this is
department two so we want to look at all
the contents of these three different
files and there it is it's greater than
four so we have golf is five outdoor six
uh fan shop is seven so we've
effectively filtered out our data and
just storing the data we want on our
file system so if you're going to store
data on here the next stage is to export
the data remember a lot of times you
have my sql server and we're continually
dumping that data into our long term
storage and access a hadoop file system
but what happens when you need to pull
that data out and
restore a database or
maybe you have
you just merged with a new company a
favorite topic merging companies
emerging databases
that's listed under nightmare and how
many different names for company can you
have so you can see where being able to
export is also equally important and
let's go ahead and do that i'm going to
flip back over to my sql server here and
we'll need to go ahead and create our
database we're going to export into now
i'm not going to go too much in detail
on this command we're simply creating a
table and the table is going to have
it's pretty much the same table we
already have in here from departments
but in this case we're going to create a
table called dept
so it's the same setup but it's just
going to we're just giving a different
name a different schema and so we've
done that and we'll go ahead and do a
select star from dept
there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new database a new data
table and it's empty in there so now we
need to go ahead and export our data
that we just filtered out into there so
let's flip back on over here to our
scoop setup which is just our linux
terminal window and let's go back up to
one of our commands here's scoop import
in this case instead of import we're
going to take the scoop and we're going
to export so we're going to just change
that export
and the connection is going to remain
the same so same connect same database
we're also we're still doing the retail
db we have the same password so none of
that changes
the big change here is going to be the
table instead of departments remember we
changed it and gave it a new name and so
we want to change it here also d-e-p-t
so department we're not going to worry
about the mapper count and the where was
part of our import there we go and then
finally it needs to know where to export
from so instead of target directory we
have an export directory that's where
it's coming from uh still user cloudera
and we'll keep it as department 2. just
so you can see how that data is coming
back with that we filtered in and let's
go ahead and run this it'll take it just
a moment to go through with steps and
again because it's low i'm just going to
go and skip this so you don't have to
sit through it and once we've wrapped up
our export we'll flip back on over here
to mysql use the up arrow and this time
we're going to select star from
department and we can see that there it
is it exported the golf outdoors and fan
shop and you can imagine also that you
might have to use the where command in
your export also so there's a lot of
mixing the command line for scoop is
pretty straightforward you're changing
the different variables in there whether
you're creating a table listing a table
listing databases very powerful tool for
bringing your data into the hadoop file
system and exporting it so now that
we've wrapped up our demo on scoop and
gone through a lot of basic commands
let's dive in with a brief history of
hive so the history of hive begins with
facebook facebook began using hadoop as
a solution to handle the growing big
data and we're not talking about a data
that fits on one or two or even five
computers we're talking due to the fits
on if you've looked at any of our other
hadoop tutorials you'll know we're
talking about very big data and data
pools and facebook certainly has a lot
of data it tracks as we know the hadoop
uses mapreduce for processing data
mapreduce required users to write long
codes and so you have these really
extensive java codes very complicated
for the average person to use not all
users were versed in java and other
coding languages this proved to be a
disadvantage for them users were
comfortable with writing queries in sql
sql has been around for a long time the
standard
sql query language hive was developed
with the vision to incorporate the
concepts of tables columns just like sql
so why hive well the problem was for
processing and analyzing data users
found it difficult to code as not all of
them were well versed with the coding
languages you have your processing ever
analyzing and so the solution was
required a language similar to sql which
was well known to all the users and thus
the hive or hql language evolved what is
hive hive is a data warehouse system
which is used for querying and analyzing
large data sets stored in the hdfs or
the hadoop file system hive uses a query
language that we call hive ql or hql
which is similar to sql so if we take
our user the user sends out their hive
queries and then that is converted into
a mapreduce tasks and then accesses the
hadoop mapreduce system let's take a
look at the architecture of hive
architecture of hive we have the hive
client
so that could be the programmer or maybe
it's a manager who knows enough sql to
do a basic query to look up the data
they need the hive client supports
different types of client applications
in different languages prefer for
performing queries and so we have our
thrift application in the hive thrift
client thrift is a software framework
hive server is based on thrift so it can
serve the request from all programming
language that support thrift and then we
have our jdbc application and the hive
jdbc driver jdbc java database
connectivity jdbc application is
connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python c plus plus spar
java you can find just about any
connection in any of the main scripting
languages and so we have our hive
services as we look at deeper into the
architecture hive supports various
services
so you have your hive server basically
your thrift application or your hive
thrift client or your jdbc or your hive
jdbc driver your odbc application or
your hive odbc driver they all connect
into the hive server and you have your
hive web interface you also have your
cli now the hive web interface is a gui
is provided to execute hive queries and
we'll actually be using that later on
today so you can see kind of what that
looks like and get a feel for what that
means commands are executed directly in
cli and then the cli is a direct
terminal window and i'll also show you
that too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver the hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed
then the optimizer kicks in and the
optimized logical plan in the form of a
graph of mapreduce and hdfs tasks is
obtained and then finally in the
executor in the final step the tasks are
executed we look at the architecture we
also have to note the meta store
metastore is a repository for hive
metadata stores metadata for hive tables
and you can think of this as your schema
and where is it located and it's stored
on the apache derby db processing and
resource management
is all handled by the mapreduce v1
you'll see mapreduce v2 the yarn and the
tez these are all different ways of
managing these resources depending on
what version of hadoop you're in hive
uses mapreduce framework to process
queries and then we have our distributed
storage which is the hdfs and if you
looked at our hadoop
tutorials you'll know that these are on
commodity machines and are linearly
scalable that means they're very
affordable a lot of time when you're
talking about big data you're talking
about a tenth of the price of storing it
on enterprise computers and then we look
at the data flow and hive
so in our data flow in hive we have our
hive in the hadoop system and underneath
the user interface or the ui we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our meta store that all goes into
the mapreduce and the hadoop file system
so when we execute a query you see it
coming in here goes into the driver step
one step two we get a plan what are we
going to do refers to the query
execution then we go to the metadata
it's like well what kind of metadata are
we actually looking at where is this
data located what is the schema on it
then this comes back with the metadata
into the compiler then the compiler
takes all that information and the syn
plan returns it to the driver the driver
then sends the execute plan to the
execution engine once it's in the
execution engine the execution engine
acts as a bridge between hive and hadoop
to process the query and that's going
into your mapreduce in your hadoop file
system or your hdfs and then we come
back with the metadata operations it
goes back into the metastore to update
or let it know what's going on which
also goes to the between it's a
communication between the execution
engine and the metastore execution
engine communications is
bi-directionally with the metastore to
perform operations like create drop
tables metastore stores information
about tables and columns so again we're
talking about the schema of your
database and once we have that we have a
bi-directional
send results communication back into the
driver and then we have the fetch
results which goes back to the client so
let's take a little bit look at the hive
data modeling hive data modeling so you
have your high data modeling you have
your tables you have your partitions and
you have buckets the tables in hive are
created the same way it is done in rd
bms so when you're looking at your
traditional sql server or mysql server
where you might have enterprise
equipment and a lot of
people pulling and removing stuff off of
there the tables are going to look very
similar and this makes it very easy to
take that information and let's say you
need to keep current information but you
need to store all of your years of
transactions back into the hadoop hive
so you match those those all kind of
look the same the tables are the same
your databases look very similar and you
can easily import them back you can
easily store them into the hive system
partitions here tables are organized
into partitions for grouping same type
of data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employees
are concerned and finally we have
buckets uh data present in partitions
can be further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency at this level a lot of times
you're taught you're working with the
programmer and the admin of your hadoop
file system to maximize the efficiency
of that file system so it's usually a
two-person job and we're talking about
hive data modeling you want to make sure
that they work together and you're
maximizing your resources hive data
types so we're talking about hive data
types we have our primitive data types
and our complex data types a lot of this
will look familiar because it mirrors a
lot of stuff in sql in our primitive
data types we have the numerical data
types string data type date time data
type and
miscellaneous data type and these should
be very they're kind of self-explanatory
but just in case numerical data is your
floats your integers your short integers
all of that numerical data comes in as a
number a string of course is characters
and numbers and then you have your date
time stamp and then we have kind of a
general way of pulling your own created
data types in there that's our
miscellaneous data type and we have
complex data types so you can store
arrays you can store maps you can store
structures
and even units in there as we dig into
hive data types
and we have the primitive data types and
the complex data types so we look at
primitive data types and we're looking
at numeric data types data types like an
integer a float a decimal those are all
stored as numbers in the hive data
system a string data type data types
like characters and strings you store
the name of the person you're working
with you know john doe the city
memphis the state tennessee maybe it's
boulder colorado usa or maybe it's hyper
bad
india that's all going to be string and
stored as a string character and of
course we have our date time data type
data types like timestamp date interval
those are very common as far as tracking
sales anything like that you just think
if you can type a stamp of time on it or
maybe you're dealing with the race and
you want to know the interval how long
did the person take to complete whatever
task it was all that is date time data
type and then we talk miscellaneous data
type these are like boolean and binary
and when you get into boolean and binary
you can actually almost create anything
in there but your yes knows zero one now
let's take a look at complex data types
a little closer uh we have arrays so
your syntax is of data type and it's an
array and you can just think of an array
as a collection of same entities one two
three four if they're all numbers and
you have maps this is a collection of
key value pairs
so understanding maps is so central to
hadoop
so we store maps you have a key which is
a set you only have one key per mapped
value and so you in hadoop of course you
collect
the same keys and you can add them all
up or do something with all the contents
of the same key but this is our map as a
primitive type data type and our
collection of key value pairs and then
collection of complex data with comment
so we can have a structure we have a
column name data type comment call a
column comment uh so you can get very
complicated structures in here with your
collection of data and your commented
setup and then we have units and this is
a collection of heterogeneous data types
so the syntax for this is union type
data type data type and so on so it's
all going to be the same a little bit
different than the arrays where you can
actually mix and match different modes
of hive hive operates in two modes
depending on the number and size of data
nodes we have our local mode and our map
reduce mode when we talk about the local
mode it is used when hadoop is having
one data node and the data is small
processing will be very fast on a
smaller data sets which are present in
local machine and this might be that you
have a local file stuff you're uploading
into the hive and you need to do some
processes in there you can go ahead and
run those high processes and queries on
it usually you don't see much in the way
of a single node hadoop system if you're
going to do that you might as well just
use like an sql database or even a java
sqlite or something python is sqlite so
you don't really see a lot of single
node hadoop databases but you do see the
local mode in hive where you're working
with a small amount of data that's going
to be integrated into the larger
database and then we have the map reduce
mode this is used when hadoop is having
multiple data nodes and the data is
spread across various data nodes
processing large data sets can be more
efficient using this mode and this you
can think of instead of it being one two
three or even five computers we're
usually talking with the hadoop file
system we're looking at 10 computers 15
100 where this data is spread across all
those different hadoop nodes difference
between hive and rdbms
remember rdbms stands for the relational
database management system let's take a
look at the difference between hive and
the rdbms with hive hive enforces schema
on read and it's very important that
whatever is coming in that's when hive's
looking at it and making sure that it
fits the model the rdbms enforces a
schema when it actually writes the data
into the database so it's read the data
and then once it starts to write it
that's where it's going to give you the
error tell you something's incorrect
about your scheme hive data size is in
petabytes that is hard to imagine um you
know we're looking at your personal
computer on your desk maybe you have 10
terabytes if it's a high-end computer
we're talking petabytes so that's
hundreds of computers grouped together
when a rdbms data size is in terabytes
very rarely do you see an rdbms system
that's spread over more than five
computers and there's a lot of reasons
for that with the rdbms it actually has
a high end amount of writes to the hard
drive there's a lot more going on there
you're writing and polling stuff so you
really don't want to get too big with an
rd bms or you're going to run into a lot
of problems with hive you can take it as
big as you want hive is based on the
notion of write once and read many times
this is so important and they call it
worm which is write w wants o read are
many times m they refer to it as worm
and that's true of any of a lot of your
hadoop setup it's it's altered a little
bit but in general we're looking at
archiving data that you want to do data
analysis on we're looking at pulling all
that stuff off your rd bms from years
and years and years of business or
whatever your company does or scientific
research and putting that into a huge
data pool so that you can now do queries
on it and get that information out of it
with the rdbms it's based on the notion
of read and write many times so you're
continually updating this database
you're continually bringing up new stuff
new sales
the account changes because they have a
different licensing now whatever
software you're selling all that kind of
stuff where the data is continually
fluctuating and then hive resembles a
traditional database by supporting sql
but it is not a database it is a data
warehouse this is very important it goes
with all the other stuff we've talked
about that we're not looking at a
database but a data warehouse to store
the data and still have fast and easy
access to it for doing queries you can
think of
twitter and facebook they have so many
posts that are archived back
historically those posts aren't going to
change they made the post they're posted
they're there and they're in their
database but they have to store it in a
warehouse in case they want to pull it
back up with the rdbms it's a type of
database management system which is
based on the relational model of data
and then with hive easily scalable at a
low cost again we're talking maybe a
thousand dollars per terabyte um the
rdbms is not scalable at a low cost when
you first start on the lower end you're
talking about 10 000 per terabyte of
data including all the backup on the
models and all the added necessities to
support it as you scale it up you have
to scale those computers and hardware up
so you might start off with a basic
server and then you upgrade to a sun
computer to run it and you spend you
know tens of thousands of dollars for
that hardware upgrade with hive you just
put another computer into your hadoop
file system so let's look at some of the
features of hive
when we're looking at the features of
hive we're talking about the use of sql
like language called hive ql a lot of
times you'll see that as hql which is
easier than long codes this is nice if
you're working with your shareholders
you come to them and you say hey you can
do a basic sql query on here and pull up
the information you need this way you
don't have to take off have your
programmers jump in every time they want
to look up something in the database
they actually now can easily do that if
they're not
skilled in programming and script
writing tables are used which are
similar to the rdbms hence easier to
understand and one of the things i like
about this is when i'm bringing tables
in from a mysql server or sql server
there's almost a direct reflection
between the two so when you're looking
at one which is the data which is
continually changing and then you're
going into the archive database it's not
this huge jump where you have to learn a
whole new language
you mirror that same schema into the
hdfs into the hive making it very easy
to go between the two and then using
hive ql multiple users can
simultaneously query data so again you
have multiple clients in there and they
send in their query that's also true
with the rdbms which kind of cues them
up because it's running so fast you
don't notice the lag time well you get
that also with the hql as you add more
computers and query can go very quickly
depending on how many computers and how
much resources each machine has to pull
the information and hive supports a
variety of data types
so with hive it's designed to be on the
hadoop system which you can put almost
anything into the hadoop file system so
with all that let's take a look at a
demo on hive ql or hql before i dive
into the hands-on demo let's take a look
at the website hive.apache.org
that's the main website uh since apache
it's an apache open source uh software
this is the main software for the main
site for the build and if you go in here
you'll see that they're slowly migrating
hive into beehive and so if you see
beehive versus hive note the beehive as
the new release is coming out that's all
it is it reflects a lot of the same
functionality of hive it's the same
thing and then we like to pull up some
kind of documentation on commands and
for this i'm actually going to go to
hortonworks hive cheat sheet and that's
because hortonworks and cloudera are two
of the most common used builds for
hadoop and for which include hive and
all the different tools in there and so
hortonworks has a pretty good pdf you
can download cheat sheet on there i
believe cloudera does too but we'll go
ahead and just look at the horton one
because it's the one that comes up
really good and you can see when we look
at the query language it compares my sql
server to hive ql or hql and you can see
the basic select we select from columns
from table where conditions exist the
most basic command on there and they
have different things you can do with it
just like you do with your sql and if
you scroll down you'll see data types so
here's your integer your flow your
binary double string timestamp and all
the different data types you can use
some different semantics different keys
features functions
for running a hive query command line
setup and of course the hive shell uh
set up in here so you can see right here
if we loop through it it has a lot of
your basic stuff and it is we're
basically looking at sql across a horton
database we're going to go ahead and run
our hadoop cluster hive demo and i'm
going to go ahead and use the cloudera
quick start this is in the virtual box
so again we have an oracle virtual box
which is open source and then we have
our cloudera quick start which is the
hadoop setup on a single node now
obviously hadoop and hive are designed
to run across a cluster of computers so
we talk about a single node is for
education testing that kind of thing and
if you have a chance you can always go
back and look at our demo we had on
setting up a hadoop system in a single
cluster just set a note down below in
the youtube video and our team will get
in contact with you and send you that
link if you don't already have it or you
can contact us at the www.simply
now in here it's always important to
note that you do need
on your computer if you're running on
windows because i'm on a windows machine
you're going to need probably about 12
gigabytes to actually run this i used to
be buy with a lot less but as things
have evolved they take up more and more
resources and you need the professional
version if you have the home version i
was able to get that to run but boy did
it take a lot of extra work to get the
home version to let me use the virtual
setup on there and we'll simply click on
the cloudera quickstart and i'm going to
go and just start that up and this is
starting up our linux so we have our
windows 10 which is a computer i'm on
and then i have the virtual box which is
going to have a linux operating system
in it and we'll skip ahead so you don't
have to watch the whole install
something interesting to know about the
cloudera is that it's running on
linuxcentos and for whatever reason i've
always had to click on it and hit the
escape button for it to spin up and then
you'll see the dos come in here now that
our cloudera spun up on our virtual
machine with the linux on we can see
here we have our it uses the thunderbird
browser on here by default and
automatically opens up a number of
different tabs for us and a quick note
because i mentioned like the
restrictions on getting set up on your
own computer if you have a home edition
computer and you're worried about
setting it up on there you can also go
in there and spin up a one month free
service on amazon web service to play
with this uh so there's other options
you're not stuck with just doing it on
the quick start menu you can spin this
up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to note is that we've come
in here into cloudera and i'm going to
access this in two ways uh the first one
is we're going to use hue and i'm going
to open up hue and i'll take it a moment
to load from the setup on here and hue
is nice if i go in and use hue as an
editor into hive or into the hadoop
setup usually i'm doing it as a
from an admin side because it has a lot
more information a lot of visuals less
to do with you know actually diving in
there and just executing code and you
can also write this code into files and
scripts and there's other things you can
otherwise you can upload it into hive
but today we're going to look at the
command lines and we'll upload it into
hue and then we'll go into and actually
do our work in a terminal window under
the hive shell now in the hue browser
window if you go under query and click
on the pull down menu and then you go
under editor and you'll see hive there
we go there's our hive setup i go and
click on hive and this will open up our
query down here and now it has a nice
little b that shows our hive going and
we can go something very simple down
here like show
databases and we follow it with the
semicolon and that's the standard in
hive as you always add our
punctuation at the end there and i'll go
ahead and run this and the query will
show up underneath and you'll see down
here since this is a new quick start i
just put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name i haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like
assistant function tables
your databases up here there's all kinds
of things you can research you can look
at through hue as far as a bigger
picture the downside of this is it
always seems to lag for me whenever i'm
doing this i always seem to run slow so
if you're in cloudera you can open up a
terminal window they actually have an
icon at the top you can also go under
applications and under applications
system tools and terminal either one
will work it's just a regular terminal
window and this terminal window is now
running underneath our linux so this is
a linux terminal window or on our
virtual machine which is resting on our
regular windows 10 machine and we'll go
ahead and zoom this in so you can see
the text better on your own video and i
simply just clicked on view and zoom in
and then all we have to do is type in
hive and this will open up the shell on
here and it takes it just a moment to
load when starting up hive i also want
to note that depending on your rights on
the computer you're on in your action
you might have to do pseudohyme and put
in your password and username most
computers are usually set up with the
hive login again it just depends on how
you're accessing the linux system and
the hive shell once we're in here we can
go ahead and do a simple uh hql command
show databases and if we do that we'll
see here that we don't have any
databases so we can go ahead and create
a database and we'll just call it office
for today for this moment now if i do
show we'll just do the up arrow up arrow
is a hotkey that works in both linux and
in hive so i can go back and paste
through all the commands i've typed in
and we can see now that i have my
there's of course a default database and
then there's the office database so now
we've created a database it's pretty
quick and easy and we can go ahead and
drop the database we can do drop
database
office now this will work on this
database because it's empty if your
database was not empty you would have to
do cascade and that drops all the tables
in the database and the database itself
now if we do show database and we'll go
ahead and recreate our database because
we're going to use the office database
for the rest of this hands-on demo a
really handy command to now
set with the sql or hql is to use office
and what that does is that sets office
as a default database so instead of
having to reference the database every
time we work with a table it now
automatically assumes that's the
database being used whatever tables
we're working on the difference is you
put the database name period table and
i'll show you in just a minute what that
looks like and how that's different if
we're going to have a table and a
database we should probably load some
data into it so let me go ahead and
switch gears here and open up a terminal
window you can just open another
terminal window and it'll open up right
on top of the one that you have hive
shell running in and when we're in this
terminal window first we're going to go
ahead and just do a list which is of
course a linux command you can see all
the files i have in here this is the
default load we can change directory to
documents we can list in documents and
we're actually going to be looking at
employee.csv a linux command is the cat
you can use this actually to combine
documents there's all kinds of things
that cat does but if we want to just
display the contents of our employee.csv
file we can simply do cat employee csv
and when we're looking at this we want
to know a couple things one there's a
line at the top okay so the very first
thing we notice is that we have a header
line the next thing we notice is that
the data is comma separated and in this
particular case you'll see a space here
generally with these you've got to be
real careful with spaces there's all
kinds of things you've got to watch out
for because they can cause issues these
spaces won't because these are all
strings that the space is connected to
if this was a space next to the integer
you'd get a null value that comes into
the database without doing something
extra in there now with most of hadoop
that's important to know that you're
writing the data once reading it many
times and that's true of almost all your
hadoop things coming in so you really
want to process the data before it gets
into the database and for those who of
you have studied data transformation
that's the etyl where you extract
transfer form and then load the data so
you really want to extract and transform
before putting it into the hive then you
load it into the hive with the
transformed data and of course we also
want to note the schema we have an
integer string string integer integer so
we kept it pretty simple in here as far
as the way the data is set up the last
thing that you're going to want to look
up
is the source since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
home slash cloudera slash documents and
these are just text documents we're
working with right now we're not doing
anything fancy so we can do a simple get
edit employee.csv
and you'll see it comes up here it's
just a text document so i can easily
remove these added spaces there we go
and then we go and just save it and so
now it has a new setup in there we've
edited it the g edit is usually one of
the default that loads into linux so any
text editor will do back to the hive
shell so let's go ahead and create a
table employee and what i want you to
note here is i did not put the semicolon
on the end here semicolon tells it to
execute that line so this is kind of
nice if you're you can actually just
paste it in if you have it written on
another sheet and you can see right here
where i have create table employee and
it goes into the next line on there so i
can do all of my commands at once now
just so i don't have any typo errors i
went ahead and just pasted the next
three lines in and the next one is our
schema if you remember correctly from
the other side we had the different
values in here which was id
name department year of joining and
salary and the id is an integer name is
a string department string air joining
energy salary an integer and they're in
brackets we put close brackets around
them and you could do this all as one
line and then we have row format
delimited fields terminated by comma and
this is important because the default is
tabs so if i do it now it won't find any
terminated fields so you'll get a bunch
of null values loaded into your table
and then finally our table properties we
want to skip the header line count
equals one now this is a lot of work for
uploading a single file it's kind of
goofy when you're uploading a single
file that you have to put all this in
here but keep in mind hive and hadoop is
designed for writing many files into the
database you write them all in there and
then you can they're saved it's an
archive it's a data warehouse and then
you're able to do all your queries on
them so a lot of times we're not looking
at just the one file coming up we're
loading hundreds of files you have your
reports coming off of your main database
all those reports are being loaded and
you have your log files you have i mean
all this different data is being dumped
into hadoop and in this case hive on top
of hadoop and so we need to let it know
hey how do i handle these files coming
in and then we have the semicolon at the
end which lets us know to go ahead and
run this line and so we'll go ahead and
run that and now if we do a show tables
you can see there's our employee on
there we can also describe if we do
describe employee
you can see that we have our id integer
name string department string year of
joining integer and salary integer and
then finally let's just do a select star
from employee very basic sql nhql
command selecting data it's going to
come up and we haven't put anything in
it so as we expect there's no data in it
so if we flip back to our
linux terminal window you can see where
we did the cat
employee.csv and you can see all the
data we expect to come into it and we
also did our pwd and right here you see
the path you need that full path when
you are loading data you know you can do
a browse and if i did it right now with
just the employee.csv as a name it will
work but that is a really bad habit in
general when you're loading data because
it's you don't know what else is going
on in the computer you want to do the
full path almost in all your data loads
so let's go ahead and flip back over
here to our hive shell we're working in
and the command for this is load data so
that says hey we're loading data that's
a hive command hql and we want local
data so you got to put down local in
path so now it needs to know where the
path is now to make this more legible
i'm just going to go ahead and hit enter
then we'll just paste the full path in
there which i have stored over on the
side like a good prepared demo and
you'll see here we have home cloudera
documents employee.csv so it's a whole
path for this text document in here and
we go ahead and hit enter in there and
then we have to let it know where the
data is going so now we have a source
and we need a destination and it's going
to go into the table and we'll just call
it employee we'll just match the table
in there and because i want it to
execute we put the semicolon on the end
it goes ahead and executes all three
lines now if we go back if you remember
we did the select star from employee
just using the up arrow to page through
my different commands i've already typed
in you can see right here we have as we
expect we have rows sam mike and nick
and we have all their information
showing in our four rows and then let's
go ahead and do uh select
and count let's look at a couple of
these different select options you can
do we're going to count everything from
employee now this is kind of interesting
because the first one just pops up with
the basic select because it doesn't need
to go through the full map reduce phase
but when you start doing a count it does
go through the full map redo setup in
the hive and hadoop and because i'm
doing this demo on a single node
cloudera virtual box on top of a windows
10 all the benefits of running it on a
cluster are gone and instead it's now
going through all those added layers so
it takes longer to run you know like i
said when you do a single node as i said
earlier it doesn't do any good as an
actual distribution because you're only
running it on one computer and then
you've added all these different layers
to run it and we see it comes up with
four and that's what we expect we have
four rows we expect four at the end and
if you remember from
our cheat sheet which we brought up here
from hortons it's a pretty good one
there's all these different commands we
can do we'll look at one more command
where we do the uh what they call sub
queries right down here because that's
really common to do a lot of sub queries
and so we'll do select
star or all different columns from
employee now if we weren't using the
office database it would look like this
from office dot employee and either one
will work on this particular one because
we have office set as the default on
there so from office employee and then
the command where creates a subset and
in this case we want to know where the
salary is greater than 25
000. there we go and of course we end
with our semicolon and if we run this
query you can see it pops up and there's
our salaries of people top earners we
have rows and i t and mike and hr kudos
to them of course they're fictional i
don't actually we don't actually have a
rose and a mic in those positions or
maybe we do so finally we want to go
ahead and do is we're done with this
table now remember you're dealing with a
data warehouse so you usually don't do a
lot of dropping of tables and
databases but we're going to go ahead
and drop this table here before we drop
it one more quick note is we can change
it so what we're going to do is we're
going to alter table office employee and
we want to go ahead and rename it
there's some other commands you can do
in here but renames pretty common and
we're going to rename it to
and it's going to stay in office and uh
turns out one of our
shareholders really doesn't like the
word employee he wants employees plural
it's a big deal to him so let's go ahead
and change that name for the table it's
that easy because it's just changing the
metadata on there and now if we do show
tables you'll see we now have employees
not employee and then at this point
maybe we're doing some house cleaning
because this is all practice so we're
going to go ahead and drop table and
we'll drop table employees because we
changed the name in there so if we did
employee just give us an error and now
if we do show tables you'll see all the
tables are gone now the next thing we
want to take a look at and we're going
to walk back through the loading of data
just real quick because we're going to
load two tables in here and let me just
float back to our terminal window so we
can see what those tables are that we're
loading and so up here we have a
customer we have a customer um file and
we have an order file we want to go
ahead and put the customers and the
orders into here so those are the two
we're doing and of course it's always
nice to see what you're working with so
let's do our cat
customer.csv we could always do g edit
but we don't really need to edit these
we just want to take a look at the data
in customer and important in here is
again we have a header so we have to
skip a line comma separated nothing odd
with the data we have our schema which
is
integer string integer string integer so
you'd want to take that note that down
or flip back and forth when you're doing
it and then let's go ahead and do cat
order dot csv and we can see we have oid
which i'm guessing is the order id we
have a date up something new we've done
integers and strings but we haven't done
date when you're importing new and you
never worked with the date date's always
one of the more trickier fields to port
in when that's true of just about any
scripting language i've worked with all
of them have their own idea of how
date's supposed to be formatted what the
default is this particular format or
it's year and it has all four uh digits
dash month two digits dash day is the
standard import for the hive so you'll
have to look up and see what the
different formats are if you're gonna do
a different format in there coming in or
you're not able to pre-process the data
but this would be a pre-processing of
the data thing coming in if you remember
correctly from our edel which is uh e
just in case you weren't able to hear me
last time etl which stands for extract
transform then load so you want to make
sure you're transforming this data
before it gets into here and so we're
going to go ahead and bring
both this data in here and really we're
doing this so we can show you the basic
join there is if you remember from our
setup merge join all kinds of different
things you can do but joining different
data sets is so common so it's really
important to know how to do this we need
to go ahead and bring in these two data
sets and you can see where i just
created a table customer here's our
schema the integer name age address
salary here's our delimited by commas
and our table properties where we skip a
line well let's go ahead and load the
data first and then we'll do that with
our order and let's go ahead and put
that in here and i've got it split into
three lines so you can see it easily we
got load data local in path so we know
we're loading data we know it's local
and we have the path here's the complete
path for
oops this is supposed to be order csv
grab the wrong one of course it's going
to give me errors because you can't
recreate the same table on there and
here we go create table here's our
integer date customer the basic setup
that we had coming in here for our
schema row format commas table
properties skip header line and then
finally let's load the data into
our order table load data local in path
home cloudera documents order.csv into
table order now if we did everything
right we should be able to do select
star from customer and you can see we
have all seven customers and then we can
do select star from order and we have uh
four orders uh so this is just like a
quick frame we have a lot of times when
you have your customer databases in
business you have thousands of customers
from years and years and some of them
you know they move they close their
business they change names all kinds of
things happen uh so we want to do is we
want to go ahead and find just the
information connected to these orders
and who's connected to them and so let's
go ahead and do it's a select because
we're going to display information so
select and this is kind of interesting
we're going to do c dot id
and i'm going to define c as customer as
a customer table in just a minute then
we're going to do c dot name and again
we're going to define the c c dot age so
this means from the customer we want to
know their id their name their age and
then you know i'd also like to know the
order amount uh so let's do o for dot
amount and then this is where we need to
go ahead and define uh what we're doing
and i'm going to capitalize from
customer so we're going to take the
customer table in here and we're going
to name it c that's where the c comes
from so that's a customer table c and we
want to join order as o that's where our
o comes from so the o dot amount is what
we're joining in there and then we want
to do this on we got to tell it how to
connect the two tables c dot id equals o
dot customer underscore id so now we
know how they're joined and remember we
have seven customers in here we have
four orders and as a processes we should
get a return of four different names
joined together and they're joined based
on of course the orders on there and
once we're done we now have the order
number the person who made the order
their age and the amount of the order
which came from the order table uh so
you have your different information and
you can see how the join works here very
common use of tables and hql and sql and
let's do one more thing with our
database and then i'll show you a couple
other hive commands and let's go ahead
and do a drop and we're going to drop
database office
and if you're looking at this and you
remember from earlier this will give me
an error and let's just see what that
looks like it says fail to execute
exception one or more tables exist so if
you remember from before you can't just
drop a database unless you tell it to
cascade that lets it know i don't care
how many tables are in it let's get rid
of it and in hadoop since it's an our
it's a warehouse a data warehouse you
usually don't do a lot of dropping maybe
at the beginning when you're developing
the schemas and you realize you messed
up you might drop some stuff but down
the road you're really just adding
commodity machines to take up so you can
store more stuff on it so you usually
don't do a lot of database dropping and
some other
fun commands to know is you can do
select round 2.3 as round value you can
do a round off in
hive we can do as floor value which is
going to give us a 2. so it turns it
into an integer versus a float it goes
down you know basically truncates it but
it goes down and we can also do ceiling
which is going to round it up so we're
looking for the next integer above
there's a few commands we didn't show in
here because we're on a single node as
as an admin to help spediate the process
you usually add in partitions for the
data and buckets you can't do that on a
single node because the when you add a
partition it partitions it across
separate nodes but beyond that you can
see it's very straightforward we have
sql coming in and all your basic queries
that are in sql are very similar to hql
let's get started with pig why pig what
is pig map reduce versus hive vs pig
hopefully you've had a chance to do our
hive tutorial in our mapreduce tutorial
if you haven't send a note over to
simplylearn and we'll follow up with a
link to you we'll look at pig
architecture working a pig pig latin
data model pig execution modes a use
case twitter and features a pig and then
we'll tag on a short demo so you can see
pig in action so why pig as we all know
hadoop uses mapreduce to analyze and
process big data processing big data
consumed more time so before we had the
hadoop system they'd have to spend a lot
of money on a huge set of computers and
enterprise machines so he introduced the
hadoop map reduce and so afterwards
processing big data was faster using
mapreduce then what is the problem with
map reduce prior to 2006 all mapreduce
programs were written in java
non-programmers found it difficult to
write lengthy java codes they faced
issues in incorporating map sort reduced
to fundamentals of map reduce while
creating a program you can see here map
face shuffle and sort reduce phase
eventually it became a difficult task to
maintain and optimize a code due to
which the processing time increased you
can imagine a manager trying to go in
there and need a simple query to find
out data and he has to go talk to the
programmers anytime he wants anything so
that was a big problem not everybody
wants to have a on-call programmer for
every manager on their team yahoo faced
problems to process and analyze large
data sets using java as the codes were
complex and lengthy there was a
necessity to develop an easier way to
analyze large datasets without using
time-consuming complex java modes and
codes and scripts and all that fun stuff
apache pig was developed by yahoo it was
developed with the vision to analyze and
process large datasets without using
complex java codes pig was developed
especially for non-programmers pig used
simple steps to analyze data sets which
was time efficient so what exactly is
pig pig is a scripting platform that
runs on hadoop clusters designed to
process and analyze large data sets and
so you have your pig which uses sql like
queries they're definitely not sql but
some of them resemble sql queries and
then we use that to analyze our data pig
operates on various types of data like
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data let's take a closer
look at mapreduce versus hive versus pig
so we start with a compiled language
your mapreduce and we have hive which is
your sql like query and then we have pig
which is a scripting language it has
some similarities to sql but it has a
lot of its own stuff remember sql like
query which is what hive is based off
looks for structured data and so we get
into scripting languages like pig now
we're dealing more with semi-structured
and even unstructured data with a hadoop
map reduced we have a need to write long
complex codes with hive no need to write
complex codes you could just put it in a
simple sql query or hql hive ql and in
pig no need to write complex codes as we
have piglet now remember in the map
reduce it can produce structured
semi-structured and unstructured data as
i mentioned before hive can process only
structured data think rows and columns
where pig can process structured
semi-structured and unstructured data
you can think of structured data as rows
and columns semi-structured as your html
xml documents like you have on your web
pages and unstructured could be anything
from groups of documents and written
format twitter tweets any of those
things come in as very unstructured data
and with our hadoop map reduce we have a
lower level of abstraction with both
hive and pig we have a higher level
abstraction so it's much more easy for
someone to use without having to dive in
deep and write a very lengthy map reduce
code and those map and reduce codes can
take 70 80 lines of code when you can do
the same thing in one or two lines with
high ever pig this is the advantage pig
has over hive it can process only
structured data and hive while in pig it
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data some other
features to know that separates the
different query languages is when we
look at map and reduce mapreduce
supports partitioning features as does
hive pig no concept of partitioning in
picks it doesn't support your
partitioning feature your partitioning
features allow you to partition the data
in such a way that it can be queried
quicker you're not able to do that in
pig mapreduce uses java and python while
hive uses an sql like query language
known as hive ql or hql pig latin is
used which is a procedural data flow
language mapreduce is used by
programmers pretty much as
straightforward on java hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers
have been known to go in and use a hive
for quick query and anybody's been able
to use pig for quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce in pig
under pig code performance is lesser
than mapreduce but better than hive so
if we're going to look at speed and time
the map reduce is going to be the
fastest performance on all of those
where pig will have second and high
follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig latin pig latin
is the procedural data flow language
used in pig to analyze data it is easy
to program using piglet and it is
similar to sql and then we have the
runtime engine runtime engine represents
the execution environment created to run
pig latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces mapreduce programs uses
hdfs or your hadoop file system for
storing and retrieving data and as we
dig deeper into the pig architecture
we'll see that we have pig latin scripts
programmers write a script in piglet to
analyze data using pig then you have the
grunt shell and it actually says grunt
when we start it up and we'll show you
that here in a little bit which goes
into the pig server and this is where we
have our parser parser checks the syntax
of the pig script after checking the
output will be a dag directed acylic
graph and then we have an optimizer
which optimizes after your dag your
logical plan is passed to the logical
optimizer where an optimization takes
place finally the compiler converts the
dag into map reduce jobs and then that
is executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and
stored in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that
the kind of end you always want to
execute everything once you've created
it and so dump is kind of our execution
statement and you can see right here as
we were talking about earlier once we
get to the execution engine and it's
coded into mapreduce then the mapreduce
processes it onto the hdfs
working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users so you have low
data and write pig script and pig
operations so when we look at the
working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users there's step one we
load data and write pig script and step
two in this step all the pig operations
are performed by parser optimizer and
compiler so we go into the pig
operations and then we get to step three
execution of the plan in this stage the
results are shown on the screen
otherwise stored in the hdfs as per the
code so it might be of a small amount of
data you're reducing it to and you want
to put that on the screen or you might
be converting a huge amount of data
which you want to put back into the
hadoop file system for other use let's
take a look at the pig latin data model
the data model of pig latin helps pig to
handle various types of data for example
we have atom rob or 50. atom represents
any single value of primitive data type
in pig latin like integer float string
it is stored as a string tuple so we go
from our atom which are most basic
things so if you look at just rob or
just 50 that's an atom that's our most
basic object we have in pig latin then
you have a tuple tuple represents
sequence of fields that can be of any
data type it is the same as a row in
rdbms for example a set of data from a
single row and you can see here we have
rob comma five and you can imagine with
many of our other examples we've used we
might have the id number the name where
they live their age their date of
starting the job that would all be one
row and stored as a tuple and then we
create a bag a bag is a collection of
tuples it is the same as a table in
rdbms and is represented by brackets and
you can see here we have our table with
rob5 mic 10 and we also have a map a map
is a set of key value pairs key is a
character array type and a value can be
of any type it is represented by the
brackets and so we have name and age
where the key value is mic in 10. pig
latin has a fully nestable data model
that means one data type can be nested
within another here's a diagram
representation of pig latin data model
and in this particular example we have
basically an id number a name an age and
a place and we break this apart we look
at this model from pig latin perspective
we start with our field and if you
remember a field contains basically an
atom it is one particular data type and
the atom is stored as a string which
then converts it into either an integer
or number or character string next we
have our tuple and in this case you can
see that it represents a row so our
tuple would be three comma joe comma 29
comma california and finally we have our
bag which contains three rows in it in
this particular example let's take a
quick look at pig execution modes pig
works in two execution modes depending
on where the data is reciting and where
the pig script is going to run we have
local mode here the pig engine takes
input from the linux file system and the
output is stored in the same file system
local mold local mode is useful in
analyzing small data sets using pig and
we have the map reduced mode here the
pig engine directly interacts and
executes in hdfs and mapreduce in the
map reduce mode queries written in pig
latin are translated into mapreduce jobs
and are run on a hadoop cluster by
default pig runs in this mode there are
three modes in pig depending on how a
pig latin code can be written we have
our interactive mode batch mode and
embedded mode the interactive mode means
coding and executing the script line by
line when we do our example we'll be in
the interactive mode in batch mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
and the file is directly executed and
then there's embedded mode pig lets its
users define their own functions udfss
in a programming language such as java
so let's take a look and see how this
works in a use case in this case use
case twitter users on twitter generate
about 500 million tweets on a daily
basis the hadoop mapreduce was used to
process and analyze this data analyzing
the number of tweets created by a user
in the tweet table was done using
mapreduce and java programming language
and you can see the problem it was
difficult to perform map reduce
operations as users were not well versed
with written complex java codes so
twitter used apache pig to overcome
these problems and let's see how let's
start with the problem statement analyze
the user table and tweet table and find
out how many tweets are created by a
person and here you can see we have a
user table we have alice tim and john
with their id numbers one two three and
we have a tweet table in the tweet table
you have your the id of the user and
then what they tweeted
google was a good whatever it was tennis
dot dot spacecraft olympics politics
whatever they're tweeting about the
following operations were performed for
analyzing given data first the twitter
data is loaded into the pig storage
using load command and you can see here
we have our data coming in and then
that's going into pig storage and this
data is probably on an enterprise
computer so this is actually active
twitter's going on and then it goes into
hadoop file system remember the hadoop
file system is a data warehouse for
storing data and so the first step is we
want to go ahead and load it into the
pig storage into our data storage system
the remaining operations performed are
shown below in join and group operation
the tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from
user names and tweet to the id link
directly to the name so alice was user 1
10 was 2 and john 3. and so now they're
listed with their actual tweet the next
operation is the aggregation the tweets
are counted according to the names the
command used is count so it's very
straightforward we just want to count
how many tweets each user is doing and
finally the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
here where alice had three tim two and
john one pig reduces the complexity of
the operations which would have been
lengthy using mapreduce in joining group
operation the tweet and user tables are
joined and grouped using co-group
command the next operation is the
aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
we're talking about three lines of
script versus a mapreduce code of about
80 lines finally we could find out the
number of tweets created by a user in a
simple way so let's go quickly over some
of the features of pig that we already
went through most of these
first ease of programming as pig latin
is similar to sql lesser lines of code
need to be written short development
time as the code is simpler so we can
get our queries out rather quickly
instead of having to have a programmer
spend hours on it handles all kinds of
data like structured semi-structured and
unstructured pig lets us create user
defined functions pig offers a large set
of operators such as join filter and so
on it allows for multiple queries to
process on parallel and optimization and
compilation is easy as it is done
automatically and internally
so enough theory let's dive in and show
you a quick demo on some of the commands
you can do in pick today's setup will
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go and use cloudera quick start
and we'll be doing this in virtual box
we do have a tutorial in setting that up
you can send a note to our simply learn
team and then get that linked to you
once your cloudera quickstart has uh
spun up and remember this is virtualbox
we've created a virtual machine and this
virtual machine is centos linux once
it's spun up you'll be in a full linux
system here and as you can see we have
thunderbird browser which opens up to
the hadoop basic system browser and we
can go underneath the hue where it comes
up by default if you click on the pull
down menu and go under editor you can
see there's our impala our hive
pig along with a bunch of other query
languages you can use and we're going
under pig and then once you're in pig we
can go ahead and use our command line
here and just click that little blue
button to start it up and running we
will actually be working in terminal
window and so if you're in the cloudera
quick start you can open up the terminal
window up top or if you're in your own
setup and you're logged in you can
easily use all of your commands here in
terminal window and we'll zoom in that
way you get a nice view of what's going
on there we go now for our first command
we're going to do a hadoop command and
import some data into the hadoop system
in this case a pig input and let's take
a look at this we have uh hadoop now
listen no it's going to be a hadoop
command dfs there's actually four
variations of dfs so if you have hdfs or
whatever that's fine all four of them
point used to be different setups
underneath different things and now they
all do the same thing and we want to put
this file which in this case is under
home cloudera documents and sample and
we just want to take that and put it
into the pig input and let's take a look
at that file if i go under my document
browsers and open this up you'll see
it's got a simple id name profession and
age we have one jack engineer 25 and
that was in one of our earlier things we
had in there and so let's go ahead and
hit enter and execute this and now we've
uploaded that data and it's gone into
our pig input and then a lot of the
hadoop commands mimic the linux commands
and so you'll see we have cat as one of
our commands or we has a hyphen before
it so we execute that with hadoop dfs
hyphen cat slash pig input because
that's what we called it that's where we
put our sample csv at and we execute
this you can see from our hadoop system
it's going to go in and pull that up and
sure enough it pulls out the data file
we just put in there and then we can
simply enter the pig latin or pig editor
mode by typing in pig and we can see
here by our grunt i told you that's how
it was going to tell you you were in pig
latin there's our grunt command line so
we are now in the pig shell and then
we'll go ahead and put our load command
in here and the way this works is i'm
going to have office equals load and
here's my load in this case it's going
to be pig input we have that in single
brackets you remember that's where the
data is in the hadoop file system where
we dumped it into there we're going to
using pig storage our data was separated
as with a comma so there's our comma
separator and then we have as in this
case we have an id character array name
character array profession character a
and age character ray and we're just
going to do them all as character arrays
just to keep this simple for this one
and then when i hit put this all in here
you can see that's our full command line
going in and we have our semicolon at
the end so when i hit enter it's now set
office up but it hasn't actually done
anything yet it doesn't do anything
until we do dump office so there's our
command to execute whatever we've loaded
or whatever setup we have in here and we
run that you can see it go through the
different languages and this is going
through the map reduce remember we're
not doing this locally we're doing this
on the hadoop setup and once we finished
our dump you can see we have id name
profession age and all the information
that we just dumped into our pick oh we
can now do let's say oh let's say we
have a request just for we'll keep it
simple in here but just for the name and
age and so we can go office we'll call
it each as our variable underscore each
and we'll say for each office generate
name comma h and for each means that
we're going to do this for each row and
if you're thinking map reduce you know
that this is a map function because it's
mapping each row and generating name and
age on here and of course we want to go
ahead and close it with a semicolon and
then once we've created our query or the
command line in here let's go ahead and
dump office underscore each in with our
semicolon and this will go through our
map reduce
setup on here and if we were on a large
cluster the same processing time would
happen in fact it's really slow because
i have multiple things on this computer
and this particular virtual box is only
using a quarter of my processor it's
only dedicated to this and you can see
here there it is name and age and it
also included the top row since we
didn't delete that out there or tell it
not to and that's fine for this example
but you need to be aware of those things
when you're processing a significantly
large amount of data or any data then we
can also do
office and we'll call this dsc for
descending so maybe the boss comes to
you and says hey can we order office by
id
descending and of course your boss
you've taught him how to uh your
shareholder sounds a little druggatory
and say boss you've talked to the
shareholder and you said and you've
taught them a little bit of pig latin
and they know that they can now create
office description and we can order
office by id description and of course
once we do that we have to dump office
underscore description so that it'll
actually execute and there goes into our
map reduce we'll take just a moment for
it to come up because again i'm running
on only a quarter of my processor and
you can see we now have our ids in
descending order returned let's also
look at and this is so important with
anytime you're dealing with big data
let's create office with a limit and you
can of course do any of this instead of
with office we could do this with office
descending so you get just the top two
ids on there we're gonna limit just to
two and of course to execute that we
have to dump office underscore limit you
can just think of dumping your garbage
into the pig pen for the pig to eat
there we go dump office limit two and
that's gonna just limit our office to
the top 2. and for our output we get our
first row which had our id name
profession and age and our second row
which is jack who's an engineer let's do
an filter we'll call it office
underscore
filter you guessed it equals filter
office by profession equals and keep
note this is uh similar to how python
does it with the double equal signs for
equal for doing a true false statement
so for your logic statement remember to
use two equal signs in pig and we're
going to say it equals doctor so we want
to find out how many doctors do we have
on our list and we'll go ahead and do
our dump we're dumping all our garbage
into the pig pen and we're letting pig
take over and see what it can find out
and see who's a doctor on our list and
we find uh employee id number two bob is
a doctor 30 years old for this next
section we're going to cover something
we see it a lot nowadays in data
analysis and that's word counting
tokenization that is one of the next big
steps as we move forward in our data
analysis where we go from say stock
market analysis of highs and lows and
all the numbers to what are people
saying about companies on twitter what
are they saying on the web pages and on
facebook suddenly you need to start
counting words and finding out how many
words are totaled how many in the first
part of the document and so on we're
going to cover a very basic word count
example and in this case i've created a
document called wordrose.txt
and you can see here we have simplylearn
is a company supporting online learning
simplylearn helps people attain their
certifications simplylearn is an online
community i love learn i love
programming i love data analysis and i
went and saved this into my documents
folder so we could use it and let me go
ahead and open up a new terminal window
for our word count let me go and close
the old one so we're going to go in here
and instead of doing this as pig we're
going to do pig minus x local and what
i'm doing is i'm telling the pig to
start the pig shell but we're going to
be looking at files local to our virtual
box or this centos machine and let me go
ahead and hit enter on there just
maximize this up there we go and it will
load pig up and it's going to look just
the same as the pig we were doing which
was defaulted to hot to our hadoop
system to our hdfs this is now defaulted
to the local system now we're going to
create lines we're going to load it
straight from the file remember last
time we took the hdfs and loaded it into
there and then loaded it into pig since
we're going to local we're just going to
run a local script we have lines equals
load home the actual full path home
cloudera documents and i called it
wordrose.txt
and as line as a character array so each
line and i've actually you can change
this to read each document i certainly
have done a lot of document analysis and
then you go through and do word counts
and different kind of counts in there so
once we go ahead and create our line
instead of doing the dump we're going to
go ahead and start entering all of our
different setups or each of our steps we
want to go through and let's just take a
look at this next one because the load
is straightforward we're loading from
this particular file since we're locals
loading it directly from here instead of
going into the hadoop file system and it
says as and then each line is read as a
character array now we're going to do
words equal for each of the lines
generate flat tokenize line space as
word now there's a lot of ways to do
this this is if you're a programmer
you're just splitting the line up by
spaces there's actual ways to tokenize
it you gotta look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the
flatten takes the line and just creates
a it flattens each of the words out so
this is uh we're just going to generate
a bunch of words for each line and then
each each of those words is as a word a
little confusing in there but if you
really think about it we're just going
down each line separating it out and
we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenized line
without the space in there if you do
that it'll automatically tokenize it by
space you can do either one and then
we're going to do group we're going to
group it by words so we're going to
group words by word so when we we split
it up each token is a word and it's a
list of words and so we're going to
grouped equals group words by word so
we're going to group all the same words
together and if we're going to group
them then we want to go ahead and count
them and so for count we'll go ahead and
create a word count variable and here's
our four each so for each grouped
grouped is our line where we group all
the words in the line that are similar
we're going to generate a group and then
we're going to count the words for each
group so for each line we group the
words together we're going to generate a
group and that's going to count the
words we want to know the word count in
each of those and that comes back in our
word count and finally we want to take
this and we want to go ahead and dump
word count and this is a little bit more
what you see when you start looking at
grunt scripts you'll see right here
these these lines right here we have
each of the steps you take to get there
so we load our file for each of our
lines we're going to generate and
tokenize it into words then we're going
to take the words and we're going to
group them by same words
for each group we're going to generate a
group and we're just going to count the
words so we're going to summarize all
the words in here and let's go ahead and
do our dump word count which executes
all this and it goes through our
mapreduce it's actually a local runner
you'll see down here you start seeing
where they still have map reduced but as
a special runner we're mapping it that's
a part of each row being counted and
grouped and then when we do the word
count that's a reducer the reducer
creates these keys and you can see i is
used three times a came up once and came
up once is to continue on down here to
attain online people company analysis
simply learn they took the top rating
with four certification so all these
things are encountered in the how many
words are used in in data analysis this
is probably the very the beginnings of
data analysis where you might look at it
and say oh they mentioned love
three times so whatever's going on in
this post it's about love and uh what do
they love and then you might attach that
to the different objects in here so you
can see that uh pig latin is fairly easy
to use there's nothing really you know
it takes a little bit to learn the
script uh depending on how good your
memory is as i get older my memory leaks
a little bit more so i don't memorize it
as much but that was pretty
straightforward the script we put in
there and then it goes through the full
map reduce localized run comes out and
like i said it's very easy to use that's
why people like pig latin is because
it's intuitive one of the things i like
about pig latin is when i'm
troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
you start doing one line at a time and
so i can go lines equal load and there's
my loaded text and maybe i'll just dump
lines and then it's going to run it's
going to show me all the lines that i'm
working on in the small amount of data
and that way i can test that if i got an
error on there that said oh this isn't
working maybe they'll be oh my gosh i'm
in map reduce or i'm in the basic um
grunt shell instead of the local path
grunt uh so maybe it'll generate an
error on there and you can see here it
just shows each of the lines going down
hive versus pig on one side we'll have
our sharp stinger on our black and
yellow friend and on the other side our
thick hide on our pig let's start with
an introduction to hbase back in the
days data used to be less and was mostly
structured you see we have structured
data here we usually had it like in a
database where you had uh every field
was exactly the correct length so if you
had a name field that is exactly 32
characters i don't remember the old
access database in microsoft the files
are small if we had you know hundreds of
people in one database that was
considered big data this data could be
easily stored in relational database or
rdbms when we talk about relational
database you might think of oracle you
might think of sql microsoft sql mysql
all of these have evolved even from back
then to do a lot more today than they
did but they still fall short in a lot
of ways and they're all examples of an
rdms or relationship database then
internet evolved and huge volumes of
structured and semi-structured data got
generated and you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam folder you know
we're talking about all the html pages
xml which is a lot of time is displayed
on our html and help desk pages json all
of this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
apache age base apache hbase was the
solution for this let's take a look at
the history the hbase history and we
look at the hbase history we're going to
start back in 2006 november google
released a paper on big table and then
in 2017 just a few months later hbase
prototype was created as a hadoop
contribution later on in the year 2007
in october first usable hbase along with
the hadoop 0.15 was released and then in
january of 2008 hbase became the
subproject of hadoop and later on that
year in october all the way into
september the next year hbase was
released the .81 version the .19 version
and .20 and finally in may of 2010 hbase
became apache top level project and so
you can see in the course of about four
years hbase started off as just an idea
on paper and has evolved all the way
till 2010 as a solid project under the
apache and since 2010 has continued to
evolve and grow as a major source for
storing data in semi-structured data so
what is hbase hbase is a column oriented
database management system derived from
google's nosql database bigtable that
runs on top of the hadoop file system or
the hdfs it's an open source project
that is horizontally scalable and that's
very important to understand that you
don't have to buy a bunch of huge
expensive computers you're expanding it
by continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential nosql
database written in java which permits
faster querying so java is the backend
for the hbase setup and it's well suited
for sparse data sets so it can contain
missing or n a values and this doesn't
boggle it down like it would another
database companies using hbase so let's
take a look and see who is using this
nosql database for their servers and for
storing their data and we have
hortonworks which isn't a surprise
because they're one of the like cloudera
hortonworks they are behind hadoop and
one of the big developments and backing
of it and of course apache hbase is the
open source behind it and we have
capital one as banks you also see bank
of america where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it uh
so their information might be very
sparse they might have one bank way back
when they collected information as far
as the person's family
and what their income for the whole
family is and their personal income and
maybe another one doesn't collect the
family income as you start seeing where
you have data that is very difficult to
store where it's missing a bunch of data
hubspot's using it facebook
certainly all of your facebook twitter
most of your social medias are using it
and then of course there's jpmorgan
chase and company another bank that uses
the hbase as their data warehouse for
nosql let's take a look at an hbase use
case so we can dig a little bit more
into it to see how it functions
telecommunication company that provides
mobile voice and multimedia services
across china the china mobile and china
mobile they generate billions of call
detailed records or cdr and so these
cdrs and all these records are these
calls and how long they are and
different aspects of the call maybe the
tower they're broadcasted from all that
is being recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing and real-time analysis
of billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution apache
hbase hbase stores billions of rows of
detailed call records hbc performs fast
processing of records using sql queries
so you can mix your sql and nosql
queries and usually just say no sql
queries because of the way the query
works applications of hbase one of them
would be in the medical industry hbase
is used for storing genome sequences
storing disease history of people of an
area and you can imagine how sparse that
is as far as both of those a genome
sequence might be only have pieces to it
that each person is unique or is unique
to different people and the same thing
with disease you really don't need a
column for every possible disease a
person could get you just want to know
what those diseases those people have
had to deal with in that area e-commerce
hbase is used for storing logs about
customer search history performs
analytics and target advertisement for
better business insights sports hbase
stores match details in the history of
each match uses this data for better
prediction so when we look at hbase we
all want to know what's the difference
between hbase versus rdbms that is a
relational database management system
hbase versus rdbms so the hbase does not
have a fixed schema schema-less defines
only column families and we'll show you
what that means later on rdbms has a
fixed schema which describes the
structure of the tables and you can
think of this as you have a row and you
have columns and each column is a very
specific structure how much data can go
in there and what it does with the hbase
it works well with structured and
semi-structured data with the rdbms it
works only well with structured data
with the aids base it can have
denormalized data it can contain missing
or null values with the rdbms it can
store only normalized data now you can
still store a null value in the rdbms
but it still takes up the same space as
if you're storing a regular value in
many cases and it also for the hbase is
built for y tables it can be scaled
horizontally for instance if you were
doing a tokenizer of words and word
clusters you might have 1.4 million
different words you're pulling up and
combinations of words so with an rdbms
it's built for thin tables that are hard
to scale you don't want to store 1.4
million columns in your sql it's going
to crash and it's going to be very hard
to do searches with the age base it only
stores that data which is part of
whatever row you're working on let's
look at some of the features of the
hbase it's scalable data can be scaled
across various nodes as it is stored in
the hdfs and i always think about this
it's a linear add-on for each terabyte
of data i'm adding on roughly a thousand
dollars in commodity computing with an
enterprise machine uh we're looking at
about 10 000 at the lower end for each
terabyte of data that includes all your
backup and redundancy so it's a big
difference it's like a tenth of the cost
to store it across the hbase it has
automatic failure support right ahead
log across clusters which provides
automatic support against failure
consistent read and write hbase provides
consistent read and write of the data
it's a java api for client access
provides easy to use java api for
clients block cache and bloom filters so
the hbase supports block caching and
bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase storage a space column
oriented storage and i told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key this is really one of the
important references is each row has to
have its own key or your row id and then
you have your column family and in here
you can see we have column family one
column family two column family three
and you have your column qualifiers so
you can have in column family one you
can have three columns in there and
there might not be any data in that so
when you go into column family one and
do a query for every column that
contains a certain thing that row might
not have anything in there and not be
queried where in column family two maybe
you have column one filled out and
column three filled out and so on and so
forth and then each cell is connected to
the row where the data is actually
stored let's take a look at this and
what it looks like when you fill the
data in so in here we have a row key
with a row id and we have our employee
id one two three that's pretty
straightforward you probably would even
have that on an sql server and then you
have your column family this is where it
starts really separating out your column
family might have personal data and
under personal data you would have name
city age you might have a lot more than
just that you might have number of
children you might have degree all those
kinds of different things that go into
personal data and some of them might be
missing you might only have the name and
the age of an employee you might only
have the name the city and how many
children and not the age and so you can
see with the personal data you can now
collect a large variety of data and
store it in the hbase very easily and
then maybe you have a family of
professional data your designation your
salary all the stuff that the employee
is doing for you in that company let's
dig a little deeper into the hbase
architecture and so you can see here
what looks to be a complicated chart
it's not as complicated as you think
from the apache a space we have the
zookeeper which is used for monitoring
what's going on and you have your h
master this is the hbase master assigns
regions and load balancing and then
underneath the region or the hbase
master then under the h master or hbase
master you have your read your server
serves data for read and write and the
region server which is all your
different computers you have in your
hadoop cluster you'll have a region an h
log you'll have a store memory store and
then you have your different files for h
file that are stored on there and those
are separated across the different
computers and that's all part of the
hdfs storage system so we look at the
architectural components or regions and
we're looking down we're drilling down a
little bit hbase tables are divided
horizontally by row so you have a key
range into regions so each of those ids
you might have ids 1 to 20 21 to 50 or
whatever they are regions are assigned
to the nodes in the cluster called
region servers a region contains all
rows in the table between the regions
start key and the end key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
get and the git sends it out and finds
out where that start if it's between
which start keys and n keys and then it
pulls the data from that different
region server and so the region sign
data definition language operation
create delete are handled by the
h-master so the h-master is telling it
what are we doing with this data what's
going out there assigning and
reassigning regions for recovery or load
balancing and monitoring all servers so
that's also part of it so you know if
your ids if you have 500 ids across
three servers you're not going to put
400 ids on server 1 and 100 on the
server 2 and leaves region 3 and region
4 empty you're going to split that up
and that's all handled by the h master
and you can see here monitors region
servers assigns regions to region
servers assigns regions to recent
servers and so forth and so forth hbase
has a distributed environment where
h-master alone is not sufficient to
manage everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with h-master so you
have an active h-master which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region servers so
the region servers send their status to
zoo keeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active hmaster
fails it will come to the rescue active
hmaster and region servers connect with
a session 2 zookeeper so you see your
active hmaster selection region server
session they're all looking at the
zookeeper keeping that pulse an active
h-master region server connects with a
session to the zoo keeper and you can
see here where we have ephemeral nodes
for active sessions via heartbeats to
indicate that the region servers are up
and running so let's take a look at
hbase read or write going on there's a
special hbase catalog table called the
meta table which holds the location of
the regions in the cluster here's what
happens the first time a client reads or
writes data to hbase the client gets the
region server the host the meta table
from zookeeper and you can see right
here the client it has a request for
your region server and goes hey
zookeeper can you handle this the
zookeeper takes a look at it and goes ah
metal location is stored in zookeeper so
it looks at his
data on there and then the metadata
table location is sent back to the
client the client will query the meta
server to get the region server
corresponding to the row key if it wants
to access the client caches this
information along with the minute table
location and you can see here the client
going back and forth to the region
server with the information and it might
be going across multiple region servers
depending on what you're querying so we
get the region server for row key from
the meta table that's where that row key
comes in and says hey this is where
we're going with this and so once it
gets a row key from the corresponding
region server we can now put row or get
row from that region server let's take a
look at the hbase meta table special
hbase catalog table that maintains a
list of all the region servers in the
hbase storage system so you see here we
have the meta table we have a row key
and a value table key region region
server so the meta table is used to find
the region for the given table key and
you can see down here you know meta
table comes in is going to fire out
where it's going with the region server
and we look a little closer at the right
mechanism in hbase we have right ahead
log or wall as you abbreviate it kind of
a way to remember wall is right ahead
log is a file used to store new data
that is yet to be put on permanent
storage it is used for recovery in the
case of failure so you can see here
where the client comes in and it
literally puts the new data coming in
into this kind of temporary storage or
the wall on there once it's gone into
the wall then the memory store memstor
is the right cache that stores a new
data that's not yet been written to disk
there is one mems store per column
family per region and once we've done
that we have three ack once the data is
placed in mems store the client then
receives the acknowledgement when the
mems store reaches the threshold it
dumps or commits the data into h file as
you can see right here we've taken our
gun into the wall the wall then source
it into the different memory stores
and then the memory stores it says hey
we've reached we're ready to dump that
into our h files and then it moves it
into the h files h files store the rows
as data as stored key value on disk so
here we've done a lot of theory let's
dive in and just take a look and see
what some of these commands look like
and what happens in our age base when
we're manipulating a nosql setup
[Music]
so if you're learning a new setup it's
always good to start with where is this
coming from it's open source by apache
and you can go to hbase.apache.org
and you'll see that it has a lot of
information you can actually download
the hbase separate from the hadoop
although most people just install the
hadoop because it's bundled with it and
if you go in here you'll find a
reference guide and so you can go
through the apache reference guide and
there's a number of things to look at
but we're going to be going through
apache hbase shell that's what we're
going to be working with and there's a
lot of other interfaces on the setup and
you can look up a lot of the different
commands on here so we go into the
apache hbase reference guide we can go
down to read hbase shell commands from a
command file you can see here where it
gives you different options of formats
for putting the data in and listing the
data certainly can also create files and
scripts to do this too but we're going
to look at the basics we're going to go
through this on a basic hbase shell and
one last thing to look at is of course
if you continue down the setup you can
see here where they have more detail as
far as how to create and how to get to
your data on your hbase now i will be
working in a virtual box and this is by
oracle you can download the oracle
virtual box you can put a note in below
for the youtube as we did have a
previous session on setting up virtual
setup to run your hadoop system in there
i'm using the cloudera quick start
installed in here there's hordens you
can also use the amazon web service
there's a number of options for trying
this out in this case we have cloudera
on the oracle virtualbox the virtual box
has linux centos installed on it and
then the hadoop that has all the
different hadoop flavors including hbase
and i bring this up because my computer
is a windows 10 the operating system of
the virtual box is linux and we're
looking at the hbase data warehouse and
so we have three very different entities
all running on my computer and that can
be confusing if it's the first time in
and working with this kind of setup now
you'll notice in our cloudera setup they
actually have some hbase monitoring so i
can go underneath here and click on
hbase and master and it'll tell me
what's going on with my region servers
it'll tell me what's going on with our
backup tables right now i don't have any
user tables because we haven't created
any and this is only a single node and a
single hbase tour so you're not going to
expect anything too extensive in here
since this is for practice and education
and perhaps testing out package you're
working on it's not for really you can
deploy cloudera of course but when you
talk about a quick start or a single
node setup that's what it's really for
so we can go through all the different
hbase and you'll see all kinds of
different information with zookeeper if
you saw it flash by down here what
version we're working in since zookeeper
is part of the hbase setup where we want
to go is we want to open up a terminal
window and in cloudera it happens to be
up at the top and when you click on here
you'll see your cloudera terminal window
open and let me just expand this we have
a nice full screen and then i'm also
going to zoom in that way you have a
nice big picture and you can see what
i'm typing and what's going on and to
open up your hbase shell simply type
hbase shell to get in and hit enter and
you'll see it takes just a moment to
load and we'll be in our age based shell
for doing hbase commands once we've
gotten into our hbase shell you'll see
it'll have the hbase prompt information
ahead of it we can do something simple
like list this is going to list whatever
tables we have it so happens that
there's a base table that comes with
hbase now we can go ahead and create and
i'm going to type in just create what's
nice about this is it's going to throw
me kind of a it's going to say hey
there's no just straight create but it
does come up and tell me all these
different formats we can use for create
so we can create our table and one of
our families you can add splits names
versions all kinds of things you can do
with this let's just start with a very
basic one on here and let's go ahead and
create and we'll call it new
table now let's just call it new tbl for
table new table and then we also want to
do let's do knowledge so let's take a
look at this i'm creating a new table
and it's going to have a family of
knowledge in it and let me hit enter
it's going to come up it's going to take
it a second to go ahead and create it
now we have our new table in here so if
i go list you'll now see table and new
table so you can now see that we have
the new table and of course the default
table that's set up in here and we can
do something like uh describe we can
describe and then we're going to do new
tbl and when we describe it it's going
to come up it's going to say hey name i
have knowledge data block encoding none
bloom filter row replication scope
version all the different information
you need new minimum version zero
forever deleted cells false block size
in memory you can look this stuff up on
apache.org to really track it down one
of the things that's important to note
is versions so you have your different
versions of the data that's stored and
that's always important to understand
that we might talk about that a little
bit later on and then we have to
describe it we can also do a status the
status says i have one active master
going on that's our hbase as a whole we
can do status
summary it should do the same thing as
status so we got the same thing coming
up and now that we've created let's go
ahead and put something in it so we're
going to put new tbl and then we want
row one you know what before i even do
this let's just type in put and you can
see when i type in put it gives us like
a lot of different options of how it
works and different ways of formatting
our data as it goes in and all of them
usually begin with the new table new tbl
then we have in this case we'll call it
row one and then we'll have knowledge
remember we created knowledge already
and we'll do knowledge sports and then
in knowledge and sports we're gonna set
that equal to qriket so we're gonna put
underneath this uh our knowledge setup
that we have a thing called sports in
there and we'll see what this looks like
in just a second let's go ahead and put
in we'll do a couple of these let's see
let's do another row one and this time
instead of sports let's do
science you know this person not only
you know we have row one which is both
knowledgeable and cricket and also in
chemistry so it's a chemist who plays
cricket in row one and uh let's see if
we have let's do another row one just to
keep it going and we'll do science in
this case let's do physics not only in
chemistry but also a physicist i have
quite a joy in physics myself so here we
go we have row one there we go and then
let's do uh row two let's see what that
looks like when you start putting in row
two and in row two this person is has
knowledge in economics this is a master
of business and how or maybe it's global
economics maybe it's just for the
business and how it fits in with the
country's economics and we call it
macroeconomics so i guess it is for the
whole country there so we have knowledge
economics macroeconomics and then let's
just do one more we'll keep it as row
two and this time our economist is also
a musician so we'll put music and they
happen to have knowledge and they enjoy
oh let's do pop music they're into the
current pop music going on so we've
loaded our database and you'll see we
have two rows row one and row two in
here and we can do is we can list the
contents of our database by simply doing
scan scan and then let's just do scan by
itself so you can see how that looks you
can always just type in there and it
tells you all the different setups you
can do with scan and how it works in
this case we want to do scan new tbl and
in our scan new tbl we have row one row
one row two row two and you'll see row
one has a column called knowledge
science time step value crickets value
physics so it has information as when it
was created when the timestamp is rule
one also has knowledge sports and a
value of cricket so we have sports and
science and this is interesting because
if you remember up here we also gave it
originally we told it to come in here
and have chemistry we had science
chemistry and science physics and we
come down here i don't see the chemistry
why because we've now replaced chemistry
with physics so the new value is physics
on here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're going to
ask the question is enabled new
table when i hit enter in here you're
going to see it comes out true and then
we'll go ahead and disable it let's go
ahead disable new table make sure i have
our quotes around it and now that we've
disabled it what happens when we do the
scan when we do the scan new table and
hit enter you're going to see that we
get an error coming up so once it's
disabled you can't do anything with it
until we re-enable it now before we
enable the table let's do an alteration
on it and here's our new table and this
should look a little familiar because
it's very similar to create we'll call
this test info we'll hit enter in there
it'll take just a moment for updating
and then we want to go ahead and enable
it so let's go ahead and enable our new
table so it's back up and running and
then we want to describe describe
new table and we come in here you'll now
see we have name knowledge and under
there we have our data encoding and all
the information under knowledge and then
we also have down below test info so now
we have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops i already
did that i guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at well we
had scan new table and you can see here
where it brings up the information like
this what if we want to go ahead and get
a row so we'll do r1 and when we do
hbase r1 you can see we have knowledge
science and it has a time stamp value
physics and we have knowledge sports and
it has a time stamp on it and value
cricut and then let's see what happens
when we put into our new
table and in here we want row one and if
you can guess from earlier because we
did something similar uh we're going to
do knowledge economics and then it's
going to be instead of i think it was
what uh macroeconomics is now market
economics and we'll go back and do our
get command and now see what it looks
like and we can see here where we have
knowledge economics it has a timestamp
value market economics physics and
cricket and this is because we have
economic science and sports those are
the three different columns that we have
and then each one has different
information in it and so if you manage
to go through all these commands and
look at basics on here you'll now have
the ability to create a very basic hbase
setup nosql setup based on your columns
and your rows and just for fun we'll go
back to the cloudera where they have the
website up for the hbase master status
and i'll go ahead and refresh it and
then we can go down here and you'll see
user tables table set one and we can
click on details and here's what we just
did it goes through so if you're the
admin looking at this and go oh someone
just created new tbl and this is what
they have underneath of it and their new
table in there here we will learn on
apache spark history of spark what is
spark hadoop which is a framework again
wes spark components of apache spark
that is spark core spark sql spark
streaming spark ml lab and graphics then
we will learn on spark architecture
applications of spark spark use cases so
let's begin with understanding about
history of apache spark it all started
in 2009 as a project at uc berkeley amp
labs by mate
in 2010 it was open source under a bsd
license in 2013 spark became an apache
top level project and in 2014
used by data bricks to sort large scale
data sets and it set a new world record
so that's how apache spark started and
today it is one of the most in-demand
processing framework or i would say
in-memory computing framework which is
used across the big data industry so
what is apache spark let's learn about
this apache spark is a open source
in-memory computing framework or you
could say data processing engine which
is used to process data in batch and
also in real time across various cluster
computers and it has a very simple
programming language behind the scenes
that is scala which is used although if
users would want to work on spark they
can work with python they can work with
scala they can work with java and so on
even r for that matter so it supports
all these programming languages and
that's one of the reasons that it is
called polyglot wherein you have good
set of libraries and support from all
the programming languages and developers
and data scientists incorporate spark
into their applications or build spark
based applications to process analyze
query
and transform data at a very large scale
so these are key features of apache
spark now if you compare hadoop west
spark we know that hadoop is a framework
and it basically has map reduce which
comes with hadoop for processing data
however processing data using map reduce
in hadoop is quite slow because it is a
batch oriented operation and it is time
consuming if you if you talk about spark
spark can process the same data 100
times faster than mapreduce as it is a
in-memory computing framework well there
can always be conflicting ideas saying
what if my spark application is not
really efficiently coded and my
mapreduce application has been very
efficiently coded well then it's a
different case however normally if you
talk about code which is efficiently
written for mapreduce or for spark based
processing spark will win the battle by
doing almost 100 times faster than
mapreduce so as i mentioned hadoop
performs batch processing and that is
one of the paradigms of map reduced
programming model which involves mapping
and reducing and that's quite rigid so
it performs batch processing the
intermittent data is written to sdfs and
written red back from sdfs and that
makes hadoop's mapreduce processing
slower in case of spark it can perform
both batch and real-time processing
however a lot of use cases are based on
real-time processing take an example of
macy's take an example of retail giant
such as walmart and there are many use
cases who would prefer to do real-time
processing or i would say near real-time
processing so when we say real time or
near real time it is about processing
the data as it comes in or you're
talking about streaming kind of data now
hadoop or hadoop's mapreduce obviously
was started to be written in java now
you could also write it in scala or in
python however if you talk about
mapreduce it will have more lines of
code since it is written in java and it
will take more times to execute you have
to manage the dependencies you have to
do the right declarations you have to
create your mapper and reducer and
driver classes however if you compare
spark it has few lines of code as it is
implemented in scala and scala is a
statically typed dynamically inferred
language it's very very concise and the
benefit is it has features from both
functional programming and
object-oriented language and in case of
scala whatever code is written that is
converted into byte codes and then it
runs in the jvm now hadoop supports
kerberos authentication there are
different kind of authentication
mechanisms kerberos is one of the
well-known ones and it can really get
difficult to manage now spark supports
authentication via a shared secret it
can also run on yarn leveraging the
capability of kerberos so what are spark
features which really makes it unique or
in demand processing framework when we
talk about spark features one of the key
features is fast processing so spark
contains resilient distributed data sets
so rdds are the building blocks for
spark and we'll learn more about rdds
later so spark contains rdds which saves
huge time taken in reading and writing
operations so it can be 100 times or you
can say 10 to 100 times faster than
hadoop when we say in memory computing
here i would like to make a note that
there is a difference between caching
and in memory computing think about it
caching is mainly to support read ahead
mechanism where you have your data
pre-loaded so that it can benefit
further queries however when we say in
memory computing we are talking about
lazy valuation we are talking about data
being loaded into memory only and only
when a specific kind of action is
invoked so data is stored in ram so here
we can say ram is not only used for
processing but it can also be used for
storage and we can again decide whether
we would want that ram to be used for
persistence or just for computing so it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics now
spark is quite flexible it supports
multiple languages as i already
mentioned and it allows the developers
to write applications in java scala r or
python it's quite fault tolerance so
spark contains these rdds or you could
say execution logic or you could say
temporary data sets which initially do
not have any data loaded
and the data will be loaded into rdds
only when execution is happening so
these can be fault tolerant as
these rdds are distributed across
multiple nodes so failure of one worker
node in the cluster will really not
affect the rdds because that portion can
be recomputed so it ensures loss of data
it ensures that there is no data loss
and it is absolutely fault tolerant it
is for better analytics so spark has
rich set of sql queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics all of this
supported by various par components
which we will learn in coming slides
with all these functionalities analytics
can be performed better in terms of
spark so these are some of the key
features of spark however there are many
more features which are related to
different components of spark and we
will learn about them so what are these
components of spark which i'm talking
about spark core so this is the core
component which basically has rdds which
has a core engine which takes care of
your processing now you also have spark
sql so people who would be interested in
working on structured data or data which
can be structuralized would want to
prefer using spark sql and spark sql
internally has components or features
like data frames and data sets which can
be used to process your structured data
in a much much faster way you have spark
streaming now that's again an important
component of spark which allows you to
create your spark streaming applications
which not only works on data which is
being streamed in or data which is
constantly getting generated but you
would also or you could also transform
the data you could analyze or process
the data as it comes in in smaller
chunks you have sparks mlib now this is
basically a set of libraries which
allows developers or data scientists to
build their machine learning algorithms
so that they can do predictive analytics
or prescriptive descriptive pre-emptive
analytics or they could build their
recommendation systems or bigger smarter
machine learning algorithms using these
libraries and then you have graphics so
think about organizations like linkedin
or say twitter where you have data which
naturally has a network kind of flow so
data which could be represented in the
form of graphs now here when i talk
about graphs i'm not talking about pie
charts or bar charts but i'm talking
about network related data that is data
which can be networked together which
can have some kind of relationship think
about facebook think about linkedin
where you have one person connected to
other person or one company connected to
other companies so if we have our data
which can be represented in the form of
network graphs then spark has a
component called graphics which allows
you to do graph based processing so
these are some of the components of
apache spark spark core spark sql spark
streaming spark mlib and graphics so to
learn more about components of spark
let's learn here about spark core now
this is the base engine and this is used
for large scale parallel and distributed
data processing so when you work with
spark at least and the minimum you would
work with a spark core which has rdds as
the building blocks of your spark so it
is responsible for your memory
management your fault recovery
scheduling distributing and monitoring
jobs on a cluster and interacting with
storage system so here i would like to
make a key point that spark by itself
does not have its own storage
it relies on storage now that storage
could be your sdfs that is hadoop's
distributed file system it could be a
database like nosql database such as
hbase or it could be any other database
say rdbms from where you could connect
your spark and then fetch the data
extract the data process it analyze it
so let's learn a little bit about your
rdds resilient distributed data sets now
spark core which is the base engine or
the core engine is embedded with the
building blocks of spark which is
nothing but your resilient distributed
data set so as the name says it is
resilient so it is existing for a
shortest period of time distributed so
it is distributed across nodes and it is
a data set where the data will be loaded
or where the data will be existing for
processing so it is immutable fault
tolerant distributed collection of
objects so that's what your rdd is and
there are mainly two operations which
can be performed on an rdd now to take
an example of this
say i want to process a particular file
now here i could write a simple code in
scala and that would basically mean
something like this so if i say val
which is to declare a variable i would
say val x and then i could use what we
call a spark context which is basically
the most important entry point of your
application so then i could use a method
of spark context for example that is
text file and then i could point it to a
particular file so this is just a method
of your spark context and spark context
is the entry point of your application
now here i could just give a path in
this method so what does this step do it
does not do any evaluation so when i say
val x i'm creating an immutable variable
and to that variable i'm assigning a
file now what this step does is it
actually creates a rdd resilient
distributed data set so we can imagine
this as a simple execution logic a empty
data set which is created in memory of
your node so if i would say i have
multiple nodes in which my data is split
and stored imagining that your yarn your
spark is working with hadoop so i have
hadoop which is using say two nodes and
this is my distributed file system sdfs
which basically means my file is written
to htfs and it also means that the file
related blocks are stored in the
underlying disk of these machines so
when i say val x equals sc.text file
that is using a method of spark context
now there are various other methods like
whole text files parallel eyes and so on
this step will create an rdd so you can
imagine this as a logical data set which
is created in memory across these nodes
because these nodes have the data
however no data is loaded here so this
is the first rdd and i can say first
step in what we call as a tag a dag
which will have series of steps which
will get executed at later stage now
later i could do further processing on
this i could say val y and then i could
do something on x so i could say x dot
map and i would want to apply a function
to every record or every element in this
file and i could give a logic here x dot
map now this second step is again
creating an rdd a resilient distributed
data set you can say second step in my
dag okay and here you have a external
rdd one more rdd created which depends
on the first rtd so my first rdd becomes
the base rdd or parent rdd and the
resultant rdd becomes the child rdd then
we can go further and we could say val
zed and i would say okay now i would
want to do some filter on y so this
filter which i am doing here and then i
could give a logic might be i'm
searching for a word i am searching for
some pattern so i could say val z equals
y dot filter which again creates one
more rdd a resilient distributed data
set in memory and a you can say this is
nothing but one more step in the dag so
this is my tag which is a series of
steps which will be executed now here
when does the execution happen when the
data get when will the data get loaded
into these rdds so all of this that is
using a method using a transformation
like map using a transformation like
filter or flat map or anything else
these are your
transformations so the operations such
as map filter join union and many others
will only create rdds which basically
means it is only creating execution
logic no data is evaluated no operation
is happening right now only and only
when you invoke an action that is might
be you want to print some result might
be you want to take some elements and
see that might be you want to do a count
so those are actions which will actually
trigger the execution of this dag right
from the beginning so if i here say z
dot count where i would want to just
count the number of words which i am
filtering this is an action which is
invoked and this will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning so this is what happens in a
spark now if i do a z dot count again
it will start the whole execution of dag
again right from the beginning so my z
dot count second time in action is
invoked again the data will be loaded in
the first rtd then you will have map
then you will have filter and finally
you will have result
so this is the core concept of your rdds
and this is how rtd works so mainly in
spark there are two kind of operations
one is your transformations and one is
your actions transformations are using a
method of spark context will always and
always create an rtd or you could say a
step in the tag actions are something
which will invoke the execution which
will invoke the execution from the first
rdd till the last rdd where you can get
your result so this is how your rdds
work now when we talk about components
of spark let's learn a little bit about
spark sql so spark sql is a component
type processing framework which is used
for structured and semi-structured data
processing so usually people might have
their structured data stored in rdbms or
in files where data is structured with
particular delimiters and has a pattern
and if one wants to process this
structured data if one wants to
use spark to do in-memory processing and
work on this structured data they would
prefer to use spark sql so you can work
on different data formats say csv json
you can even work on smarter formats
like avro parquet even your binary files
or sequence files you could have your
data coming in from an rdbms which can
then be extracted using a jdbc
connection so at the bottom level when
you talk about spark sql it has a data
source api which basically allows you to
get the data in whichever format it is
now spark sql has something called as
data frame api so what are data frames
data frames in short you can visualize
or imagine as rows and columns or if
your data can be represented in the form
of rows and columns with some column
headings so data frame api allows you to
create data frames so like my previous
example when you work on a file when you
want to process it you would convert
that into an rdd using a method of smart
context or by doing some transformations
so in the similar way when you use data
frames or when you want to use spark sql
you would use sparks context which is
sql context or hive context or spark
which allows you to work with data
frames so like in my earlier example we
were saying val x equals sc dot text
file now in case of data frames instead
of sc you would be using say spark dot
something so spark context is available
for your data frames api to be used in
older versions like spark 1.6 and so on
we were using hive context or sql
context so if you were working with
spark 1.6 you would be saying val x
equals sql context dot here we would be
using spark dot so data frame api
basically allows you to create data
frames out of your structured data which
also lets spark know that data is
already in a particular structure it
follows a format and based on that your
sparks back-end dag scheduler right so
when i say about that i talk about your
sequence of steps so spark is already
aware of
what are the different steps involved in
your application so your data frame api
basically allows you to create data
frames out of your data and data frames
when i say i'm talking about rows and
columns with some headings
and then you have your data frame dsl
language or you can use spark sql or
hive query language any of these options
can be used to work with your data
frames so to learn more about data
frames follow in the next sessions when
you talk about spark streaming now this
is very interesting for organizations
who would want to work on streaming data
imagine a store like macy's where they
would want to have machine learning
algorithms now what would these machine
learning algorithms do suppose you have
a lot of customers walking in the store
and they are
searching for particular product or
particular item so there could be
cameras placed in the store and this is
being already done there are cameras
placed in the store which will keep
monitoring in which corner of the store
there are more customers now once camera
captures this information this
information can be streamed in to be
processed by algorithms and those
algorithms will see which product or
which series of product customers might
be interested in and if this algorithm
in real time can process based on the
number of customers based on the
available product in the store it can
come up with a attractive alternative
price so that which the price can be
displayed on the screen and probably
customers would buy the product now this
is a real-time processing where the data
comes in algorithms work on it do some
computation and give out some result and
which can then result in customers
buying a particular product so the whole
essence of this machine learning and
real-time processing will really hold
good if and when customers are in the
store or this could relate to even an
online shopping portal where there might
be machine learning algorithms which
might be doing real time processing
based on the clicks which customer is
doing based on the clicks based on
customer history based on customer
behavior algorithms can come up with
recommendation of products or better
altered price so that the sale happens
now in this case we would be
seeing the essence of real time
processing only in a fixed or in a
particular duration of time and this
also means that you should have
something which can process the data as
it comes in so spark streaming is a
lightweight api that allows developers
to perform batch processing and also
real-time streaming and processing of
data so it provides secure reliable fast
processing of live data streams so what
happens here in spark streaming in brief
so you have a input data stream now that
data stream could be a file which is
constantly getting appended it could be
some kind of metrics it could be some
kind of events based on the clicks which
customers are doing or based on the
products which they are choosing in a
store this input data stream is then
pushed in through a spark streaming
application now spark streaming
application will broke break this
content into smaller streams what we
call as disk criticized streams or
batches of smaller data on which
processing can happen in frames so you
could say process my file every five
seconds for the latest data which has
come in now there are also some windows
based uh
options like when i say windows i mean a
window of past three events window of
past three events each event being of
five seconds so your batches of smaller
data is processed by spark engine and
this process data can then be stored or
can be used for further processing so
that's what spark streaming does when
you talk about mlib it's a low-level
machine learning library that is simple
to use scalable and compatible with
various programming languages now hadoop
also has some libraries like you have
apache mahout which can be used for
machine learning algorithms however in
terms of spark we are talking about
machine learning algorithms which can be
built using ml labs libraries and then
spark can be used for processing so ml
lib eases the deployment and development
of scalable machine learning algorithms
i mean think about your clustering
techniques
so think about your classification where
you would want to classify the data
where you would want to do supervised or
unsupervised learning think about
collaborative filtering and many other
data science related techniques or
techniques which are required to build
your recommendation engines or machine
learning algorithms can be built using
sparks mlip graphics is spark's own
graph computation engine so this is
mainly if you are interested in doing a
graph based processing think about
facebook think about linkedin where you
can have your data which can be stored
and that data
has some kind of network connections or
you could say it is well networked i
could say x is connected to y y is
connected to z z is connected to a so x
y z a all of these are in terms of graph
terminologies we call as vertices or
vertex which are basically being
connected and the connection between
these are called edges so i could say a
is friend to b so a and b are vertices
and friend a relation between them is
the edge now if i have my data which can
be represented in the form of graphs if
i would want to do a processing in such
way this could be not only for social
media it could be for your network
devices it could be a cloud platform it
could be about different applications
which are connected in a particular
environment so if you have data which
can be represented in the form of graph
then graphics can be used to do etl that
is extraction transformation load to do
your data analysis and also do
interactive graph computation so
graphics is quite powerful now when you
talk about spark your spark can work
with your different clustering
technologies so it can work with apache
mesos that's how spark came in where it
was initially to prove the credibility
of apache mesos spark can work with yarn
which is usually you will see in
different working environments spark can
also work as standalone that means
without hadoop spark can have its own
setup with master and worker processes
so usually or you can say technically
spark uses a master slave architecture
now that consists of a driver program
that can run on a master node it can
also run on a client node it depends on
how you have configured or what your
application is
and then you have multiple executors
which can run on worker nodes so your
master node has a driver program and
this driver program internally has the
spark context so your spark every spark
application will have a driver program
and that driver program has a inbuilt or
internally used spark context which is
basically your entry point of
application for any spark functionality
so your driver or your driver program
interacts with your cluster manager now
when i say interacts with cluster
manager so you have your spark context
which is the entry point that takes your
application request to the cluster
manager now as i said your cluster
manager could be say apache mesos it
could be yarn it could be spark
standalone master itself so your cluster
manager in terms of yarn is your
resource manager so your spark
application internally runs as series or
set of tasks and processes your driver
program wherever that is run will have a
spark context and spark context will
take care of your application execution
how does that do it spark context will
talk to cluster manager so your cluster
manager could be yan and in terms of
when i say cluster manager for yarn
would be resource manager so at high
level we can say a job is split into
multiple tasks and those tasks will be
distributed over the slave nodes or
worker nodes so whenever you do some
kind of transformation or you use a
method of spark context and rdd is
created and this
is distributed across multiple nodes as
i explained earlier worker nodes are the
slaves that run different tasks so this
is how a spark architecture looks like
now we can learn more about spark
architecture and its interaction with
yarn so usually what happens when your
spark context interacts with the cluster
manager so in terms of yarn i could say
resource manager now we already know
about yarn so you would have say node
managers running on multiple machines
and each machine has some ram and cpu
cores allocated for your node manager on
the same machine you have the data nodes
running which obviously are there to
have the hadoop related data so whenever
the application wants to process the
data your application via spark context
contacts the cluster managers that is
resource manager now what does resource
manager do resource manager makes a
request so resource manager makes
requests to the node manager of the
machines wherever the relevant data
resides asking for containers so your
resource manager is negotiating or
asking for containers from node manager
saying hey can i have a container of 1gb
ram and one cpu core can i have a
container of 1gb ram and 1 cpu core and
your node manager based on the kind of
processing it is doing will approve or
deny it so node manager would say fine i
can give you the container and once this
container is allocated or approved by
node manager resource manager will
basically start an extra piece of code
called appmaster so appmaster is
responsible for execution of your
applications whether those are spark
applications or mapreduce so your
application master which is a piece of
code will run in one of the containers
that is it will use the ram and cpu core
and then it will use the other
containers which were allocated by node
manager to run the tasks so it is within
this container which can take care of
execution so what is a container a
combination of ram and cpu core so it is
within this container we will have a
executable process which would run and
this executor process is taking care of
your application related tasks so that's
how overall spark works in integration
with yarn now let's learn about this
spark cluster managers as i said spark
can work in a standalone mode so that is
without hadoop so by default application
submitted to spark standalone mode
cluster will run in fifo order and each
application will try to use all the
available nodes so you could have a
spark standalone cluster which basically
means you could have multiple nodes on
one of the nodes you would have the
master process running and on the other
nodes you would have the spark worker
processes running so here we would not
have any distributed file system because
spark is standalone and it will rely on
an external storage to get the data or
probably the file system of the nodes
where the data is stored and processing
will happen across the nodes where your
worker processes are running you could
have spark working with apache mesos now
as i said apache massos is an open
source project to manage your computer
clusters and can also run hadoop
applications apache mesos was introduced
earlier and spark came in and as
existence to prove the credibility of
apache missiles you can have spark
working with hadoop's yarn this is
something which widely you will see in
different working environments so yarn
which takes care of your processing and
can take care of different processing
frameworks also supports spark you could
have kubernetes now that is something
which is making a lot of news in today's
world it is an open source system for
automating deployment scaling and
management of containerized applications
so where you could have multiple docker
based images which can be connecting to
each other so spark also works with
kubernetes now let's look at some
applications of spark so jp morgan chase
and company uses spark to detect
fraudulent transactions analyze the
business spends of an individual to
suggest offers and identify patterns to
decide how much to invest and where to
invest so this this is one of the
examples of banking a lot of banking
environments are using spark due to its
real-time processing capabilities and
in-memory faster processing where they
could be working on fraud detection or
credit analysis or pattern
identification and many other use cases
alibaba group that uses also spark to
analyze large data sets of data such as
real-time transaction details now that
might be based online or in the stores
of looking at the browsing history in
the form of spark jobs and then provides
recommendations to its users so alibaba
group is using spark in its e-commerce
domain you have iq via now this is a
leading healthcare company that uses
spark to analyze patients data identify
possible health issues and diagnose it
based on their medical history so there
is a lot of work happening in healthcare
industry where real time processing is
finding a lot of importance and real
time and faster processing is what is
required so healthcare industry and iqvi
is also using spark you have netflix
which is known and you have riot games
so entertainment and gaming companies
like netflix and ride games use apache
spark to showcase relevant
advertisements to their users based on
the videos that they have watched shared
or liked so these are few domains which
find use cases of spark that is banking
e-commerce health care entertainment and
then there are many more which are using
spark in their day-to-day activities for
real time in memory faster processing
now let's discuss about the sparks use
case and let's talk about conviva which
is world's leading video streaming
companies so video streaming is a
challenge now if you talk about youtube
which has data you could always read
about it so youtube has data which is
worth watching 10 years so that is huge
amount of data where people are
uploading their videos or companies are
doing advertisements and this
videos
are streamed in or can be watched by
users so video streaming is a challenge
and especially with increasing demand
for high quality streaming experiences
conviva collects data about video
streaming quality to give their
customers visibility into the end user
experience they are delivering now how
do they do it apache spark again using
apache spark conviva delivers a better
quality of service to its customers by
removing the screen buffering and
learning in detail about network
conditions in real time this information
is then stored in the video player to
manage live video traffic coming in from
4 billion video feeds every month to
ensure maximum retention now using
apache spark conviva has created an auto
diagnostics alert it automatically
detects anomalies along the video
streaming pipeline and diagnoses the
root cause of the issue now this really
makes it one of the leading video
streaming companies based on auto
diagnostic alerts it reduces waiting
time before the video starts it avoids
buffering and recovers the video from a
technical error and the whole goal is to
maximize the viewer engagement so this
is sparks use case where conviva is
using spark in different ways to stay
ahead in video streaming related
deliveries if we have understood and
learned about your spark components your
spark architecture we can also see
running a spark application now a spark
application can run in a standalone mode
that is you could set up your ide such
as eclipse with a scala plug-in and then
you could have your coded application
which is written in eclipse to be run in
local mode now here i have an example of
application which can be run in a local
mode or on a cluster so this application
is importing some packages that is spark
context spark conf i have created an
object which is first app it is the main
class of your project and other classes
can just be extending app rather than
having main here we declare a variable
called x which is pointing to a file in
my project directory it looks for a file
which is
abc1.txt and this file basically has
some content what are we doing in the
application so we create a variable
where we assign the file then we define
or initialize our spark context so
remember whenever you work with ide you
don't have spark context or spark
available implicitly that has to be
defined so here we create a
configuration object we set our
application name we set the master as
local if you want to run it in a local
mode if you want to run it say on your
windows machine or if you would want to
run on a spark standalone cluster if i
would be running it on yarn then i would
remove this property that is set master
now once you have defined your
configuration object you can be
basically using spark context you can
use method of it which will result in
rtt that is what is happening in line 13
val y and then finally i can create a
variable where i would want to do a flat
map transformation on y which would
result in an internal rdd followed by a
map transformation which would again
result in an rdd and finally reduce by
key which is doing an aggregation once
all these steps are done i can decide to
display the result on the screen or i
can even use save as text file point it
to a particular location and then have
my application run now this is my
eclipse refer to other sessions where i
have explained how you can set up ide on
windows with different environment
variables and then you can run your
applications on a particular cluster if
i would want to run this application on
a cluster then i will have to give a
particular path so here in this case i
can say let's do this and i will say my
file is
abc1.txt let's save it and i'll also say
my output will be getting stored in a
default location as i intend to run it i
intend to run this application on a
cluster now in that case the cluster
would usually be set up on linux
machines would have a hadoop cluster
where you can run this application so if
i would want to run this application on
a cluster but not locally on the machine
i can just delete this part i can keep
my application now if you see my
application already compiles and does
not show any error message and that is
because in my project's build path i
have added all the spark related jars
all the spark related jars you can get
from your spark directory or you can be
getting in manually all the dependencies
some people would prefer to use meven or
say sbt for packaging your application
as jar and that can also be done so here
my code compiles code is fine it is
pointing to a file and then it is also
creating an output which will have word
count now what i can do is since i have
my code already written i know that i
have sbt installed on this machine
because i would want to package this
code as jar and run it on a cluster so
for that we can look in
our command prompt and here i can go
into workspace i can go into my scholar
project and if you see here we have your
build.sbt file you have your binaries
and you have your source so you might
not have these spark related directories
now these exist in my case because i
have been using spark and i've done some
previous runs now this is what we have
within my spark apps so to build my
package i need a build dot sbt file we
can see what does that contain so your
build.sbt contains your name version of
your package jar scala version spark
version and then repository which spark
will refer to when it wants to have the
dependencies for all of your components
such as sparkcore spark sql mnlab and so
on so this is my build.spd file which
exists in the project folder and if you
are intending to use sbt to package your
code as jar and then run it on the
cluster in that case i can even skip
adding spark related charge to the build
path so that is only done to make sure
that your code compiles now once i have
my code written i have sbt installed i
have made the file path changes i can
just go to the command line within my
project folder and i can say sbt package
now this will basically resolve all the
dependencies based on whatever you have
given in the code it will create a jar
file and place it in a particular
location and then we can use the same
jar file to run on a particular cluster
so sbt package is busy in creating the
jar now meanwhile what i can do is i can
open up a lab content and what i can do
is
i can just say for example
simply learn
and here i already have a lab setup so
you could have your own spark standalone
cluster where you could also run this
jar file you could have spark with
hadoop which is what i have here and i
will use that to submit an application
on the yarn cluster and let's go to the
web console let me copy my link i'll
close this i'll say launch lab and then
i can log in here i can just do paste my
password and i'm logged in so i can just
say spark 2 shell now that's how it has
been configured here to work with your
spark version 2. so this is an
interactive way of bringing your spark
shell and running your application but
what we are interested in is running the
application as a jar file so let's go
and see here where we have our code and
let's see if svd has done the packaging
yes it has done and it has created a jar
file in this location so what i can do
is i need to get this jar file from this
location onto my cluster so what i can
do is i can come in here i can do a ftp
so this basically allows me to push
whatever jars i have on my web console
so i'll go in here i'll say connect now
i'll search if there is already existing
jar file which might create a conflict
so i have something here
so i can for now just delete it it's
done i will say upload file and i am
interested in getting the jar file so
here we can
click on users win 10 i have my
workspace project i can get into target
scala 2.11 and take my jar file and say
open so this will upload my jar file on
the web console or the terminal wherein
i can connect to my cluster now let's go
in here let's quit from spark shell as
we want to run an application on the
cluster how do i do it so i can search
if i have my jar file existing it's here
so i'll say spark to submit and then i
will point to my jar file and then i can
simply say class and i know my code has
a package and a class name so this is
package and this is my object or class
name so i can say main dot scala dot
first app now it will be good if we
check if the file exists which our code
points to so i'll just for now comment
it out i will check in my sdfs ls in my
default user directory this is where it
will search for a file and here we can
search if i have a file called abc so i
don't see anything here so let's do this
what i can do is i can again go to ftp
and basically i can do a upload file
like what we did earlier and this time
i'll pick up this existing abc1 file
which i showed you and uploaded once
this is done i can put it on my cluster
by just saying sdfs dfs put let's take
the abc1 file and let's put it in my
directory so this will be my input so
i'm putting in a file there and now i
can do a spark submit to submit the
application on the cluster so if you see
here it has basically started the
application it contacts the resource
manager it gets an application id and
now it is doing the processing of my
file where i would want to get once this
is done it will be completed and the
temporary directory will be deleted so
this is how i run a spark application on
a cluster now once this is done i can
also go to spark's history server by
saying this is the path for my spark
history server it shows an application
which was run today which was doing a
word count you can click on the
application it says it ended with save
as text file you can click on this and
then it shows you the dag visualization
it says we started with text file we did
a flat map we did a map and then there
was some shuffling because we wanted to
do reduce by key so as i said every rdd
by default has two partitions and if you
want to do some aggregate or wider
transformations like reduce by key sort
by key group by key count by key and so
on in that case
similar key related data has to be
shuffled and brought into one partition
that's where we see shuffling happening
here and it also tells what are the
number of tasks which have run per
partition so here we ran a spark
application by packaging it as jar using
your sbt so sbt created the jar file and
then basically we brought our jar file
onto the cluster and then submitted it
using spark submit so this is how a
spark application runs on the cluster so
as i said your application has a driver
program now your spark applications run
as independent processes and they can
run on a cluster across the nodes so we
just saw how we can run a spark
application on a cluster now we can
always look at spark applications
progress or after it has completed by
looking into the spark ui your spark
application as i mentioned has a driver
program and when you run your
application on the
cluster you can always specify where
would you want your driver program to
run so in our case when we ran our spark
application here we basically just did a
simple spark submit and we gave our jar
and the class name i could also say
master and then i could specify if i
would want my application to run in a
local mode or i could say yarn but that
is default or if it was a spark
standalone cluster then i could be
giving something like this your host
name and then your port so you could do
all of these options by specifying minus
minus master i could also specify how
many executors i need how much memory
per executor how much course per
executor i need
and i could also say deploy mode as
client which basically means my driver
will run on this machine however my
execution of application will happen on
cluster nodes i can also say deploy mode
as cluster which basically means my
driver will run on one of the nodes of
the cluster you could submit your
application and then based on whatever
arguments you have given your
application will be submitted on the
cluster and it will run so you can have
your application running so as i said
you have an application which has a
driver and it also has either spark
session or spark context which takes
your application request to the resource
manager now if your application is
completed you can always come back and
look into the spark history server or
spark ui if i choose this as my
application which i have run i can go to
executors and that shows me that there
was one for your driver now that was
running on this particular node which is
my client node then i have my executors
on my other nodes which are nodes of my
cluster which used one core which ran
two tasks for the partitions which they
were working on and there was some
shuffling involved as we were doing a
word count which uses reduce by key so
when you run your application your yarn
or your cluster manager such as resource
manager negotiates the resources to the
slave processes your worker node
basically will have the resources
available for any kind of execution now
as i said your resource manager will
request for containers your worker nodes
will approve those containers and then
within those containers you will have
the executor which will run which will
take care of the task to process the
data so what is a task it is a unit of
work for the data set which has to be
worked upon so your rdds which get
created have partitions and for every
partition you have a task which is taken
care by the executor so the data is
loaded into the rdd when the action is
invoked and then your task is worked
upon by the executor so what does it do
it basically gets the data into the
partition of rdd and then does the
execution as a task on that particular
partition results are then sent back to
the driver and you can also have your
output saved on the disk so this is how
your application run whenever you run a
particular application you can always go
to your web console and scroll or look
into the logs for more information so
here our application was run and we can
see right from the beginning here when
we talk about spark submit which is done
here it says running spark version 2.2
it basically then will see that there
will be a driver which will be started
you can further see that it does some
memory calculations it then starts a
spark ui and here we can see that
requesting a new application from
cluster with four node managers verify
our application has not requested more
than maximum memory capability of the
cluster so the container sizing at the
cluster level is 3 gb per container and
your application should not be
requesting for a container bigger than
that it starts a application master
container with specific amount of memory
and then finally your execution starts
if we scroll down and look into the logs
we will see where my driver runs it will
also see show you how much memory was
utilized and it will talk about back
scheduler which is taking care of
execution of your tag that is series of
your rdds and finally you will see the
result getting generated or saved so
this is how you run your spark
application this is how you can see your
spark applications in history server or
spark ui and this is how overall apache
spark works utilizing your cluster
manager help getting the resources from
the worker processes and then running
the executors within those here we will
learn on what is spark streaming spark
streaming data sources
features of spark streaming working of
spark streaming disk criticized streams
caching or persistence as we call check
pointing in spark streaming and we will
then have a demo on spark streaming so
let's learn on what is spark streaming
and what it is capable of so it's an
extension of core spark api that
basically enables scalable high
throughput fault tolerant stream
processing of live data streams now data
can be ingested from different sources
like kafka flume kinases or tcp sockets
and then it can be processed using
complex algorithms expressed with
different kind of functions such as map
reduce join in window and when we have
the data processed that data can be
pushed out to your file systems
databases and live dashboards so if you
look on this image we can clearly see
that we would be working on a input data
stream which goes into spark streaming
component of spark which gives us
batches of input data or you could say
the streaming data is broken down into
smaller patches which would then be
worked upon by spark core engine and you
have finally batches of processed data
now when we talk about spark streaming
and the data sources you could have
streaming data sources coming in from
kafka or flume or say twitter api or
also with different formats such as
parquet you could also have static data
sources coming in from mongodb hbase
mysql and postgres
so when we talk about spark streaming it
receives the input data streams divides
the data into patches which can then be
processed by spark engine to generate
your final stream of results again in
batches so your spark streaming actually
provides a high level abstraction called
disk criticize stream and we will learn
about that or what we call as d stream
which represents a continuous stream of
data now when we look at your different
data sources from where the data can
come in spark streaming would take in
this input and then you could have even
your mlib component which could be used
that is sparks component to build
machine learning algorithms wherein you
can train your models with live data and
you can even use your trained model you
could be also going for structured
processing or processing the data which
is structuralized and that could be done
by using sparks components that is spark
sql which has data frames and data sets
so you could process your data with data
frames interactively query with sql when
spark streaming is working on the data
which is constantly flowing in finally
the data which is processed can be
stored in your distributed file system
such as sdfs or any other nosql or sql
based database now when we talk about
spark streaming it is good to know some
of the features of spark streaming and
here you have some of the features so it
enables fast recovery from failures
while it is working on streaming data
you have better load balancing and
resource usage and you can also combine
the streaming data with static data sets
and perform interactive queries now your
spark streaming also supports native
integration with advanced processing
libraries and that is one of the
benefits users can have when they are
using spark streaming let's learn about
working of spark streaming so as i
mentioned earlier at one end you have
your data streams now those data streams
are then caught or received by your
receivers which we have to enable in our
application your data streams or
streaming data which is constantly
getting generated and flowing in is
broken down into smaller patches which
will then be processed by spark so you
would have your final processed results
now if we look at the bigger picture
here we will talk about live input data
streams that could be divided into
smaller batches and when we say batches
these are batches of input data as rdds
so spark streaming performs computation
expressed using these streams it
generates rdd transformations so you
would have your spark pad jobs to
execute rdd transformations which would
give you your final processed result now
there are various examples and we'll
look at examples later so once your
spark streaming works on breaking the
input into smaller streams it can then
process the data finally giving you
batches of your result and that is again
on the streaming data now what is these
d streams let's understand about these
streams or disk criticized streams so
that's the basic abstraction provided by
spark streaming now it represents a
continuous stream of data either the
input data stream received from the
source or the process data stream
generated by transforming the input
stream now here if we look at the d
stream we would say you would have
series of rdds or series of
transformations applied on the data
which is flowing in for a particular
time frame now here we say data from
time 0 to 1 and that would result in
some of the transformations which you
would perform on the data when it has
come in between this time zone or time
frame you would have again data from
time 1 to 2 and so on so that's how your
spark streaming works so if we look at
your different transformations now there
could be various transformations which
could be applied on your data so this is
something like your streaming data which
comes in you would want to say have a
receiver which monitors a particular
socket or a particular port and looks
for data coming in we would also define
the time interval and for that time
interval the data is taken so that's a
smaller batch or a d stream on which you
could have your processing done now
within your application you would have
series of steps which are nothing but
transformations which would be performed
on this data within this time frame
giving you a result which could be
stored which could be seen on your
console or which could just be pushed
further for processing and this keeps
happening at regular time intervals
whatever you have specified till the
spark streaming application continues
now when we talk about spark we already
know that there are different kind of
transformations which can be applied so
you have map transformation wherein you
have map and then you pass in a function
which basically says you would want to
perform a function on every element so
when we say map function that would
return a new d stream by passing each
element of the source d stream through a
function which is passed similarly it is
for flat map where you would be passing
in a function you would want to perform
a flat map transformation on the data
stream or t stream which comes in so
each input item can be mapped to zero or
more output elements
you could be doing a filter wherein you
return a d stream by selecting only the
records of the source d stream on which
the function returns true so filtering
is used when you want to run a
transformation where you would want to
look at the input data for a particular
time interval as i mentioned earlier and
you would want to filter that data as
per whatever your function is applied
now you could be doing a union where you
could basically be having a union of
multiple d streams so that this would
return a new d stream that contains
union of elements in the source tree
stream and a other d string you could be
doing a transform function that contains
the union of elements you could be doing
a count you could be doing a join so
these are some of the transformations
which can be performed on your d streams
now there is also a concept of windowing
and that is basically to process the
data for a series of time intervals so
when i mention windowed stream
processing i'm saying spark streaming
would allow you to apply transformations
over a sliding window of data now this
operation is called as windowed
computation let's see how it looks like
so if you have your original d stream
which is b which is basically your data
coming in now that would be looked upon
for specific time intervals such as time
one time two and then you could be doing
a windowed computation which could
basically mean that i could have a
window which is a series of these time
intervals on which you would want to
perform series of your rdd
transformations so you have a window d
stream at time 1 then at time two and
time three so that could be one window
wherein you would want to get an output
so here we see window at time three now
you could also have a another sliding
window which would take your time series
and we have time 3 time 4 and time 5
where you could be performing the series
of transformations so this is usually
helpful where you would not only want to
process the data at particular time
interval but you would want a
consolidated processing for series of
intervals and that's what we mean by
windowed computation now before we
understand about caching and persistence
we can talk a little bit more on
windowing so if one would want to
understand the window stream processing
or as we say spark streaming's feature
of windowed computations we need to
think it as applying transformations
over a sliding window of data now as we
see here every time the window slides
over a source d stream the source rdds
that fall within the window are combined
and operated upon to produce the rdds of
windowed stream now in this specific
case we can say the operation is applied
over last three time units of data and
slides by two time units this shows that
any window operation needs to specify
two parameters one is the window length
which is basically the duration of
window so for example we can say 3 as we
see in the figure here and then you have
a sliding interval which is basically
the interval at which window operation
is performed so these two parameters
must be multiples of the batch interval
of source d stream so that's what we do
when we talk about window now there are
various other transformations which can
be applied or window based operations
which can be done on your d streams here
to talk a little bit more on these
streams which is as i said it's a basic
abstraction provided by spark streaming
it represents a just remember it has a
continuous stream of data now either the
input data stream received from source
or the process data stream which is
generated by transforming the input
stream so a d stream is represented by
you could say a continuous series of
rdds which is sparks abstraction of a
immutable distributed data set so any
operation applied on a d stream it is
basically translating to operations on
the underlying rdds now for example we
can say converting a stream of lines to
word the flat map operation is applied
on each rdd in the lines now d stream to
generate the rtd's of your words t
stream so when we talk about your
discretized streams understand that you
would have a series of transformations
which would be applied for this time
interval whatever has been specified now
when you talk about your streaming or
spark streaming architecture as i
mentioned here that is your receivers
now that plays a very important role
here so your input d streams or data
streams are representing the stream of
input data that is received from your
streaming sources now we could have
different kind of data and we could be
doing different kind of transformations
so your receiver is basically an object
which receives the data from a source
and stores it in sparks memory for
processing and that's the main role of
your receiver now spark streaming
provides two categories of building
streaming sources so you have basic
sources that is sources directly
available in streaming context which is
a class we learn about it such as your
file systems or socket connections so
those could be your basic sources from
where the data is coming in you could
have advanced sources like your kafka
flume kinases etc and they would be
available through extra utility classes
so your receiver is going to be looking
into the data which is constantly
getting generated and then basically
forwarding it for processing by your
spark streaming you know when we talk
about your spark streaming one more
important aspect is basically
understanding the caching and
persistence now as we know from the spar
core engine or as you should know that
rdds are say your logical steps or rdds
are created when you perform some
transformations and these
transformations or these computations or
these rdds can be cached so that it can
improve the performance of your
application so the computed rdds or the
rdds which are result of some performing
some transformations they can be cached
so that they can be reutilized down your
application for your further processing
so when we talk about your caching and
persistence these streams also allows
developers to persist the stream data in
memory so similar to your concept of
rdds these streams can allow you to
persist the particular streams data in
memory now that is by doing or using
your persist method on a d stream which
will automatically persist every rdd of
that d stream in memory it could be
every rdd or it could be specifically
chosen rdds now this is really useful if
the data in d stream has to be or would
be computed multiple times say in your
application so for example if we say
window based operations like reduce by
window reduce by key and window wherein
you have
group of operations being done or you
could have state based operations like
update state by key now in any of these
cases your d streams generated by say
window based operations are
automatically persistent in memory
without the developer calling for the
persist method now for input streams
that receive data over networks such as
kafka flume sockets etc the default
persistence level is set to replicate
the data to two nodes for fault
tolerance now one thing which we should
remember is unlike your rdds the default
persistence level of d streams keeps the
data data serialized in memory and that
we can discuss again further about your
serializations or deserialization now
one important aspect which takes care of
your fault recovery is check pointing
mechanism in spark streaming now when i
say check pointing a streaming
application as uh in real scenario we
would want must operate 24 bar 7 and if
the streaming application is constantly
running then there has to be a mechanism
which can make your streaming
application resilient to failures which
can be unrelated to your application
logic so spark streaming needs to do the
check pointing it needs to check point
enough information to a fault tolerant
underlying storage system such that it
can recover from failures so your check
pointing is the process to make
streaming applications more fault
tolerant or resilient to your failures
now this is usually used when you would
want to recover from failure of a node
running the driver of streaming
application now we know driver is
existing for every application and it is
basically one which knows the flow of
your application driver also has the
context in case of streaming application
we would have say the spark streaming
context which is the entry point of your
application now when we talk about your
check pointing to ensure your streaming
application is more fault tolerant you
have two kinds of checkpointing here so
you could have a metadata checkpointing
and you could have data checkpointing
now when we talk about metadata what
does that include so metadata includes
configuration d stream operations or
even incomplete batches so when we talk
about metadata it has configurations
configuration that was used to create
the streaming application you could have
d stream operations that is set of d
stream operations that define the
streaming application that is your
series of rdds and then you have
incomplete batches or batches whose jobs
are queued but not have completed so
this would have to be check pointed so
metadata check pointing is used for
recovering from a node failure running
the streaming application driver now
your metadata which has your
configuration incomplete batches and d
stream operations need to be saved in an
underlying storage system now when you
talk about data check pointing it is
mainly about saving the generated rtds
to reliable storage that is whatever
rdds are computed so saving the
information which is saving the
computations to a storage like sdfs now
that is used in stateful transformations
combining data across various batches so
when we talk about transformations
whatever rtds are generated that depend
on rdds of previous batches if we are
talking about stateful and that can
cause the length of dependency chain to
increase or keep increasing with time
now to avoid any kind of increase in the
recovery time intermediate rdds can be
periodically check pointed and that
could be done to a reliable storage to
basically cut off the growing dependency
changes so if we would want to summarize
we would say metadata check pointing is
primarily needed for recovery from
driver failures whereas data or rtd
checkpointing is necessary even for
basic functioning if stateful
transformations are used and we should
remember we are talking about stateful
transformations here so when we talk
about checkpointing now the question is
when would you enable checkpointing or
what would you do to enable
checkpointing so checkpointing must be
enabled for applications with different
kind of requirements so for example if
you are using stateful transformations
where one series of rdds depend on the
result of your previous patches so
something like update state by key or
reduce by key in window now if these
kind of operations are used in your
application then checkpoint directory
must be provided to allow for periodic
rdd checkpoint when we say about
requirements then recovering from
failures of the driver which is taking
care of your application metadata
checkpoints should be used when we talk
about simple streaming applications
without the stateful transformations
they could be run without enabling
checkpointing because your one batch of
rdds really does not depend on the
previous set of rdds which were done in
the previous time frame now recovery
from driver failures will also be
partial in that case when you talk about
your stateless so some might be received
and your unprocessed data might be lost
but then that's pretty much acceptable
when you talk about spark streaming
applications so here we look at your
checkpointing so we say start now you
have a checkpointing now whenever your
application is creating a streaming
context it would create it would set a
checkpoint path and then you would
define your d stream which is nothing
but series of your rdd transformations
your streaming context starts which is
basically your application entry point
into the cluster for processing and at
any point of time if there is any
failure you could always recover using
the checkpoint which was created in case
of
spark streaming one more thing we need
to remember is that your check pointing
can be enabled by setting it directly in
a fault tolerant reliable file system
such as sdfs wherein the checkpointing
information will be saved so we will
have to add
some methods within your application
like streaming context with a checkpoint
and then pointing it to a checkpoint
directory and in that way we can have
our stateful transformations or metadata
information stored in the underlying
storage whichever we have chosen now
that we have discussed about spark
streaming some basics of spark streaming
let's also understand about shared
variables or what we call as accumulator
and broadcast variables so normally when
you talk about your spark operations
such as your map or reduce these are
executed on one of the node of your
cluster and what happens is when you
talk about your operations they work on
separate copies of all variables used in
the function now in this case variables
are copied to each machine and no
updates to the variables on remote
machines are propagated back to the
driver program now when we talk about
read write shared variables across tasks
that would be inefficient so spark
actually provides two limited types of
shared variables for common usage
patterns and those are your broadcast
variables and your accumulators now when
you talk about your accumulators these
are variables that are only added
through an associative or commutative
operation so spark natively supports
accumulators of numeric types and
programmers can add support for your new
types so when we talk about accumulators
they can be used to implement counters
such as your mapreduce or sums so as a
user you can create named or unnamed
accumulators now as we see in the image
here a named accumulator in this
instance counter will display in web ui
for the stage that modifies that
accumulator spark displays the value for
each accumulator modified by a task in
the tasks table now tracking
accumulators in the ui can be useful for
understanding the progress of your
running stages but we should remember
that as of now this is not supported in
python might be in future the support
for python will also be added now when
you talk about your accumulators you can
have say a numeric accumulator created
by calling a spark context and its
method such as long accumulator or you
could have double accumulator to
accumulate values of type long or double
respectively so tasks running on a
cluster can then add to it using the add
method now we cannot i mean in this case
the value cannot be read but driver
program can read the accumulator's value
using its value method we can look at
some examples to understand this later
now when you talk about your broadcast
variables that is one more type of
variables which allows the programmers
to keep a read-only variable cached on
each machine rather than shipping a copy
of it with tasks now what we know is
sometimes you might be doing very
costlier operations like joins where you
might be working on multiple rdds they
need to be joined and these rtds could
also be pair rdds which could be key
value pairs now whenever you are
performing a join there would be kind of
two level of shuffling one within a
particular rdd so if you are joining two
rdds the first rdd which might have data
in the form of key value pairs that rdd
would have to have some shuffling where
all the similar keys can be brought into
one partition and this would happen on
the second rdd also which has again key
value pairs and then if you're doing a
join these rtds will be shipped to the
node or basically the data would be
loaded in the memory and then basically
your transformations will happen this
can be a costlier affair so what can be
done is you could create broadcast
variables so for example if we have two
rdds and we want to perform a join
operation and if one rdd is known to be
smaller then we can create a broadcast
variable of the smaller rdd so that this
variable itself can be shipped to each
machine and then this variable can be
used for your join operations with the
other rdd which is existing in the
memory of those nodes so that saves time
and that improves your performance so
spark basically attempts to distribute
the broadcast variable using efficient
broadcast algorithms to reduce the
communication cost now if for example
you have multiple nodes in a cluster and
if you would want to give every node a
copy of large input data set in an
efficient manner so spark actions are
executed through a set of stages now we
know that and stages are separated by
your shuffle operations so whenever we
talk about narrow dependencies such as
map flat map filter you would not have
any shuffling involved but if you go for
group by key reduce by key and such
operations to bring the similar keys
together there would be shuffling
involved and also this applies when you
are doing some join operations so in
that case broadcast variables could be a
really plus where one set of data or rdd
which is already computed that could be
broadcasted to other nodes so the data
broadcasted will be cached in serialized
form and deserialized before running
each task this means that explicitly
creating broadcast variables can be
useful when tasks across multiple stages
need the same data or when caching the
data in deserialized form is important
so we can create broadcast variables
using spark context and its method
called broadcast and your broadcast
variable can then be shipped to other
nodes which can be used for your other
operations now when you talk about smart
streaming it is used in various use
cases i mean you could talk about speech
recognition you could talk about
sentiment analysis you could talk about
a streaming applications which would be
performing some kind of
analytics on the data which is coming in
it is also used widely in retail chain
companies now if you look at the example
here so big retail chain companies would
want to build real-time dashboards so
that they can keep a track of their
inventory and operations and for this
they would need one streaming data or
data which is constantly getting
generated at source which needs to be
processed on and this information can
then be populating your dashboards to
give you a real-time scenario or
real-time information of what is
happening so in case of an inventory
dashboard you could use then these
interactive dashboards uh wherein you
could draw insights about the business
and that's what retail companies are
doing so how many products are being
purchased or products that have been
shipped or how many products have been
delivered to customers and this kind of
information would be good to capture in
real time so when the streaming data is
basically being processed so at one end
you have your data which is getting
generated that might be based on the
sales which are happening that might be
based on the products which are being
shipped or that might be based on the
acknowledgement that the products have
been received now while this data is
getting generated at various sources it
can be subjected to a smart streaming
application which will look into the
streaming data perform series of
transformations which you would want to
process the data at regular time
intervals and then pushing it to your
dashboards or to your storage layer
wherein it could then be used to answer
such questions so when we talk about
spark streaming it's an ideal choice to
process this kind of data in real time
and there are various use cases so at
one end if you see you have a input
stream which shows the product status
that is how many products were purchased
or shipped or delivered now this would
be then handled by your spark streaming
and also your spar core engine which
would then process the data to give you
an output stream which gives you a
status
such as what was the total count of
products which are purchased products
which were shipped and products which
were delivered so this was a quick and
brief introduction to spark streaming
and how it works now we can also see how
spark streaming works or how we create
an application for that what we can do
is we can basically set up our eclipse
to have your scala based spark
applications and for that what you could
do is you could have your eclipse which
can then be having a scala plug-in added
to it now if somebody would want to look
at the scala plugin then you can always
go to scala.ibe.org
and this is the place where you can
scroll towards the bottom you can click
on stable and that basically also shows
your video how scala plugin can be added
to your eclipse it also tells from where
you can get the scala latest release and
this can be added to your eclipse so in
my case it has already been added to the
eclipse i'm bringing it up here and then
you can have your applications built
using your ide people would prefer to
use intellij and that's also fine so you
could also look for videos on setting up
intellij with your scala plug-in now
there are two ways
one you can build your application run
it on your windows machine when you
could have some kind of utility like
netcat which can be used to send in some
messages in a streaming fashion you
could have a receiver which looks at a
particular socket at a particular port
and you could build a streaming
application within your ide run it on
your windows machine in a local mode
which would then be looking at your
source where the data is getting
generated that's one option the second
option is you could build your
application package it as jar and then
run it on a cluster now that could be a
spark standalone cluster or spark with
yarn and then you could be packaging
your application using tools like sbt
and then use spark submit to submit your
application now i'll show you both the
ways in which you can work with
streaming applications so first is get
your eclipse and make sure that scala
plugin is already added now in my case
on the right top corner i see scala
symbol that says i can be using scholar
perspective now here i have some
projects so what you can do is you can
create a project by saying new scala
project you can give it a name so for
example i could say my apps3 and then
you can say finish so that creates a
project now within your project what you
can do is you can create a package so
for example i could say something like
main dot scala and then say finish so
that creates your package now also one
thing to remember is it would be good to
change your compiler instead of 2.12 to
2.11 normally for different environments
you might have spark with different
versions and scala with two point turner
2.11 so it would be good to have the
compiler change to the bundle 2.11 so we
can select this project i can do a right
click i can go to the build path i can
say configure build path and then i can
click on scala compiler where i will use
project settings and i will choose to
2.11 bundle so that would make sure that
your applications can compile just say
ok it might say the compiler settings
have changed a full rebuild is required
for changes to take effect just hit on
ok so that's the first thing you need to
do the second thing is for your code to
compile it would be good to have your
jars added to your build path now we
could do that or as i said you could be
writing your application which might not
compile within your ide but you could
package it using sbt and then run it as
jar so what i'm doing here is on my
machine within my c drive i already have
spark distribution which i've downloaded
so basically i have downloaded spark and
then untied it so spark 2.4.3 i have
unzipped or untied it i have kept it in
my c and this basically has my spark now
within which i have my jars and this has
all my spark related jars so technically
speaking i can even use windows command
line and i can start working on spark in
an interactive way or packaging my
application and running it in a local
mode so you could also do this so
basically have your spark and then if
you see on my desktop i have a hadoop
folder within which i have a bin folder
and within which i have a win utils.exe
and this will be basically required when
you want to try out your spark based
applications whether that is streaming
or data frames to be tested on your
windows machine so you can always search
and download the winutils.exe
place it in a hadoop folder within the
bin folder on your machine so once you
get your
once you have your charts what you can
do is for your project you can just say
right click you can go to the build path
and you can say configure build path and
here you had add external jars so we can
select all of these jars here which i
would want to add to my build path so
that my code can compile and i can test
it on the windows machine itself i can
say open and then just basically do
apply and okay so that has created my
project with a package my compiler has
changed to 2.11 i have added the
external chars the spark related jars
and that is good enough for my code now
what we need is a streaming application
which we need to build so let me show
you from my existing project how it
looks like so within your source the
same way i have main package and here i
have a streaming application so this
streaming application is to test or to
work on capturing the data which is
generated at this particular stream on a
particular ip and a particular port and
i would want to do some series of
transformations on that so this gives me
an example of doing a word count and
then i would want to print the results i
could also be saving the output in a
particular location so for this
application we need basically to import
certain packages that is say spark
streaming spark context and also you
have spark conf so these are the
packages which we need to import now
here i have created an object i have
called as fifth app and i'm saying
extends app and this is because within
my project i already have an application
which has been defined as main so if
your application has been defined as
main one application is already existing
then you can just have your new objects
with extending app so we don't need to
define the main method here now here i'm
saying val conf new spark conf so i'm
creating a configuration object i'm
setting my application name and to test
it on windows we will have to set the
master as local and it is advisable to
give it more than one thread because you
would be creating a receiver within your
application that would utilize one
thread so here i am saying set master
local and then i am saying two threads i
am also creating my spark context which
we need to initialize based on the
configuration object we just created in
the previous step then we need to create
a spark streaming context and this
streaming context depends on spark
context and i've given a time interval
of 10 seconds so this is the time
interval which i am setting for which i
would want to work on the stream of data
which comes in every 10 seconds on a
particular socket now here we are
setting up a receiver so i say stream
rdd which is basically be spark
streaming context and then you use your
socket text stream now there are various
methods of spark streaming context for
example if i just go here and if i just
do a dot it shows me what are the
different options you have file stream
you have q stream you have socket stream
receiver stream and so on so i am using
socket text stream and i would want to
point it to this machine so i will say
127.0.0.1
i will also specify port 2222 okay and
here once i have created my
configuration object my spark context my
spark streaming context with the time
interval and i have set my receiver to
use the socket text stream method on
this particular ip on this particular
port now then i am specifying what i
would want to do on the data which gets
generated on this machine at this
particular port so i am saying val word
counts so i would want to work on the
stream rtd that is the d stream i would
want to do a flat map on it to split the
data based on space i would want to map
every word to word comma 1 and then i
would want to do a reduce by key now
reduce by key you can pass in
specifically the function you would want
to do i could do a count of this i could
print the result or i could even save it
with an output using the java method to
create a random string attached to the
output once you're done with this here
i'm mentioning spark streaming context
start now this will basically trigger my
spark streaming context to start and it
will run till we terminate this
application now here to run this on
windows machine you can always look into
your run configuration and what i have
done is in my environment i basically
want to use
let's say okay now let's look at the
configuration what you need to set so
here i have
my streaming application and let's look
at the run configuration which basically
shows my application has started and
it's running on the environment so if
you see here i have added hadoop
underscore home pointing to this hadoop
directory which has been and when utils
x i have also given spark local ip which
is
127.0.0.1 so that is my run
configuration now if you see here my
streaming application has started my
streaming application has not yet
started probably it is running a
different application so we can come
back and check this so we can go to run
as scala application and let's see what
it does so it tries to connect to 127.
so receiver is trying to do that but it
does not find anything on that
particular machine on that particular
port so my receiver is not able to find
it is not able to establish a connection
now what i can do is i can go to my
command line and here i will go into
downloads so i have already downloaded
the netcat utility for windows and here
we can basically search for something
which i have on my machine within
downloads and that is your netcat
utility so what i would do is i will
come back here and i would say
nc.exe lvp and then i could say my port
which i have specified in my streaming
application and i can just start this
netcat utility now here it says
listening on 222 it says connection to
127.0.0.1
and then if i look in the background my
receiver will now be able to establish a
connection establish a connection with
this netcat utility now whatever i type
here will be taken for processing every
10 seconds and we would see a word count
while my application is running so let's
test this so i'll say this is a test
test
is
being done and as soon as i pass in this
message we see that there is a word
count happening for the stream of data
which is coming in we can say winters
are coming winters will be cold and once
i given these messages we will see our
streaming application which will try to
work on the data which is coming in and
process it and show us the result so we
can say this is a test
of winters and let's see if it continues
to do the processing and shows us doubt
right so my streaming application is
running fine it is looking at the words
which we are passing in and we can say
if it is able to process my data and
every 10 seconds the tech stock socket
stream is looking on this machine at
this particular port doing a series of
transformations and these series of
transformations and then are seen within
your console now in my application if i
had
used word counts dot save as text file
then i could also have my output getting
generated at every 10 second interval
and that would get saved here i could
also decide to have my output saved and
stored on a sdfs or any other storage so
this is a simple streaming application
what we saw which is using socket tech
stream it is looking at this machine on
a particular port where we are running a
netcat utility it does
series of your rdd transformations that
is flat map map and then you're reduced
by key and finally we are invoking an
action such as print which basically
triggers these rdds which work on my
streaming data so this is one example
now what i could also be doing is this
is particularly my application now i
already have sbt for windows installed
so i can be going into my project space
so i could say workspace
i could go into my apps and i'm in my
project folder so i could say sbt
package and this will basically then
based on my build file which i already
have within my project folder so if you
see here this is my build file which
says name the version scala version
spark version and the repository with
the spark to manage the dependencies for
all its components like sparkcore sqlml
streaming and hive so you need to have
this build dot sbt file within your
project folder which can be used to
package your application as jar now we
have done the packaging and it shows me
that it has created a jar of my
applications within this particular
folder now once i have this i can
basically then import this package into
my cluster where i can run it on a
cluster using spark submit now to run
the spark streaming application on a
cluster here i have a two node cluster
which will then have my spark standalone
cluster you could look at the previous
videos which wherein i explained how to
set up a spark standalone cluster now
here i can go into the spark directory
and then i could just say s bin start
all dot sh which will start by spark
master and worker node now i do have
hadoop cluster also set up on this but
right now i'm running a spark standalone
cluster which shows me i have a master
and worker process on this machine and i
have a worker process on this machine so
my spark standalone cluster is running
we can always bring up the ui to see how
it looks like so here i can just be
giving http
slash um1
0 so that's my spark standalone cluster
with two worker nodes right now there is
no application running we can come back
here and we can check if we have my jar
file so i've already placed my jar here
now at any point of time if you have
your jar which has been packaged you can
always go and do a jar minus xvf and you
can choose your jar to see what is
within your jar which i have already
done on this machine so if i look in the
main folder i have scala and within
scala if you see these are the different
classes what we have so my code was
packaged as a jar it has a fifth app
class which we would want to run here so
what i can do is i can just be saying
spark
submit because now i would want my
application to run on the cluster so i
can say class main dot scala and then my
object name so i will say fifth app now
that's my class my jar is this one and
we will also say master which is going
to be spark which is running on um one
and it listens on 7077 port so that
would basically start my streaming
application but what we would also need
is like our windows we would also need
some utility like netcat so basically
what i can do is i can here use a netcat
utility to basically connect or send in
some messages for our streaming
application so let's say let me search
if i have already the net cat which i
might have used here so let's see so we
on your window machine you will have to
install your netcat utility by saying a
apt-get netcat so here i can say nc
minus l and then i can say port which is
2 2 2 2 so we can see if this is working
so this is a test and let's see if it
works so let's start our application
streaming application which then needs
the receiver to establish a connection
with the particular machine and let's
see if that is done so here i could also
be canceling this and give it a
particular port so i can say 192 168
0.80 now the only problem is when we
packaged our application when we
packaged our application we should be
specifically giving the ip and also
comment out the local so when i package
this to run on the cluster i commented
out this part and i obviously would not
be giving 127 but the ip where my net
cat is running so right now let's test
it so we will say this
is a test new test for our application
and i'm sending in some messages so it
is already doing the word count as we
expected it to do and if while we are
doing it if you come back here so you
would see your application is now
running on the cluster so it is my
application it is using four cores what
is the memory per executor and you can
basically click on your application now
here you can look at the application
detail ui to see what is being done so
for our application we have streaming
job running receiver which says this is
my application it says it is running you
can basically click at this click on
this and it says your dag visualization
which will say the streaming job which
is running you can look at the stages if
you would want to see if there are
multiple stages which we don't have
because we are not doing any wider
transformation we can look at storage if
we have used some persisting or caching
we can look at the executors which are
being used and one of the important
things when you talk about your
streaming is the streaming tab which
gets activated now that does not show up
when you run your batch applications but
in your streaming applications you have
the ui shows you the streaming tab and
that basically says running batches of
10 seconds for 2 minutes 9 seconds
already now we see the input rate we see
the receivers we see if there is any
delay in scheduling what is the
processing time how many batches it has
completed and it basically shows me what
is the processing time how many tasks
were run and so on so my application is
running fine and unless and until we go
ahead and cancel this my application
will continue to run it will keep
looking for messages which we keep
typing in so for example if i would want
to just copy this and start again where
i would keep passing in this is say test
one test one is this where
we test streaming application right and
i can be seeing that my messages are
being processed i'm getting a word count
so we can say winter winter summer old
winter and you can always look at if
your streaming application is doing the
word count so this is a simple way where
you can run your streaming application
either on a windows machine in a local
mode or you could be running on a spark
standalone cluster or you could also
deploy your application to run on a yarn
based cluster now that we have seen a
streaming application which does a word
count it will be interesting to also see
the window based computation or
windowing operation which is supported
in spark streaming as i explained and
for that we can look at a different
application here which is streaming with
a window option let's look into this
what this application does so here i am
importing some packages that is
streaming streaming context your spark
in spark context spark configuration i'm
also using the spark api java function
and then using spark streaming api and
i'm also using storage level because i
also intend to have the persistence or
caching done now here we create an
application say streaming app extends
app we create our configuration object
where we say app name and then we set
master with appropriate number of
threads we create the spark streaming
context that's we initialize it and then
we have the spark streaming context
which depends on sc and we have given a
time interval of 10 seconds we then set
up a receiver so we say stream rdd which
will use socket text stream like we did
earlier with which will look for this
particular machine at this port wherein
i'm also using storage level so what i
would want is that the data stream which
would get generated here every 10
seconds should be cached in memory now
we could use different storage levels
that is we could use memory only disk
only memory and disk you could have
memory and disk with replication factor
so you have different storage levels now
here we are then doing some series of
transformations like what we did earlier
but if you see in my previous example we
just had reduce by key and here i am
using a transformation which is reduced
by key and window now this one basically
takes the function as i said the
windowing takes associative or
commutative functions so instead of
using the shortcut wave we will be
specifying our function so we say it
takes a and b and basically it uses this
function now here we have to give the
interval that is 30 seconds that's my
window time frame and then within that
what will be my each interval which we
would want to look at so these are the
two main aspects one is using your
window based transformation and then
also specifying your time interval for
your windowing which basically means we
would still do a word count but then
here we would basically not only be
doing a word count for every 10 seconds
for the data which is coming in here but
we would also want to have a
consolidated set of computation done
every 30 seconds so that is looking at
the last three time intervals now if you
also notice i am also doing a check
pointing here wherein i have not
specified a specific directory but what
i am saying here is i would want to
check point or i would want to basically
save my computations for any kind of
fault recovery now this is a streaming
application with window based
computation we are using storage level
for persistence we are also doing the
check pointing which takes care of fault
recovery now to run this application we
have already set our environment
variables and so on so i can basically
start this application by just doing a
run as scala application now this would
start my streaming application with
window based computations now we can
open up our command line where we would
want to start a netcat utility so i
could go to downloads let me just
minimize this window here and what i can
do is i can then be starting my netcat
utility so i could say
nc.exe minus lvp and on a port two two
two as soon as i do this in background
my application receiver will be able to
establish connection to this netcat
utility running on this particular port
now that's done so we can see if the
word count happens for our 10 second
interval so let's do that so i'll say
this is my first test and if i do this
it should give me the word count for the
data which i have passed in now i can
say this is my second test this
is my third test and if you see here it
basically is doing this now if i say
this is my first test again so since we
are doing window based operation also we
will see a consolidated set of
transformations which happen for a
window of three intervals so if you see
here now my this
is giving me a count but it is not
showing me totally this as 4 or say this
because it is only looking at a window
of last 2 or 3 time intervals so now it
is back because it is looking at the
last one so if i say this is my test
test is done test is done so if you do
this it will show you the word count
which is for whatever you have passed in
like test is done is twice test is
thrice but then since windowing based
operation is done you will look at the
time interval of the messages which were
passed within that particular window now
we can also since my application is
running and it is on windows we can
bring up your spark ui so i can go to
http and slash slash i can be looking at
my machine and the port so for example i
could do this this shows my streaming
application which is running in wherein
i can see the window based application
which is running but what would be
interesting is to look at the stages if
there is any kind of shuffling which is
happening looking at the storage should
show me the persistence which we are
doing now if you see here it shows me
that we have been persisting in the
memory what size it occupies how many
partitions were cached and this is
because of the persistence or the
storage level what we have used as
memory only now if we change that to
disk we will see our rdds will be cached
on disk and then you can look at your
streaming tab which gives you more
information about your patches so this
is a very simple example obviously you
can change what kind of rtd computations
you would want to do here whether you
want to do a word count or something
else whether you want to save your
processed output now here we are able to
do that you can always do a refresh on
your project and here what we see is we
see some entries of a folder getting
created right and we can decide whether
we would want our output to be created
we can also see within this what would
be containing and since we have set
checkpointing in the project folder it
would also be checkpointing temporarily
the information for any kind of failure
so this is a classic example of
streaming application using window based
computations persisting your
computations and also doing the check
pointing simultaneously in this tutorial
here we have some list of questions and
an explanation of those so that you can
be well prepared for your hadoop
interviews now let's look at some
general hadoop questions so what are the
different vendor specific distributions
of hadoop now all of you might be aware
that hadoop or apache hadoop is the core
distribution of hadoop and then you have
different vendors in the market which
have packaged the apache hadoop in a
cluster management solution which allows
everyone to easily deploy manage monitor
upgrade your clusters so here are some
vendor-specific distributions we have
cloudera which is the dominant one in
the market we have hortonworks and now
you might be aware that cloudera and
hortonworks have merged so it has become
a bigger entity you have mapper you have
microsoft azure ibm's infosphere and
amazon web services so these are some
popularly known vendor-specific
distributions if you would want to know
more about the hadoop distributions you
should basically look into google and
you should check for hadoop different
distributions wiki page so if i type
hadoop different distributions and then
i check for the wiki page that will take
me to the distributions and commercial
support page and this basically says
that the sold products that can be
called a release of apache hadoop come
from apache.org so that's your open
source community and then you have
various vendor specific distributions
which basically are running in one or
the other way apache hadoop but they
have packaged it as a solution like a
installer so that you can easily set up
clusters on set of machines so have a
look at this page and read through about
different distributions of hadoop coming
back let's look at our next question so
what are the different hadoop
configuration files now whether you're
talking about apache hadoop cloudera
hortonworks map r or no matter which
other distribution these config files
are the most important and existing in
every distribution of hadoop so you have
hadoop environment dot sh wherein you
will have environment variables such as
your java path what would be your
process id path where will your logs get
stored what kind of metrics will be
collected and so on your core hyphen
site file has the hdfs path
now this has many other properties like
enabling trash or enabling high
availability or discussing or mentioning
about your zookeeper but this is one of
the most important file you have hdfs
hyphen site file now this file will have
other information related to your hadoop
cluster such as your replication factor
where will name node store its metadata
on disk if a data node is running where
would data node store its data if a
secondary name node is running where
would that store a copy of name node's
metadata and so on your map red hyphen
site file is a file which will have
properties related to
your mapreduce processing you also have
masters and slaves now these might be
deprecated in a vendor-specific
distribution and in fact you would have
a yarn hyphen side file which is based
on the yarn processing framework which
was introduced in hadoop version 2 and
this would have all your resource
allocation and resource manager and node
manager related properties again if you
would want to look at default properties
for any one of these for example let's
say hdfs hyphen site file i could just
go to google and type in one of the
properties for example i would say
dfs.namenode.name.directory and as i
know this property belongs to hdfs
hyphen site file and if you search for
this it will take you to the first link
which says sdfs default xml you can
click on this and this will show you all
the properties which can be given in
your sdfs hyphen site file it also shows
you which version you are looking at and
you can always change the version here
so for example if i would want to look
at 2.6.5
i just need to change the version and
that should show me the properties
similarly you can just give a property
which belongs to say core hyphen site
file for example i would say fs dot
default fs and that's a property which
is in core hyphen site file and
somewhere here you would see core minus
default.xml and this will show you all
the properties so similarly you could
search for properties which are related
to yarn hyphen site file or map red
hyphen site file so i could say yarn dot
resource manager and i could look at one
of these properties which will directly
take me to yarn default xml and i can
see all the properties which can be
given in yarn and similarly you could
say map reduce dot job dot reduces and i
know this property belongs to mapreduce
hyphen site file and this takes you to
the default xml so these are important
config files and no matter which
distribution of hadoop you are working
on you should be knowing about these
config files whether you work as a
hadoop admin or you work as a hadoop
developer knowing these config
properties would be very important and
that would also showcase your internal
knowledge about the configs which drive
your hadoop cluster let's look at the
next question so what are the three
modes in which hadoop can run so you can
have hadoop running in a standalone mode
now that's your default mode it would
basically use a local file system in a
single java process so when you say
standalone mode it is as you downloading
hadoop related package on one single
machine but you would not have any
process running that would just be to
test hadoop functionalities you could
have a pseudo distributed mode which
basically means it's a single node
hadoop deployment now hadoop as a
framework has many many services so it
has a lot of services and those services
would be running irrespective of your
distribution and each service would then
have multiple processes so your
pseudo-distributed mode is a mode of
cluster where you would have all the
important processes belonging to one or
multiple services running on a single
node if you would want to work on a sudo
distributed mode and using a cloud error
you can always go to google and search
for cloudera's quick start vm you can
download it by just saying cloudera
quick start vm and you can search for
this and that will allow you to download
a quick start vm follow the instructions
and you can have a single node cloudera
cluster running on your virtual machines
for more information you can refer to
the youtube tutorial where i have
explained about how to set up a quick
start vm coming back you could have
finally a production setup or a fully
distributed mode which basically means
that your hadoop framework and its
components would be spread across
multiple machines so you would have
multiple services such as sdfs yarn
flume scope
kafka hbase hive impala and for these
services there would be one or multiple
processes distributed across multiple
nodes so this is normally what is used
in production environment so you could
say standalone would be good for testing
pseudo distributed could be good for
testing and development and fully
distributed would be mainly for your
production setup now what are the
differences between regular file system
and hdfs
so when you say regular file system you
could be talking about a linux file
system or you could be talking about a
windows based operating system so in
regular file system we would have data
maintained in a single system so the
single system is where you have all your
files and directories so it is having
low fault tolerance right so if the
machine crashes your data recovery would
be very difficult unless and until you
have a backup of that data that also
affects your processing so if the
machine crashes or if the machine fails
then your processing would be blocked
now the biggest challenge with regular
file system is the seek time the time
taken to read the data so you might have
one single machine with huge amount of
disks and huge amount of ram but then
the time taken to read that data when
all the data is stored in one machine
would be very high and that would be
with least fault tolerance if you talk
about sdfs your data is distributed so
sdfs stands for hadoop distributed file
system so here your data is distributed
and maintained on multiple systems so it
is never one single machine it is also
supporting reliability so whatever is
stored in hdfs say a file being stored
depending on its size is split into
blocks and those blocks will be spread
across multiple nodes not only that
every block which is stored on a node
will have its replicas stored on other
nodes replication factor depends but
this makes sdfs more reliable in cases
of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more as you might have
situations where your data is
distributed across the nodes and even if
you are doing a parallel read your data
read might take more time because it
needs coordination from multiple
machines however if you are working with
huge data which is getting stored it
will still be beneficial in comparison
to reading from a single machine so you
should always think about its
reliability through auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up
now let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs fault
tolerant now as i just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default
block size of 128 mb that's the minimum
since hadoop version 2. so any file
which is up to 128 mb would be using one
logical block and if the file size is
bigger than 128 mb then it will be split
into blocks and those blocks will be
stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored across
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talk
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how sdfs is fault
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as i mentioned
earlier you would in a hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs
so for your sdfs service you would have
a name node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across or
getting or the processes running across
multiple machines each one of these
processes has an important role to play
when you talk about sdfs whatever data
is written to hdfs
that data is split into blocks depending
on its size and the blocks are randomly
distributed across nodes with auto
replication feature these blocks are
also
auto replicated across multiple machines
with the first condition that no two
identical blocks will sit on the same
machine now as soon as the cluster comes
up your data nodes which are part of the
cluster and based on config files would
start sending their heart beat to the
name node and this would be every three
seconds what does name node do with that
name node will store this information in
its ram so name node starts building a
metadata in its ram and that metadata
has information of what are the data
nodes which are available in the
beginning now when a data
writing activity starts and the blocks
are distributed across data nodes data
nodes every 10 seconds will also send a
block report to name node so name node
is again adding up this information in
its ram or the metadata in ram which
earlier had only data node information
now name node will also have information
about what are the files the files are
split in which blocks the blocks are
stored on which machines and what are
the file permissions now while name node
is maintaining this metadata in ram name
node is also maintaining metadata in
disk now that is what we see in the red
box which basically has information of
whatever information was written to hdfs
so to summarize your name node has
metadata in ram and metadata in disk
your data nodes are the machines where
your blocks or data is actually getting
stored and then there is an auto
replication feature which is always
existing unless and until you have
disabled it and your read and write
activity is a parallel activity however
replication is a sequential activity now
this is what i mentioned about when you
talk about name node which is the master
process hosting metadata in disk and ram
so when we talk about disk it basically
has a edit log which is your transaction
log and your fs image which is your file
system image right from the time the
cluster was started this metadata and
disk was existing and this gets appended
every time read write or any other
operations happen on sdfs
metadata in ram is dynamically built
every time the cluster comes up which
basically means that if your cluster is
coming up name node in the initial few
seconds or few minutes would be in a
safe mode which basically means it is
busy registering the information from
data nodes so name node is one of the
most critical processes if name node is
down and if all other processes are
running you will not be able to access
the cluster name node's metadata in disk
is very important for name node to come
up and maintain the cluster name node's
metadata in ram is basically for all or
satisfying all your client requests now
when we look at data nodes as i
mentioned data nodes hold the actual
data blocks and they are sending these
block reports every 10 seconds so the
metadata in name nodes ram is constantly
getting updated and metadata in disk is
also constantly getting updated based on
any kind of write activity happening on
the cluster now data node which is
storing the block will also help in any
kind of read activity whenever a client
requests so whenever a client or an
application or an api would want to read
the data it would first talk to name
node name node would look into its
metadata on ram and confirm to the
client which machines could be reached
to get to that data that's where your
client would try to read the data from
sdfs which is actually getting the data
from data nodes and that's how your read
write requests are satisfied now what
are the two types of metadata in name
node server holds as i mentioned earlier
metadata in disk very important to
remember edit log nfs image metadata in
ram which is information about your data
nodes files files being split into
blocks blocks residing on data nodes and
file permissions so i will share a very
good link on this and you can always
look for more detailed information about
your metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hortonworks however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back let's look at the next
question what is the difference between
federation and high availability now
these are the features which were
introduced in hadoop version 2. both of
these features are about
horizontal scalability of name node so
prior to version 2 the only possibility
was that you could have one single
master which basically me
means that your cluster could become
unavailable if name node would crash so
hadoop version 2 introduced two new
features federation and high
availability however high availability
is a popular one so when you talk about
federation it basically means any number
of name nodes so there is no limitation
to the number of name nodes your name
nodes are in a federated cluster which
basically means name nodes still belong
to the same cluster but they are not
coordinating with each other so whenever
a write request comes in one of the name
node picks up that request and it guides
that request for the blocks to be
written on data nodes but for this your
name node does not have to coordinate
with other name node to find out if the
block id which was being assigned was
the same one as assigned by other name
node so all of them belong to a
federated cluster they are linked via a
cluster id so whenever an application or
an api is trying to talk to cluster it
is always going via an cluster id and
one of the name node would pick up the
read activity or write activity or
processing activity so all the name
nodes are sharing a pool of metadata in
which each name node will have its own
dedicated pool and we can remember that
by a term called namespace or name
service so this also provides high fault
tolerance suppose your one name node
goes down it will not affect or make
your cluster unavailable you will still
have your cluster reachable because
there are other name nodes running and
they are available now when it comes to
heartbeats all your data nodes are
sending their heart beats to all the
name nodes and all the name nodes are
aware of all the data nodes when you
talk about high availability this is
where you would only have two name nodes
so you would have an active and you
would have a standby now normally in any
environment you would see a
high availability setup with zookeeper
so zookeeper is a centralized
coordination service so when you talk
about your active and standby name notes
election of a name node to be made as
active and taking care of an automatic
failover is done by your zookeeper high
availability can be set up without
zookeeper but that would mean that the
admins intervention would be required to
make a name node as active from standby
or also to take care of failover
now at any point of time in high
availability a active name node would be
taking care of storing the edits about
whatever updates are happening on sdfs
and it is also writing these edits to a
shared location standby name node is the
one which is constantly looking for
these latest updates and applying to its
metadata which is actually a copy of
whatever your active name node has so in
this way your standby name node is
always in sync with the active name node
and if for any reason active name node
fails your standby name node will take
over and become the active remember
zookeeper plays a very important role
here it's a centralized coordination
service one more thing to remember here
is that in your high availability
secondary name node will not be allowed
so you would have a active name node and
then you will have a standby name node
which will be configured on a separate
machine and both of these will be having
access to a shared location now that
shared location could be nfs or it could
be a quorum of general nodes so for more
information refer to the tutorial where
i have explained about sdfs high
availability and federation now let's
look at some logical question here so if
you have a input file of 350 mb which is
obviously bigger than 128 mb how many
input splits would be created by sdfs
and what would be the size of each input
split so for this you need to remember
that by default the minimum block size
is 128 mb now that's customizable if
your environment has more number of
larger files written on an average then
obviously you have to go for a bigger
block size if your environment has a lot
of files being written but these files
are of smaller size you could be okay
with 128 mb remember in hadoop every
entity that is your directory on sdfs
file on sdfs and a file having multiple
blocks each of these are considered as
objects and for each object hadoop's
name nodes ram 150 bytes is utilized so
if your block size is very small then
you would have more number of blocks
which would directly affect the name
node's ram if you keep a block size very
high that will reduce the number of
blocks but remember that might affect in
processing because processing also
depends on splits more number of splits
more the parallel processing so
setting of block size has to be done
with consideration about your
parallelism requirement and your name
nodes ram which is available now coming
to the question if you have a file of
350 mb that would be split into three
blocks and here two blocks would have
128 mb data and the third block although
the block size would still be 128 it
would have only 94 mb of data so this
would be the split of this particular
file now let's
understand about rack awareness how does
rack awareness work or why do we even
have racks so organizations always would
want to place their nodes or machines in
a systematic way there can be different
approaches you could have a rack which
would have machines running on the
master processes and the intention would
be that this particular rack could have
higher bandwidth more cooling dedicated
power supply top of rack switch and so
on the second approach could be that you
could have one master process running on
one machine of every rack and then you
could have other slave processes running
now when you talk about your rack
awareness one thing to understand is
that if your machines are placed within
racks and we are aware that hadoop
follows auto replication the rule of
replication in a rack of air cluster
would be that you would never have all
the replicas placed on the same rack so
if we look at this if we have block a in
blue color you will never have all the
three blue boxes in the same rack even
if they are on different nodes because
that makes us that makes it less fault
tolerant so you would have at least one
copy of block which would be stored on a
different track on a different note now
let's look at this so basically here we
are talking about replicas being placed
in such a way now somebody could ask a
question can i have my block and its
replicas spread across three lakhs and
yes you can do that but then in order to
make it more redundant you are
increasing your bandwidth requirement so
the better approach would be two blocks
on the same rack on different machines
and one copy on a different track now
let's proceed how can you restart name
node and all demons in hadoop so if you
were working on an apache hadoop cluster
then you could be doing a start and stop
using hadoop demon scripts so there are
these hadoop demon scripts which would
be used to start and stop your hadoop
and this is when you talk about your
apache hadoop so let's look at one
particular file which i would like to
show you more information here and this
talks about your different clusters so
let's look into this and
so let's look at the start and stop and
here i have a file let's look at this
one and this gives you highlights so if
you talk about apache hadoop this is how
the setup would be done so you would
have it download the adobe tar file you
would have to untie it edit the config
files you would have to do formatting
and then start your cluster and here i
have said using scripts so this is in
case of apache hadoop you could be using
a start all script that internally
triggers start dfs and start yarn and
these scripts start dfs internally would
run hadoop demon multiple times based on
your configs to start your different
processes then your start yarn would run
yarn demon script to start your
processing related processes so this is
how it happens in apache hadoop now in
case of cloud era or hortonworks which
is basically a vendor specific
distribution you would have say multiple
services which would have one or
multiple demons running across the
machines let's take an example here that
you would have machine 1 machine 2 and
machine 3 with your processor spread
across however in case of cloud era and
hortonworks these are cluster management
solutions so you would never be involved
in running a script individually to
start and stop your processes in fact in
case of cloudera you would have a
cloudera scm server running on one of
the machines and then cloudera scm
agents running on every machine if you
talk about hortonworks you would have
ambari server an ambari agent running so
your agents which are running on every
machine are responsible to monitor the
processes send also their heartbeat to
the master that is your server and your
server is the one or a service which
basically will give instructions to the
agents so in case of vendor specific
distribution your start and stop of
processes is automatically taken care by
these underlying services and these
services internally are still running
these commands however only in apache
hadoop you have to manually follow these
to start and stop coming back
we can look into
some command related questions so which
command will help you find the status of
blocks and file system health so you can
always go for a file system check
command now that can show you the files
for a particular sdfs path it can show
you the blocks and it can also give you
information on
status such as under replicated blocks
over replicated blocks misreplicated
blocks default replication and so on so
your fsck file system check utility does
not repair if there is any problem with
the blocks but it can give you
information of
blocks related to the files on which
machines they have stored if they are
replicated as per the replication factor
or if there is any problem with any
particular replica now what would happen
if you store too many small files in a
cluster and this relates to the block
information which i gave some time back
so remember hadoop is coded in java so
here every directory every file and file
related block is considered as an object
and for every object within your hadoop
cluster name node's ram gets utilized so
more number of blocks you have more
would be usage of name nodes ram and if
you're storing too many small files it
would not affect your disk it would
directly affect your name nodes ram
that's why in production clusters admin
guys or infrastructure specialist will
take care that everyone who is writing
data to hdfs follows a quota system so
that you could be controlled in the
amount of data you write plus the count
of data and individual rights on hdfs
now how do you copy data from local
system onto sdfs so you can use a put
command or a copy from local and then
given your local path which is your
source and then your destination which
is your sdfs path remember you can
always do a copy from local using a
minus f option that's a flag option and
that also helps you in writing the same
file or a new file to hdfs so with your
minus f you have a chance of overwriting
or rewriting the data which is existing
on sdfs so copy from local or minus put
both of them do the same thing and you
can also pass an argument when you're
copying to control your replication or
other aspects of your file now when do
you use dfs admin refresh nodes or rm
admin refresh nodes so as the command
says this is basically to do with
refreshing the node information so your
refresh nodes is mainly used when say a
commissioning or decommissioning of
nodes is done so when a node is added
into the cluster or when a node is
removed from the cluster you are
actually informing hadoop master that
this particular node would not be used
for storage and would not be used for
processing now in that case you would be
once you are done with the process of
commissioning or decommissioning you
would be giving these commands that is
refresh nodes and rm admin refresh nodes
so internally when you talk about
commissioning decommissioning there are
include and exclude files which are
updated and these include and exclude
files will have entry of machines which
are being added to the cluster or
machines which are being removed from
the cluster and while this is being done
the cluster is still running so you do
not have to restart your master process
however you can just use these refresh
commands to take care of your
commissioning decommissioning activities
now is there any way to change
replication of files on sdfs after they
are already written and the answer is of
course yes so if you would want to set a
replication factor at a cluster level
and if you have admin access then you
could edit your sdfs hyphen site file or
you could say hadoop hyphen site file
and that would take care of replication
factor being set at a cluster level
however if you would want to change the
replication after the data has been
written you could always use a setrep
command so setrep command is basically
to change the replication after the data
is written
you could also
write the data with a different
replication and for that you could use a
minus d dfs dot replication and give
your application factor when you are
writing data to the cluster so in hadoop
you can let your data be replicated as
per the property set in the config file
you could write the data with a
different replication
you could change the replication after
the data is read so all these options
are available now who takes care of
replication consistency in a hadoop
cluster and what do you mean by under
over replicated blocks now as i
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always and
always name node which takes care of
replication consistency so for example
if you have set up a replication of
three and since we know the first rule
of replication which basically means
that you cannot have two replicas
residing on the same node it would mean
that if your replication is three you
would need at least three data nodes
available now say for example you had a
cluster with three nodes and replication
was set to three at one point of time
one of your name node crashed and if
that happens your blocks would be under
replicated that means there was a
replication factor set but now your
blocks are not replicated or there are
not enough replicas as per the
replication factor set this is not a
problem your master process or name node
will wait for some time before it will
start the replication of data again so
if a data road is not responding or if a
disk has crashed and if name node does
not get information of a replica name
node will wait for some time and then it
will start re-replication of those
missing blocks from the available nodes
however while name node is doing it the
blocks are in under replicated situation
now when you talk about over replicated
this is a situation where name node
realizes that there are extra copies of
block now this might be the case that
you had three nodes running with a
replication of three one of the node
went down due to a network failure or
some other issue within few minutes name
node re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with its set of
blocks again name node is smart enough
to understand that this is a over
replication situation and it will delete
set of blocks from one of the nodes it
might be the node which has been
recently added it might be your old node
which has joined your cluster again or
any node that depends on the load on a
particular node now we discussed about
hadoop we discussed about sdfs now we
will discuss about mapreduce which is
the programming model and you can say
processing framework what is distributed
cache in mapreduce now we know that when
we talk about mapreduce the data which
has to be processed might be existing on
multiple nodes so when you would have
your mapreduce program running it would
basically read the data from the
underlying disks
now this could be a costly operation if
every time the data has to be read from
disk
so distributed cache is a mechanism
wherein
data set or data which is coming from
the disk can be cached
and available for all worker nodes now
how will this benefit so when a map
reduce is running instead of every time
reading the data from disk
it would pick up the data from
distributed cache and this this will
benefit your mapreduce processing so
distributed cache can be set in your
jobconf where you can specify that a
file should be picked up from
distributed cache
now let's understand about these roles
so what is a record reader what is a
combiner what is a partitioner and what
kind of roles do they play in a
mapreduce processing paradigm or
mapreduce operation so record reader
communicates with the input split and it
basically converts the data into key
value pairs and these key value pairs
are the ones which will be worked upon
by the mapper your combiner is an
optional face it's like mini radius so
combiner does not have its own class
it relies on the reducer class
basically your combiner would receive
the data from your map tasks
which would have completed works on it
based on whatever reducer class mentions
and then passes its output to the
reducer phase partitioner is basically a
phase which decides how many reduced
tasks would be used aggregate or
summarize your data so partitioner is a
phase which would decide based on the
number of keys based on the number of
map tasks your partition would decide if
one or multiple reduced tasks would be
used to take care of processing so
either it could be partitioner which
decides on how many reduced tasks would
run or it could be based on the
properties which we have set within the
cluster which will take care of the
number of reduced tasks which would be
used always remember your partitioner
decides how outputs from combiner are
sent to reducer and to how many reducers
it controls the partitioning of keys of
your intermediate map outputs so map
phase whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that has to be
taken by your practitioner or by a
combiner and then partitioner to be sent
to one or multiple reduced tasks this is
one of the common questions which you
might face
why is mapreduce lower
in processing so we know mapreduce goes
for parallel processing we know we can
have multiple map tasks running on
multiple nodes at the same time we also
know that multiple reduced tasks could
be running now why does then mapreduce
become a slower approach
first of all your mapreduce is a batch
oriented operation now mapreduce
is very rigid and it strictly uses
mapping and reducing phases so no matter
what kind of processing you would want
to do you would have to still provide
the mapper function and the reducer
function to work on data not only this
whenever your map phase completes
the output of your map face which is an
intermittent output would be written to
hdfs and thereafter underlying disks and
this data would then be shuffled and
sorted and picked up for reducing phase
so every time your data being written to
hdfs and retrieved from sdfs makes
mapreduce a slower approach the question
is for a mapreduce job is it possible to
change the number of mappers to be
created
now by default you cannot change the
number of map tasks because number of
map tasks depends on the input splits
however there are different ways in
which you can either set a property to
have more number of map tasks which can
be used or you can customize your code
or
make it use a different format which can
then control the number of map tasks
by default
number of map tasks
are equal to the number of splits of
file you are processing
so if you have a 1 gb of file that is
split into 8 blocks of 128 mb there
would be eight map tasks running on the
cluster these map tasks are basically
running your mapper function
if you have hard coded properties in
your map red hyphen site file to specify
more number of map tasks then you could
control the number of map tasks
let's also talk about some data types so
when you prepare for hadoop when you
want to get into big data field you
should start learning about different
data formats now there are different
data formats such as
avro parquet
you have a sequence file or binary
format and these are different formats
which are used now when you talk about
your data types
in hadoop these are implementation of
your writable and writable comparable
interfaces so for every data type
in java you have a equivalent in hadoop
so end in java would be in writable in
hadoop float would be float writable
long would be long writable double
writable boolean writable array writable
map writable and object credible so
these are your different data types that
could be used within your mapreduce
program and these are implementation of
writable and writable comparable
interfaces what is speculative execution
now imagine you have a cluster which has
huge number of nodes and your data is
spread across multiple slave machines or
multiple nodes now at a point of time
due to a disk degrade or network issues
or machine heating up or more load being
on a particular node there can be a
situation where your data node will
execute task in a slower manner now in
this case if speculative execution is
turned on there would be a shadow task
or a another
similar task running on some other node
for the same processing so whichever
task finishes first will be accepted and
the other task would be killed so
speculative execution could be good if
you are working in an intensive workload
kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied or a node
which has less load to take care of your
processing going further this is how we
can understand so node a which might be
having a slower task you would have a
scheduler which is maintaining or
having knowledge of what are the
resources available so if speculative
execution as a property is turned on
then the task which was running slow a
copy of that task or you can say shadow
task would run on some other node and
whichever task completes first will be
considered this is what happens in your
speculative execution now how is
identity mapper different from chain
mapper now this is where we are getting
deeper into mapreduce concepts so when
you talk about mapper identity mapper is
the default mapper which is chosen when
no mapper is specified in mapreduce
driver class so for every map reduced
program you would have a map class which
is taking care of your mapping phase
which basically has a mapper function
and which would run one or multiple map
tasks right your programming your
program would also have a reduce class
which would be running a reducer
function which takes care of reduced
tasks running on multiple nodes
now if a mapper is not specified within
your driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduced class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver class
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old mapreduce api in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple map
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first mapper
would become as an input to second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the under mentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in a mapreduce
program
obviously we need to have the input
location we need to have the output
location so input location is where the
files will be picked up from and this
would preferably on sdfs directory
output location is the path where your
job output would be written by your
mapreduce program you also need to
specify input and output formats if you
don't specify the defaults are
considered then we need to also have the
classes which have your map and reduce
functions and if you intend to run the
code on a cluster you need to package
your class in a jar file export it to
your cluster and then this jar file
would have your mapper reducer and
driver classes so these are important
configuration parameters
which you need to consider for a map
reduce program now what is the
difference or what do you mean by map
side join and reduce side join map side
join is basically when the join is
performed at the mapping level or at the
mapping phase or is performed by the
mapper so each input data which is being
worked upon has to be divided into same
number of partitions
input to each map is in the form of a
structured partition and is in sorted
order so map site join you can
understand it in a simpler way that if
you compare it with rdbms concepts where
you had two tables which were being
joined it will always be advisable to
give your bigger table as the left side
table or the first table for your join
condition and it would be your smaller
table on the left side and your bigger
table on the right side which basically
means the smaller table could be loaded
in memory and could be used for joining
so map side drawing is a similar kind of
mechanism where input data is divided
into same number of partitions when you
talk about reduced side join here the
join is performed by the reducer so it
is easier to implement than website join
as all the sorting and shuffling will
send the values
or send all the values having identical
keys to the same reducer so you don't
need to have your data set in a
structured form so look into your map
side join or reduce side join and other
joins just to understand how mapreduce
works however i would suggest not to
focus more on this because mapreduce is
still being used for processing but the
amount of map reduce based processing
has decreased overall or across the
industry now what is the role of output
committer class in a mapreduce job so
output committer as the name says
describes the commit of task output for
a mapreduce job so we could have this as
mentioned or apache hadoop mapreduce
output committer you could have a class
which extends your output committer
class
so mapreduce relies on this mapreduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to
set up the job initialization cleaning
up the job after the job completion that
means all the resources which were being
used by a particular job setting up the
task temporary output checking whether a
task needs a commit committing the task
output and discarding the task out so
this is a very important class and can
be used within your mapreduce job what
is the process of spilling in mapreduce
what does that mean
so spilling is basically a process of
copying the data from memory buffer to
disk when obviously the
buffer usage reaches a certain threshold
so if there is not enough memory in your
buffer in your memory then the content
which is stored in buffer or memory has
to be flushed out so by default a
background thread starts spilling the
content from memory to disk after eighty
percent of buffer size is filled now
when is the buffer being used so when
your mapreduce processing is happening
the data from data is being read from
the disk loaded into the buffer and then
some processing happens
same thing also happens when you are
writing data to the cluster so you can
imagine for a hundred megabyte size
buffer the spilling will start after the
content of buffer reaches 80 megabytes
this is customizable how can you set the
mappers and reducers for a mapreduce job
so these are the properties
so number of mappers and reducers as i
mentioned earlier can be customized so
by default your number of map tasks
depends on the split and number of
reduced tasks depends on the
partitioning phase which decides number
of reduced tasks which would be used
depending on the keys however we can set
these properties either in the config
files or provide them on the command
line or also make them part of our code
and this can control the number of map
tasks or reduce tasks which would be run
for a particular job let's look at one
more interesting question what happens
when a node running a map task fails
before sending the output to the reducer
so there was a node which was running a
map task and we know that there could be
one or multiple map tasks running on one
or multiple nodes and all the map tasks
have to be completed before the further
stages that such as combiner or reducer
come into existence so in a case if a
node crashes where a map task was
assigned to it the whole task will have
to be run again on some other note so in
hadoop version 2 yarn framework has a
temporary demon called application
master so your application master is
taking care of execution of your
application and if a particular task on
a particular node failed due to
unavailability of node it is the role of
application master to have this task
scheduled on some other node now can we
write the output of mapreduce in
different formats of course we can so
hadoop supports various input and output
formats so you can write the output of
mapreduce in different formats so you
could have the default format that is
text output format wherein records are
written as line of text you could have
sequence file which is basically to
write sequence files or your binary
format files where your output files
need to be fed into another mapreduce
jobs you could go for a map file output
format to write output as map files you
could go for a sequence file as a binary
output format so that's again a variant
of your
sequence file input format it basically
writes keys and values to a sequence
file so when we talk about binary format
we are talking about a non-human
readable format db output format now
this is basically used when you would
want to write data to say relational
databases or say nosql databases such as
hbase so this format also sends the
reduce output to a sql table now let's
learn a little bit about yarn yarn which
stands for yet another resource
negotiator it's the processing framework
so what benefits did yan bring in hadoop
version 2 and how did it solve the
issues of mapreduce version 1. so
mapreduce version 1 had major issues
when it comes to scalability or
availability because sorry in hadoop
version 1 you had only one master
process for processing layer and that is
your job tracker so your job tracker was
listening to all the task trackers which
were running on multiple machines so
your job tracker was responsible for
resource tracking and job scheduling in
yarn you still have a processing master
but that's called resource manager
instead of job tracker and now with
hadoop version 2 you could even have
resource manager running in high
availability mode you have node managers
which would be running on multiple
machines and then you have a temporary
demon called application master so in
case of hadoop version 2 your resource
manager or master is only handling the
client connections and taking care of
tracking the resources the jobs
scheduling or basically taking care of
execution across multiple nodes is
controlled by application master till
the application completes
so in yarn you can have different kind
of resource allocations that could be
done and there is a concept of container
so container is basically a combination
of ram and cpu cores yarn can run
different kind of workloads so it is not
just map reduce kind of workload which
can be run on auto version 2 but you
would have graph processing massive
parallel processing you could have a
real-time processing and huge processing
applications could run on a cluster
based on yarn so when we talk about
scalability
in case of your hadoop version 2 you can
have a cluster size of more than 10 000
nodes and can run more than 100 000
concurrent tasks and this is because for
every application which is launched you
have this temporary demon called
application master so if i would have 10
applications running i would have 10 app
masters running taking care of execution
of these applications across multiple
nodes compatibility so hadoop version 2
is fully compatible with whatever was
developed as per hadoop version 1 and
all your processing needs would be taken
care by yarn
so dynamic allocation of cluster
resources taking care of different
workloads
allocating resources across multiple
machines and using them for execution
all that is taken care by
multi-tenancy which basically means you
could have multiple users or multiple
teams
you could have open source and
proprietary data access engines and all
of these could be basically hosted using
the same cluster now how does yarn
allocate resources to an application
with help of its architecture so
basically you have a client or an
application or an api which talks to
resource manager resource manager is as
i mentioned managing the resource
allocation in the cluster when you talk
about resource manager you have its
internal two components one is your
scheduler and one is your applications
manager so when we say resource manager
being the master is tracking the
resources the source manager is the one
which is negotiating the resources with
slave it is not actually resource
manager who is doing it but these
internal components
so you have a scheduler which allocates
resources to various running
applications so scheduler is not
bothered about tracking your resources
or basically tracking your applications
so we can have different kind of
schedulers such as fifo which is first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler or you could have a capacity
scheduler and these schedulers basically
control how resources are allocated to
multiple applications when they are
running in parallel so there is a queue
mechanism so scheduler will schedule
resources based on requirements of
application but it is not monitoring or
tracking the status of applications
your applications manager is the one
which is accepting the job submissions
it is monitoring and restarting the
application masters so it's application
manager which is basically then
launching a application master which is
responsible for an application so this
is how it looks
so whenever a job submission happens we
already know that resource manager is
aware of the resources which are
available with every node manager so on
every node which has fixed amount of ram
and cpu cores
some portion of resources that is your
ram and cpu cores are allocated to node
manager now resource manager is already
aware of how much resources are
available across nodes so whenever a
client request comes in resource manager
will make a request to node manager it
will basically request node manager to
hold some resources for processing node
manager would basically approve or
disapprove this request of holding
resources
and these resources that is a
combination of ram and cpu cores are
nothing but containers we can allocate
containers of different sizes within
yarn hyphen site file so your node
manager based on a request from resource
manager guarantees the container which
would be available for processing that's
when your resource manager starts a
temporary demand called application
master to take care of your execution so
your app master which was launched by
resource manager or we can say
internally by applications manager will
run in one of the containers because
application master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution this is
how yarn is basically taking care of
your allocation your application master
is managing resource needs it is the one
which is interacting with scheduler and
if
a particular
node crashes it is the responsibility of
app master to go back to the master
which is resource manager and negotiate
for more resources
so your app master will never ever
negotiate resources with node manager
directly it will always talk to resource
manager and the source manager is the
one which negotiates the resources
container as i said is a collection of
resources like your ram cpu network
bandwidth and your container is
allocated based on the availability of
resources on a particular node so which
of the following has occupied the place
of a job tracker of mapreduce so it is
your resource manager so resource
manager is the name of the master
process in adobe portion 2. now if you
would have to
write yarn commands to check the status
of an application so we could just say
yarn application minus status and then
the application id and you could kill it
also from the command line remember your
yarn has a ui and you can even look at
your applications from the ui you can
even kill your applications from the ui
however knowing the command line
commands would be very useful can we
have more than one resource manager in a
young base cluster yes we can that is
what hadoop version 2 allows us to have
so you can have a high availability yarn
cluster where you have active and
standby and the coordination is taking
care by your zookeeper at a particular
time there can only be one active
resource manager and if active resource
manager fails your standby resource
manager comes and becomes active however
zookeeper is playing a very important
role remember zookeeper is the one which
is coordinating the server state and it
is doing the election of active to
standby failover what are the different
schedulers available in yan so you have
a fifo scheduler that is
first in first out and this is not a
desirable option because in this case a
longer running application might block
all other small running applications
your capacity scheduler is basically a
scheduler where dedicated queues are
created and they have fixed amount of
resources so you can have multiple
applications accessing the cluster at
the same time and they would be using
their own cues
and the resources allocated to them if
you talk about fair scheduler you don't
need to have a fixed amount of
resources you can just have a percentage
and you could decide what kind of
fairness is to be followed which
basically means that if you were
allocated 20 gigabytes of memory however
the cluster has 100 gigabytes and the
other team was assigned 80 gigabytes of
memory then you have 20 access to the
cluster another team has 80 percent
however if the other team does not come
up or does not use the cluster in a fair
scheduler you can go up to maximum 100
of your cluster to find out more
information about your schedulers you
could either look in hadoop definitive
guide or what you could do is you could
just go to google and you could type for
example yarn
scheduler let's search for yarn
scheduler and then you can look in
hadoop definitive guide
and so this is your hadoop definitive
guide and it beautifully explains about
your different schedulers how do
multiple applications run and that could
be in your
fifo kind of scheduling it could be in
capacity scheduler or it could be in a
fair scheduling so have a look at this
link it's a very good link you can also
search for yarn untangling and this is a
blog of four or this is a series of four
blocks where it's beautifully explained
about your yarn how it works how the
resource allocation happens what is a
container and what runs within the
container so you can scroll down you can
be reading through this and you can then
also search for part two of it which
talks about allocation and so on so
coming back
we basically have these schedulers what
happens if a resource manager fails
while executing an application in a high
availability cluster so in a high
availability cluster we know that we
will have two resource managers one
being active one being standby and
zookeeper which is keeping a track of
the server states so if a rm fails in
case of high availability the
standby will be elected as active and
then basically your resource manager or
the standby would become the active one
and this one would instruct the
application master to abort in the
beginning then your resource manager
recovers its running state so there is
something called as rm state store where
all the applications which are running
their status is stored so resource
manager recovers
its running state by looking at your
state store
by taking advantage of container
statuses and then continues to take care
of your processing now in a cluster of
10 data nodes each having 16 gb and 10
cores what would be total processing
capacity of the cluster take a minute to
think 10 data nodes 16 gb ram per node
10 cores
so if you mention the answer as 160 gb
ram
and 100 cores then you went wrong now
think of a cluster which has 10 data
nodes each having 16 gb ram and 10 cores
remember on every node in a hadoop
cluster you would have one or multiple
processors running those processes would
need ram the machine itself which has a
linux file system would have its own
processes so that would also be having
some ram usage which basically means
that if you talk about 10 data nodes you
should deduct at least 20 to 30 percent
towards the overheads towards the cloud
database services towards the other
processes which are running and in that
case i could say that you could have 11
or 12 gb available on every machine for
processing and say 6 or 7 cores multiply
that by 10 and that's your processing
capacity remember the same thing applies
to the disk usage also so if somebody
asks you in a 10 data node cluster where
each machine has 20 terabytes of disks
what is my total storage capacity
available for sdfs so the answer would
not be 200 you have to consider the
overheads and this is basically which
gives you your processing capacity now
let's look at one more question so what
happens if requested memory or cpu goes
beyond or goes beyond the size of
container now as i said you can have
your configurations which can say that
in a particular data node which has 100
gb ram i could allocate say 50 gb
for the processing like out of 100 cores
i could say 50 cores for processing so
if you have 100 gb ram and 100 cores you
could ideally allocate 100 for
processing but that's not ideally
possible so if you have 100 gb ram you
would go for 50 gb and if you have 100
cores you would go for 50 cores now
within this
ram and cpu course you have the concept
of containers right so container is a
combination of ram and cpu cores so you
could have a minimum size container and
maximum size container now at any point
of time if your application starts
demanding
more memory or more cpu cores
and this cannot fit into a container
location your application will fail your
application will fail because you
requested for a memory or a combination
of memory and cpu cores which is
more than the maximum container size so
look into this eon tangling website
which i mentioned and look for the
second blog in those series which
explains about these allocations now
here we will discuss on hive peg hbase
and these components of hadoop which are
being used in the industry for various
use cases let's look at some questions
here and let's look how you should
prepare for them so first of all we will
learn on hive which is a data
warehousing package so the question is
what are the different components of a
hive architecture now when we talk about
hive we already know that hive is a data
warehousing package which basically
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structuralized so
normally people are well versed with
querying or basically processing the
data using sql queries a lot of people
come from database backgrounds and they
would find it comfortable if they know
structured query language hive is one of
the data warehousing package which
resides within a hadoop ecosystem it
uses hadoop's distributed file system to
store the data and it uses rdbms usually
to store the metadata although metadata
can be stored locally also so what are
the different components of an hive
architecture so it has a user interface
so user interface calls the execute
interface to the driver this creates a
session to the query and then it sends
the query to the compiler to generate an
execution plan for it usually whenever
hive is set up it would have its
metadata stored in an rdbms now to
establish the connection between rdbms
and hadoop we need odbc or jdbc
connector jar file and that connector
jar file has a driver class now this
driver class is mandatory to create a
connection between hive and hadoop so
user interface creates this interface
using the driver now we have metastore
metastore stores the metadata
information so any object which you
create such as database table indexes
their metadata is stored in metastore
and usually this meta store is stored in
an rdbms so that multiple users can
connect to hive so your meta store
stores the metadata information and
sends that to the compiler for execution
of a query what does the compiler do it
generates the execution plan it has a
dag now dag stands for direct acyclic
graph so it has a dag of stages where
each stage is either a metadata
operation a map or reduced job or an
operation on sdfs and finally we have
execution engine that acts as a bridge
between hive and hadoop to process the
query so execution engine communicates
bi-directionally with metastore to
perform operations like create or drop
tables so these are four important
components of hive architecture now what
is the difference between external table
and manage table and height
so we have various kinds of table in
hive such as external table manage table
partition table the major difference
between your managed and external table
is in respect to what happens to the
data if the table is dropped usually
whenever we create a table in hive it
creates a manage table or we could also
call that as an internal table now this
manages the data and moves it into
warehouse directory by default whether
you create a manage table or external
table usually the data can reside in
hive's default warehouse directory or it
could be residing in a location chosen
however when we talk about manage table
if one drops a manage table not only the
metadata information is deleted but the
table's data is also deleted from his
dfs if we talk about external table it
is created with an external keyword
explicitly and if an external table is
dropped nothing happens to the data
which resides in sdfs so that's the main
difference between your managed and
external table what might be the use
case if somebody asks you there might be
a migration kind of activity or you are
interested in creating a lot of tables
using your queries so in that case you
could dump all the data on sdfs and then
you could create a table by pointing to
a particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact
unlike your manage table where dropping
of table will delete the data from sdfs
also let's learn a little bit on
partition so what is partition and hive
and why is partitioning required in hive
if somebody asks you that now normally
in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each table usually has one
column in context of rdbms which could
be used to partition the data and why do
we do that so that we can avoid scanning
the complete table for a query and
restrict the scan to
set of data or to a particular partition
in hive we can have any number of
partition keys so partitioning provides
granularity in hive table it reduces the
query latency by scanning only relevant
partition data instead of whole data set
we can partition at various levels now
if i compare rdbms with hive in case of
rdbms you could have
one column which could be used for
partitioning and then you could be
squaring the specific partition so in
case of rdbms your partition column is
usually a part of the table definition
so for example if i have an employee
table i might have employee id employee
name employee age and employee salary as
four columns and i would decide to
partition the table based on salary
column now why would i partition it
because i feel that employee table is
growing very fast it is or it will have
huge amount of data and later when we
query the table we don't want to scan
the complete table so i could split my
data into multiple partitions based on a
salary column giving some ranges in hive
it is a little different
in hive you can do partitioning and
there is a concept of static and dynamic
partitioning but in hive the partition
column is not part of table definition
so you might have an employee table with
employee id
name age
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on sdfs in that case when we query the
data we can see the partition column
also showing up so we can partition the
transaction data for a bank for example
based on month like chan feb etc and any
operation regarding a particular month
will then allow us to query that
particular folder that is where
partitioning is useful now why does hive
not store metadata information in sdfs
if somebody asks you so we know that
hives data is stored in sdfs which is
hadoop distributed file system however
the metadata is either stored locally
and that mode of hive would be called as
embedded mode or you could have hives
metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate a
connection now this metadata which is
very important for hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so hive stores metadata
information in metastore using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access
now if somebody asks what are the
components used in hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query is
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will work on the
execution part that is the best
generated execution plan which could be
used to get the results for the query
you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in
java or the java programming language
and then basically these user defined
functions are added to the class path
now you would have a logical plan
generation which basically looks at your
query and then generates a logical plan
or the best execution path which would
be required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components in hype so somebody
might ask you if you are querying your
data using hive what are the different
components involved or if you could
explain what are the different
components which
work
when a query is submitted so these are
the components now let's look a scenario
based question suppose there are a lot
of small csv files which are present in
a sdfs directory and you want to create
a single hive table from these files so
data in these files have fields like
registration number name email address
so if this is what needs to be done what
will be your approach to solve it where
will you create a single hive table for
lots of small files without degrading
the performance of the system so there
can be different approaches now we know
that there are a lot of small csv files
which are present in a directory so we
know that when we create a table in hive
we can use a location parameter so i
could say create table give a table name
give the column and their data types i
could specify the delimiters and finally
i could say location and then point it
to a directory on sdfs and this
directory might be the directory which
has lot of csv files so in this case i
will avoid loading the data in the table
because table being point table pointing
to the directory will directly pick up
the data from one or multiple files and
we also know that hive does schema check
on read so it does not do a schema check
on write so in case there were one or
two files
which did not follow the schema of the
table it would not prevent data loading
data would anyways be loaded only when
you query the data it might show you
null values if data which was loaded
does not follow the schema of the table
this is one approach what is the other
approach so let's look at that you can
think about sequence file format which
is basically a smart format or a binary
format and you can group these small
files together to form a sequence file
now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the
delimiters as it shows here that is row
format and fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
one is storing the data instance text
file point three would be storing the
data in sequence file format so we say
create table give the specifications we
say row format delimited fields are
terminated by comma stored as sequence
file then we can move the data from test
table into test sequence file table so i
could just say insert overwrite my new
table as select star from other table
remember in hive you cannot do insert
update delete however if the table is
existing you can do a insert overwrite
from an existing table into a new table
so this could be one approach where we
could have lot of csv files or smaller
files club together as one big sequence
file and then store it in the table now
if somebody asks you write a query to
insert a new column that is
integer data type into a hive table and
the requirement might be that you would
want to insert this table at a position
before an existing column now that's
possible by doing an alter table giving
you a table name and then specifying
change column giving you a new column
with the data type before an existing
column this is a simple way wherein you
can insert a new column into a hive
table what are the key differences
between hive and pig
now some of you might have heard high
visit data warehousing package and pig
is more of a scripting language
both of them are used for data analysis
or trend detection hypothesis testing
data transformation and many other use
cases so if we compare hive and pig hive
uses a declarative language called hive
ql that is hive querying language
similar to sql and it is for reporting
or for data analysis even for data
transformation or for your data
extraction pig uses a high level
procedural language called pig latin for
programming both of them remember use
mapreduce processing framework so when
we run a query in hive to process the
data or when we create and submit a pick
script both of them trigger a mapreduce
job unless and until we have set them to
local mode hive operates on the server
side of the cluster and basically works
on structured data or data which can be
structuralized pig usually works or
operates on the client side of the
cluster and allows both structured
unstructured or even i could say
semi-structured data hive does not
support avro file format by default
however that can be done by using the
write serializer d serializer so we can
have hive table related data stored in
avro format in sequence file format in
part k format or even as a text file
format however when we are working on
smarter formats like avro or sequence
file or par k we might have to use
specific serializers d serializers for
avro this is the package which allows us
to use avro format pig supports avro
format by default hive was developed by
facebook and it supports partitioning
and pig was developed by yahoo and it
does not support partitioning so these
are high level differences there are
lots and lots of differences remember
hive is more of a data housing package
and pig is more of a scripting language
or a
strictly procedural flow following
scripting language which allows us to
process the data now let's get more and
let's get more deeper and learn about
pig which is as i mentioned a scripting
language which can be used for your data
processing it also uses mapreduce
although we can even have big run in a
local mode let's learn about pig in the
next section now let's learn on some
questions about pig which is a scripting
language and it is extensively used for
data processing and data analysis so the
question is how is apache pig different
from mapreduce now we all know that
mapreduce is a programming model it is
it's quite rigid when it comes to
processing the data because you have to
do the mapping and reducing you have to
write huge code usually mapreduce is
written in java but now it can also be
written in python it can be written in
scala and other programming languages so
if we compare pig with mapreduce pig
obviously is very concise it has less
lines of code when compared to mapreduce
now we also know that pig script
internally will trigger a mapreduce job
however user need not know about
mapreduce programming model they can
simply write simple scripts in pig and
that will automatically be converted
into mapreduce however mapreduce has
more lines of code peak is
high level language which can easily
perform join operations or other data
processing operations mapreduce is a low
level language which cannot perform job
join operations easily so we can do join
using mapreduce however it's not really
easy in comparison to pick now as i said
on execution every pig operator is
converted internally into a mapreduce
job so every pick script which is run
which would be converted into mapreduce
job now mapreduce overall is a batch
oriented processing so it takes more
time to compile it takes more time to
execute either when you run a mapreduce
job or when it is triggered by pink
script pig works with all versions of
hadoop and when we talk about mapreduce
program which is written in one hadoop
version may not work with other versions
it might work or it might not it depends
on what are the dependencies what is the
compiler you are using what programming
language you have used and what version
of hadoop you are working on so these
are the main differences between apache
pig and mapreduce what are the different
ways of executing pig script so you
could create a script file store it in
dot pic or dot text and then you could
execute it using the pic command you
could be bringing up the grunt shell
that is pig's shell now that usually
starts with mapreduce mode but then we
can also bring it up in a local mode and
we can also run pig embedded as an
embedded script in other programming
language so these are the different ways
of executing your big script now what
are the major components of pig
execution environment this is this is a
very common question interviewers would
always want to know different components
of hive different components of pig even
different components which are involved
in hadoop ecosystem so when we want to
learn about major components of big
execution environment here are some so
you have pig scripts now that is written
in pig latin using built-in operators
and user-defined functions and submitted
to the execution environment that's what
happens when you would want to process
the data using pic now there is a parser
which does type checking and checks the
syntax of the script the output of
parser is a tag direct cyclic graph so
block and wikipedia for dag so dag is
basically a sequence of steps which run
in one direction then you have an
optimizer now this optimizer performs
optimization using merge transform split
etc it aims to reduce the amount of data
in the pipeline that's the whole purpose
of optimizer you have a internal
compiler so pick compiler converts the
optimized code into a mapreduce job and
here user need not know the mapreduce
programming model or how it works or how
it is written they all need to know
about running the pic script which would
be internally converted into a mapreduce
job and finally we have an execution
engine so mapreduce jobs are submitted
to the execution engine to generate the
desired results so these are major
components of pig execution environment
now let's learn about different complex
data types in pig supports various data
types
the main ones are tuple bag and map what
is tuple or tuple as you might have
heard a tuple is an ordered set of
fields which can contain different data
types for each field so in array you
would have multiple elements but that
would be of same types list can also
have different types your tuple is a
collection which has different fields
and each field can be of different type
now we could have an example as one
comma three or one comma three comma a
string or a float element and all of
that form a tuple bag is a set of tuples
so that's represented by curly braces so
you could also imagine this like a
dictionary which has various different
collection elements what is a map map is
a set of key value pairs used to
represent data so when you work in big
data field you need to know about
different data types which are supported
by pig which are supported by hive which
are supported in other components of
hadoop so tuple bag map array array
buffer you can think about list you can
think about dictionaries you can think
about map which is key value pair so
these are your different complex data
types other than the primitive data
types such as integer character string
boolean float and so on now what are the
various diagnostic operators available
in apache pic so these are some of the
operators or options which you can give
in a big script you can do a dumb now
dumb operator runs the pig latin scripts
and displays the result on the screen so
either i could do a dumb and see the
output on the screen or i can even do a
dump into and i could store my output in
a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator in pig and then
pigo also has different internal storage
like json loader or big storage which
can be used if you are working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or
seen on the screen you also have a
describe operator now that is used to
view the schema of a relation so you can
load the data and then you can view the
schema of relation using describe
operator explain as we might already
know displays the physical logical and
mapreduce execution plans normally in
rdbms when we use x-plane we would like
to see what happens behind the scenes
when a particular script or a query runs
so we could load the data using load
operator as in any other case and if we
would want to display the logical
physical and mapreduce execution plans
we could use explain operator there is
also an illustrate operator now that
gives the step-by-step execution of
sequence of statements so sometimes when
we would want to analyze our script to
see how good or bad they are or would
that really serve our purpose we could
use illustrate and again you can test
that by loading the data using load
operator and you could just use a
illustrate operator to have a look at
the step-by-step execution of the
sequence of statements which you would
want to execute so these are different
diagnostic operators available in apache
pic now if somebody asks state the usage
of group order by and distinct keywords
in big script so as i said pig is a
scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
variable or you can give some other name
and you can say group relation name by
age now say i have a file where i have
field various fields and one of the
field is a relation name so i could
group that by a different field order by
is used to display the contents of
relation in a sorted order whether
ascending or descending so i could
create a variable called relation two
and then i could say order relation name
one by ascending or descending order
distinct basically removes the duplicate
records and it is implemented only on
entire records not on individual records
so if you would like want to find out
the distinct values and relation name
field i could use district what are the
relational operators in pig so you have
various relational operators which help
data scientists or data analysts or
developers who are analyzing the data
such as co-group which joins two or more
tables and then performs group operation
on the join table result you have cross
it is used to compute the cross product
that is a cartesian product of two or
more relations
for each is basically to do some
iteration so if it will iterate through
tuples of a relation generating a data
transformation so for example if i say
variable a equals and then i load a file
in a and then i could create a variable
called b where i could say for each a i
would want to do something say group
join is to join two or more tables in a
relation limit is to limit the number of
output tuples or output results split is
to split the relation into two or more
relations union is to get a combination
that's it will merge the contents of two
or more relations and order is to get a
sorted result so these are some
relational operators which are
extensively used in pig for analysis
what is the use of having filters in
apache pick
now say for example i have some data
which has three fields year product
quantity and this is my phone sales data
so filter operator could be used to
select the required values from a
relation based on a condition it also
allows you to remove unwanted records
from data file so for example filter the
products where quantity is greater than
thousand so i see that i have
one row wherein are multiple rows where
the quantity is greater than thousand
such as 1500 1700 1200 so i could create
a variable called a i would load my file
using pix storage as i explained earlier
big storage is an internal parameter
which can be used to
specify the delimiters now here my
delimiter is comma so i could say using
pick storage as and then i could specify
the data type for each field so here
being integer product being character
array and quantity being integer then b
i could say filter a whatever we have in
a by quantity greater than thousand so
it's very concise it's very simple and
it allows us to extract and process data
in a simpler way now suppose there is a
file called test.txt
having 150 records in his dfs so this is
a file which is stored on his dfs and it
has 150 records where we can consider
every record being one line and if
somebody asks you to write a big command
to retrieve the first 10 records of the
file first we will have to load the data
so i could create a variable called test
underscore data and i would say load my
file using pick storage specifying the
delimiter as comma as and then i could
specify my fields whatever fields our
file have and then i would want to get
only 10 records for which i could use
the limit operator so i could say limit
on test data and give me 10 records this
is very simple and we can extract 10
records from 150 records which are
stored in the file on sdfs
now we have learnt on pig we have
learned some questions on hive you could
always look more in books like
programming in hive or programming in
pig and look for some more examples and
try out these examples on a existing
hadoop setup now let's learn on hbase
which is a nosql database now edge base
is a four dimensional database in
comparison to your rdbms which usually
are two dimensional so rdbms have rows
and columns but hbase has four
coordinates it has row key which is
always unique column family which can be
any number column qualifiers which can
again be any number per column family
and then you have a version so these
four coordinates make edge base a four
dimensional key value store or a column
family store which is unique for storing
huge amount of data and extracting data
from hbase there is a very good link
which i would suggest everyone can look
at if you would want to learn more on
hbase and you could just say hbase
mapper and this basically brings up a
documentation which is from mapr but
then that's not specific to mapper and
you can look at this link which will
give you a detailed explanation of edge
base how it works what are the
architectural components and how data is
stored and how it makes hbase a very
powerful nosql database so let's learn
on some of the important or critical
questions on hbase which might be asked
by the interviewer in an interview when
you are applying for a big data admin or
a developer position role so what are
the key components of edge base now as i
said this is one of the favorite
questions of interviewers where they
would want to understand your knowledge
on different components for a particular
service hbase as i said is a nosql
database and that comes as a part of
service with cloudera or hortonworks and
with apache hadoop you could also set up
hbase as an independent package so what
are the key components of hbase hbase
has a region server now edge base
follows the similar kind of topology
like hadoop now hadoop has a master
process that is name node and slave
processes such as data nodes and
secondary name node in the same way
hbase also has a master which is h
master and the slave processes are
called region servers so these region
servers are usually co-located with data
nodes however it is not mandatory that
if you have 100 data nodes you would
have 100 region servers so it purely
depends on admin so what does this
region server contain so region server
contains hbase tables that are divided
horizontally into regions or you could
say group of rows is called regions so
in edge base you have two aspects one is
group of columns which is called column
family and one is group of rows which is
called regions now these regions or
these rows are grouped based on the key
values or i would say row keys which are
always unique when you store your data
in each base you would have data in the
form of rows and columns so group of
rows are called regions or you could say
these are horizontal partitions of the
table so a region server manages these
regions on the node where a data node is
running a region server can have up to
thousand regions it runs on every node
and decides the size of region so region
server as i said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing hbase
data on the node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
co-located with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of edge
base as i said you have hp h master so
you would always have a connection
coming in from a client or an
application what does hmaster do it
assigns regions it monitors the region
servers it assigns regions to region
servers for load balancing and it cannot
do that without the help of zookeeper so
if we talk about components of hbase
there are three main components you have
zookeeper you have edge master and you
have region server region server being
the slave process your edge master being
the master process which takes care of
all your table operations assigning
regions to the region servers taking
care of read and write requests which
come from client and for all of this
edge master will take help of zookeeper
which is a centralized coordination
service so whenever a client wants to
read or write or change the schema or
any other metadata operations it will
contact hmaster edge master internally
will contact zookeeper so you could have
hbase setup also in high availability
mode where you could have a active edge
master than a backup edge master you
would have a zookeeper quorum which is
the way zookeeper works so zookeeper is
a centralized coordination service which
will always run with a quorum of
processes so zookeeper would always run
with odd number of processes such as 3 5
and 7 because zookeeper works on the
concept of majority consensus now
zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service is keeping a track
of all the servers which are alive
available and also keeps a track of
their status for every server with
zookeeper is monitoring zookeeper keeps
a session alive with that particular
server each master would always check
with zookeeper which region servers are
available alive so that regions can be
assigned to the region server at one end
you have region server which are sending
their status to the zookeeper indicating
if they are ready for any kind of read
or write operation and at other end h
master is querying the zookeeper to
check the status now zookeeper
internally manages a meta table now that
meta table will have information of
which regions are residing on which
region server and what row keys those
regions contain so in case of a read
activity hmaster will query zookeeper to
find out the region server which
contains that meta table once edge
master gets the information of meta
table it can look into the meta table to
find out the row keys and the
corresponding region servers which
contain the regions for those row keys
now if we would want to understand row
key and column families in each base
let's look at this and it would be good
if we could look this on an excel sheet
so row key is always unique it acts as a
primary key for any hbase table it
allows a logical grouping of cells and
make sure that all cells with the same
row key are co-located on the same
server so as i said you have four
coordinates for hbase you have a row key
which is always unique you have column
families which is nothing but group of
columns and when i say column families
one column family can have any number of
columns so when i talk about h base h
base is four dimensional and in terms of
edge base it is also called as a column
oriented database which basically means
that every row in one column could have
a different data type now you have a row
key which uniquely identifies the row
you have column families which could be
one or many depending on how the table
has been defined and a column family can
have any number of columns or i could
say for every row within a column family
you could have different number of
columns so i could say for my row one i
could just have two columns such as name
and city within the column family for my
row 2 i could have name city age
designation salary for my third row i
could have thousand columns and all that
could belong to one column family so
this is a horizontally scalable database
so column family consists of group of
columns which is defined during table
creation and each column family can have
any number of column qualifiers
separated by a delimiter now a
combination of row key column family
column qualifier such as named city h
and the value within the cell is makes
the hbase a unique four dimensional
database for more information if you
would want to learn on hbase please
refer this link which is hbase mapper
and this gives a complete hbase
architecture that is three components of
name node
three components that is name node
region servers and zookeeper how it
works how each base edge master
interacts with zookeeper what zookeeper
does in coordination how are the
components working together and how does
hbs take care of read and write coming
back and continuing why do we need to
disable a table so there are different
table operations what you can do in each
base and one of them is disabling a
table now if you would want to check the
status of table you could check that by
is disabled and giving the table name
order is enabled and the table name so
the question is why do we need to
disable a table now if we would want to
modify a table or we are doing some kind
of maintenance activity in that case we
can disable the table so that we can
modify your changes settings when a
table is disabled it cannot be accessed
through the scan command now if we have
to write a code to open a connection in
hbase now to interact with hbase one
could either use a graphical user
interface such as hue or you could be
using the command line hb shell or you
could be using hbase admin api if you
are working with java or say happy base
if you are working with python where you
may want to open a connection with hbase
so that you can work with it based
programmatically in that case we have to
create a configuration object that is
configuration my conf and then create a
configuration object and then you can
use different classes like edge table
interface to work on a new table you
could use h column qualifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbase admin api what does replication
mean in terms of hbase so edge base as i
said works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one edge based
cluster to another hbase cluster so this
replication feature in edge base
provides a mechanism to copy data
between clusters or sync the data
between different clusters this feature
can be used as a disaster recovery
solution that provides high availability
for hbase so if i have a hbase cluster
one where i have one master than
multiple region servers running in a
hadoop cluster i could use the same
hadoop cluster to create a hbase replica
cluster or i could have a totally
different hbase replica cluster where my
intention is that if things are changing
in a particular table in cluster one i
would want them to be replicated across
different clusters so i could alter the
hbase table and set the replication
scope to one now a replication scope of
zero indicates that table is not
replicated but if we set the replication
to one we basically will have to set up
ah base cluster where we can replicate
hbase tables data from cluster one to
cluster so these are the commands which
can be used to enable replication and
then replicate the data of table across
clusters can we import and export in
hbase of course we can it is possible to
import and export tables from one hbase
cluster to other hbase cluster or even
within a cluster so we can use the hbase
export utility which comes in this
particular package give a table name and
then a target location so that will
export the data of hbase table into a
directory on sdfs then i could create a
different table which would follow some
kind of same definition as the table
which was exported and then i could use
import to import the data from the
directory on sdfs to my table if you
would want to learn more on hbase import
and export you could look at hbase
import operations let's search for the
link and this is the link where you
could learn more about hbase import
export utilities how you could do a bulk
import bulk export which internally uses
mapreduce and then you could do a import
and export into hbs tables moving
further what do we mean by compaction in
hbase now we all know that hbase is a
nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is written in hbase it
is first returned to what we call as
right ahead log and also to mem store
which is
write cache now once the data is written
in wall and your
mem store it is offloaded to form an
internal hbase format file which is
called h5 and usually these edge files
are very small in nature so we also know
that sdfs is good when we talk about few
number of larger files in comparison to
large number of smaller files due to the
limitation of name node's memory
compaction is process of merging hbase
files that is these smaller edge files
into a single large file this is done to
reduce the amount of memory required to
store the files and number of disk seeks
needed so we could have lot of edge
files which get created when the data is
written to hbase and these smaller files
can then be compacted through a major or
minor compaction creating one big edge
file which internally would then be
written to sdfs and sdfs format of
blocks that is the benefit of compaction
there is also a feature called bloom
filter so how does bloom filter work so
bloom filter or hbase bloom filter is a
mechanism to test whether a h file
contains a specific row or a row column
cell bloom filter is named after its
creator burton hovered bloom it is a
data structure which predicts whether a
given element is a member of a set of
data it provides an in-memory index
structure that reduces the disk reads
and determines the probability of
finding a row in a particular file this
is one of very useful features of edge
base which allows for faster access and
avoids disk seeks
does hbase have any concept of name
space so namespace is when you have
similar elements grouped together so
namespace yes hbase supports namespace
so namespace is a logical grouping of
tables analogous to a database in rdbms
so you can create hbase namespace to the
schema of rdbms database so you could
create a namespace by saying create
namespace and giving it a name and then
you could also list the tables within a
namespace you could create tables within
a specific namespace now this is usually
done in production environment where a
cluster might be multi-tenant cluster
and there might be different users of
the same nosql database in that case
admin would create specific namespace
and for specific namespace you would
have different directories on htfs and
users of a particular business unit or a
team can work on their hbase objects
within a specific name space this is a
question which is again very important
to understand about the rights or reads
so how does right ahead log wall help
when a region server crashes now as i
said when a write happens it will happen
into mem store and wall that is your
edit log or write a headlock so whenever
a write happens it will happen in two
places mem store which is the right
cache and wall which is a edit log only
when the data is written in both these
places and based on the limitation of
mem store the data will be flushed to
create an edge-based format file called
h-file these files are then compacted
and created into one bigger file which
will then be stored on sdfs and sdfs
data as we know is stored in the form of
blocks on the underlying data nodes so
if a region server hosting a mem store
crashes now where is region server
running that would be co-located with
data node so if a data node crashes or
if a region server which was hosting the
mem store write cache crashes data in
memory the data that in memory which was
not persisted is lost now how does hbase
recover from this as i said your data is
written into wall and mem store at the
same time hbase recovers against that by
writing to wall before the write
completes so whenever a write happens it
happens in mem store and wall at the
same time hbase cluster keeps a wall to
record changes as they happen and that's
why we call it as also an edit log if
hbase goes down or the node that goes
down the data that was not flushed from
mem store to edge file can be recovered
by replaying the right ahead lock and
that's the benefit of your edit log or
write ahead log now if we would have to
write hbase command to list the contents
and update the column families of a
table i could just do a scan and that
would give me complete data of a table
if you are very specific and if you
would want to look at a particular row
then you could do a get table name and
then give the row key however you could
do a scan to get the complete data of a
particular table you could also do a
describe to see what are the different
column families and if you would want to
alter the table and add a new column
family it is very simple you can just
say alter give the hbas table name and
then give you a new column family name
which will then be added to the table
what are catalog tables in hbase so as i
mentioned your zookeeper knows the
location of this internal catalog table
or what we call as the meta table now
catalog tables in edge base have two
tables one is edge based meta table and
one is
hyphen rule the catalog table edge base
meta exists as an hbase table and is
filtered out of hbase shells list
command so if i give a list command on
edge base it would list all the tables
which edge base contains but not the
meta table it's an internal table this
meta table keeps a list of all regions
in the system and location of hbase meta
stored in zookeeper so if somebody wants
to find out or look for particular rows
they need to know the regions which
contain that data and those regions are
located on region server to get all this
information one has to look into this
meta table however we will not be
looking into meta table directly we
would just be giving a write or a read
operation internally uh based master
queries the zookeeper zookeeper has the
information of where the meta table
exists and that meta table which is
existing on region server contains
information of row keys and the region
servers where those rows can be found
your root table keeps a track of
location of the meta table what is hot
spotting in edge base and how to avoid
hot spotting now this is a common
problem and always admin guys or guys
who are managing the infrastructure
would think about it so one of the main
idea is that edge base would be
leveraging the benefit of sdfs your all
read and write requests should be
uniformly distributed across all of the
regions in region servers otherwise
what's the benefit of having a
distributed cluster so you would have
your data stored across region servers
in the form of regions which are
horizontal partitions of the table and
whenever read and write requests happen
they should be uniformly distributed
across all the regions in the region
servers now hotspotting occurs when a
given region serviced by a region server
receives most or all of read write
request which is basically a unbalanced
way of read write operations now hotspot
can be avoided by designing the row key
in such a way that data being written
should go to multiple regions across the
cluster so you could do techniques such
as salting hashing reversing the key and
many other techniques which are employed
by users of hbase we need to just make
sure that when the regions are
distributed across region servers they
should be spread across region servers
so that your read and write request can
be satisfied from different region
servers in parallel rather than all read
and write request hitting the same
region server overloading the region
server which may also lead to the
crashing of a particular region server
so these were some of the important
questions of hbase and then there are
many more please refer to the link which
i specified in during my discussion and
that gives you a detailed explanation of
how each base works you can also look
into hp's definitive guide by o'reilly
or hbase in action and these are really
good books to understand about hbase
internals and how it works now that we
have learnt on hive which is a data
warehousing package we have learnt on
pig which is a scripting or a scripting
language which allows you to do data
analysis and we have learned some
questions on a nosql database just note
it that there are more than 225 nosql
databases existing in market and if you
would want to learn and know about more
nosql databases you can just go to
google and type no sql databases
org and that will take you to the link
which is for nosql databases and this
shows there are more than 225
nosql databases existing in market and
these are for different use cases used
by different users and for with
different features so have a look at
this link now when you talk about data
ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which i would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
ingestion tools so when you talk about
different data injection tools some are
for structured data some are for
streaming data some are for data
governance some are for data ingestion
and transformation and so on so have a
look at this link which also gives you a
comparison of different data ingestion
tools so here let's learn about some
questions on scope which is one of the
data injection tools mainly used for
structured data or you could say data
which is coming in from rdbms or data
which is already structured and you
would want to ingest that you would want
to store that on hdfs which could then
be used for hive which could be used for
any kind of processing using mapreduce
or hive or pig or spark or any other
processing frameworks or you would want
to load that data into say high voltage
based tables scope is mainly for
structured data it is extensively used
when organizations are migrating from
rdbms to a big data platform and they
would be interested in ingesting the
data that is doing import and export of
data from rdbms to sdfs or vice versa so
let's learn about some important
questions on scope which you may be
asked by an interviewer when you apply
for a big data related position how is
scoop different from flume so this is a
very common question which is asked
scoop which is mainly for structured
data so scope works with rdbms it also
works with nosql databases to import and
export data so you can import data into
sdfs you can import data into data
warehousing package such as hive
directly or also in hbase and you could
also export data from hadoop ecosystem
to your rdbms however when it comes to
flow flow is more of a data injection
tool which works with streaming data or
unstructured data so data which is
constantly getting generated for example
log files or metrics from server or some
chat messenger and so on so if you are
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or hbase you could be
using flu there could be other tools
also like kafka or storm or chokwa or
some
knife i and so on scoop however is
mainly for structured data your loading
data in scope is not event driven so it
is not based on event it basically works
on data which is already stored in rdbms
in terms of flume it is completely event
driven that is as the messages or as the
events happen as the data is getting
generated you can have that data
ingested using flow scope works with
structured data sources and you have
various scope connectors which are used
to fetch data from external data
structures or rdbms so for every rdbms
such as mysql oracle db2 microsoft sql
server you have different connectors
which are available flume it works on
fetching streaming data such as tweets
or log files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms flume is then used for streaming
data now you could have one to one one
too many or many to one kind of relation
so in terms of floom you have components
such as your source sync and channel
that's the main difference between your
scope and flow what are the different
file formats to import data using scope
well there are lots and lots of formats
in which you can import data into scope
when you talk about scope you can have
delimited text file format now that's
the default import format it can be
specified explicitly using as text file
argument so when i want to import data
from an rdbms i could get that data in
sdfs using different compression schemes
or in different formats using the
specific arguments so i could specify an
argument which will write string based
representation of each record to output
files with delimiters between individual
columns and rows so that is the default
format which is used to import data
using scope so to learn more about your
scope and different arguments which are
available you can click on
scoop.apache.org
you can look into the documentation and
i would suggest choosing one of the
versions and looking into the user guide
and here you can search for arguments
and look for specific control arguments
which show how you can import data using
scope so here we have common arguments
and then you also have import control
arguments wherein we have different
options like getting data as avro as
sequence file as text file or k file
these are different formats you can also
get data in default compression scheme
that is gzip or you can specify
compression codec and then you can
specify what compression mechanism you
would want to use when you are importing
your data using scope when it comes to
default format for flume we could say
sequence file which is a binary format
that stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as java classes and scope
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scope you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as i mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
avro parquet sequence file that is
binary format or machine readable format
and then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if i look in
the content and here i could search for
a scoop based file where i have listed
down some examples so if i would want to
use different compression schemes here
are some examples have a look at these
so i'm doing a scoop import i'm also
giving an argument so that scope which
also triggers a map reduce job or i
would say map only job so when you run a
scoop import it triggers a map only job
no reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line
mapreduce.framework.name
so that you could run your map only job
in a local mode to save time or that
would interact with yarn and run a
full-fledged map only job we can give
the connection and then connect to
whatever rdbms we are connecting
mentioning the database name give your
username and password give the table
name give a target directory or it would
create a directory same as the table
name which would work only once and then
i could say minus z to get data in a
compressed format that is gzip or i
could be specifying compression codec
and then i could specify what
compression codec i would want to use
say snappy pz lz4 default i could also
run a query by giving a scope import and
when i'm specifying a query if you
notice i have not given any table name
because that would be included in the
query i can get my data as a sequence
file format which is a binary format
which will create a huge file so we
could also have compression enabled and
then i could say the output of my map
job should use a compression at record
level for my data coming in sequence
file so sequence file or a binary format
supports compression at record level or
at block level i could get my data in an
avro file where data has embedded schema
within the file or a parquet file also
so these are different ways in which you
can set up different compression schemes
or you can even get data in different
formats and you could be doing a simple
scope import for these looking further
what is the importance of eval tool in
scope so there is something called as
eval tool so scoop eval tool allows
users to execute user defined queries
against respective database servers and
preview the result in the console so
either i could be running a straight
away query to import the data into my
sdfs or i could just use scoop eval
connect to my external rdbms specify my
username and password and then i could
be giving in a query to see what would
be the result of the query which we
intend to import now let's learn about
how scope imports and exports data
between rdbms and
with its architecture so rdbms as we
know has your database structures your
tables which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scope import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scope lib folder so
scope import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks
now that depends on your scoop command
you could be specifying that you would
want to do a import only in one task or
in multiple tasks these multiple map
tasks will then run on a section of data
from rdbms and then store it in sdfs
so at high level we could say scoop will
introspect database to get gathered the
metadata it divides the input data set
into splits and this division of data
into splits mainly happens on primary
key column of the table now if somebody
might ask what if my table in rdbms does
not have a primary key column then when
you are doing a scope import either you
will have to import it using one mapper
task by specifying hyphen hyphen m
equals one or you would have to say
split by parameter to specify a numeric
column from rdbms and that's how you can
import the data let me just show you a
quick example on this so i could just
look in again into the scoop command
file and here we could be looking at an
example so if you see this one here we
are specifying minus minus m equals 1
which basically means i would want to
import the data using one map task now
in this case whether the table has a
primary key column or does not have a
primary key column will not matter but
if i say a minus minus ms6 where i am
specifying multiple map tasks to be
imported then this will look for a
primary key column in the table which
you are importing now if the table does
not have a primary key column then i
could be specifying a split by and then
specify the column so that the data
could be split into multiple chunks and
multiple map tasks could take it
now if the second scenario is your table
does not have a primary key column and
it does not have a numeric column on
which you could do a split by in that
case and if you would want to use
multiple mappers you could still say
split by on a textual column but you
will have to add this property so that
it allows splitting the data which is
non-numeric
all of these options are given in the
scoop apache.org link going further how
scoop imports and exports data between
rdbms and sdfs with its architecture so
as i said it submits the map only job to
the cluster and then it basically does a
import or export so if we are exporting
the data from sdfs in that case again
there would be a map only job it would
look at multiple splits of the data
which is existing which your map only
job would process through one or one
table map task and then export it to
rdbms suppose you have a database testdb
in mysql we if somebody asked you to
write a command to connect this database
and import tables to scoop so here is a
quick example as i showed you in the
command file so you could say scoop
import this is what we would want to do
you connect using jdbc now this will
only work if the jdbc connector already
exists within your scope lib directory
admin has to set up that so you can
connect to your rdbms you can point to
the database so
here our database name is test
underscore db i could give username and
then either i could give password on the
command line or just say capital p so
that i could be prompted for the
password and then i could give the table
name which i would want to import i
could also be specifying minus minus m
and specify how many map tasks do i want
to use for this import as i showed in
previous screen how to export a table
back to rdbms now for this we need the
data in a directory on hdfs so for
example there is a department's table in
retail database which is already
imported into scoop and you need to
export this table back to rdbms so this
is the content of the table now create a
new department table in rdbms so i could
create a table specifying the column
names whether that supports null or no
if that has a primary key column which
is always recommended and then i can do
a scope export i can connect to the
rdbms specifying my username and
password specify the table into which
you want to export the data and then you
give export directory pointing to a
directory on sdfs which contains the
data this is how you can export data
into table seeing example on this so i
could again look into my file and here i
have an example of import this is where
you are importing data directly into
hive and you have scope import where you
are importing data directly into hbase
table and you can then query your hbase
table to look at the data you could also
do a export by running your map only job
in a local mode connecting to the rdbms
specifying your username specifying the
table where you would want to export and
the directory on sdfs where you have
kept the relevant data this is a simple
example of export looking further
what is the role of jdbc driver in scoop
setup so as i said if you would want to
use scoop to connect to an external
rdbms we need the jdbc odbc connector
jar file now one or admin could download
the jdbc connector jar file and then
place the jar file within the scoop lib
directory wherever scoop is installed
and this jdbc connector jar file
contains a driver now jdbc driver is a
standard java api which is used for
accessing different databases in rdbms
so this connector jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class
and this driver class enables the
connection between your rdbms and your
hadoop structure each database vendor is
responsible for writing their own
implementation that will allow
communication with the corresponding
database and we need to download the
drivers which allow our scope to connect
to external rdbms so your jdbc driver
alone is not enough to connect to scope
we also need connectors to interact with
different database so a connector is a
plugable piece that is used to fetch
metadata and allow scoop to overcome the
differences in sql dialects so this is
how connection can be established so
normally your admins would when they are
setting up scope and hadoop they would
download
say mysql jdbc connector and this is how
they would go to the mysql connectors if
you are connecting to mysql similarly
for your other rdbms you could be say
going in here
you could be looking for a previous
version depending you could be going for
platform independent and then you could
be downloading the connected jar file
now if you enter this jar file you would
see a mysql connector jar and if we look
in com.mysql.jdbcom.mysql.jdbc.driver
so this is the package which is within
the connector jar file and this
has the driver class which allows the
connection of your scope with your rdbms
so these things will have to be done by
your admin so that you can have your
scope connecting to an external rdbms
now how do you update the columns that
are already exported so if i do a export
and i put my data in rdbms can i really
update the columns that are already
exported yes i can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
remains the same the only thing i will
have to specify now is the table name
your fields terminated by if you have a
specific delimiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in rdbms
what is code gen so scope commands
translate into your mapreduce job or map
only job so code gen is basically a tool
in scope that generates data access
objects dao java classes that
encapsulate and interpret imported
records so if i do a scoop code gen
connect to an rdbms using my username
and give a table this will generate a
java code for employee table in the test
database so this code gen can be useful
for us to understand what data we have
in this particular table finally can
scoop be used to convert data in
different formats i think i already
answered that right if no which tools
can be used for this purpose so scoop
can be used to convert data in different
formats and that depends on the
different arguments which you use when
you do a import such as avro file
parquet file binary format with record
or block level compression so if you are
interested in knowing more on different
data formats then i think i can suggest
a link for that and we can say hadoop
formats
i think it is tech
maggie avro
parque let's see you can find out the
link take mac e yeah this is a very good
link which specifies or talks about
different data formats which you should
know such as your text file format
different compression schemes how is
data organization what are the common
formats what do you have in text file
structured binary sequence files with
compression without compression what is
record level what is block level what is
a avro data file what is a square what
is a
parquet data file or a columnar format
and other formats like orc rc and so on
so please have a look at this
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on big data engineer full
course i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will help
you solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you